oh there are not
the public order emergency commission is
now in session today
good morning bonjour
yes sister
thanks very much David ninjakovski for
the Ottawa Police Service I have a
preliminary matter to raise and I'm
seeking your direction it concerns the
testimony of the panel of witnesses who
are going to be appearing later today so
I'm happy I just wanted to alert you uh
of it I've advised my friends that
commission Council and I'm in your hands
as whether you want me to raise it now
or wait till the witness witness has
finished her cross-examination
cute white suggest we deal with it after
the witnesses is has finished if that
unless there's an urgency and I think
perhaps just have you advised the
parties of of the issue
I advised um commission Council uh
yesterday and I heard back and we've had
some discussions uh so certainly
commission council is aware of our
position I have not had and I heard back
from commission Council this morning and
so I have not yet advised
my colleagues
of the issue okay uh it it might be
worthwhile and I don't know if you can
do it by email or you want to do do it
orally but just
give a heads up to the parties so that
when we get to it everybody will be have
thought it through
um if that's okay sure thank you very
much okay and we can deal with that uh a
bit later but I'd suggest we
complete this and move on to the uh that
issue once we complete
and they switch okay so unless there's
anything further uh we can start the
cross-examinations and I believe the
first is the government of Canada
and I I can but uh go ahead
it is not a problem with me so uh go
ahead Mr Chow
foreign
I just have another matter Mr
commissioner later this morning
uh good morning Miss Leach uh
my name is Paul champ I'm lawyer for the
Ottawa Coalition of residents and
businesses and I have some questions for
you concerning your testimony yesterday
uh now I want to start with something I
misledge that and we both agree on uh
you're not a national security threat in
any way
I don't believe I am no
and I also want to make sure that we're
clear on the record uh I as you know
I've I've been able to see a lot of the
financial information and so forth and
other proceedings and so forth and uh
you did everything you could to keep
track of that money and deal with it
responsibly the money that was going
through you absolutely yes sir and uh in
no way did you ever divert any of that
money towards yourself and properly and
I'm saying that that's that's what I've
seen you've dealt very responsibly in
every way you could with the money yes
sir
and you also testified yesterday you
wanted to come to Ottawa for the right
reasons uh and by that I mean you wanted
to organize with other people uh uh
bring people together over that issue
that that was important to you and send
a message to the government uh and to
your fellow Canadians that's what you
wanted to do and coming to Ottawa yes
sir
and you testified yesterday that you
originally thought you just you wanted
to drive across Canada
stand in front of parliament with some
signs and you thought that's what the
protest would be is that right I yes
essentially I had no idea that it was
going to become what what it evolved
into yes for sure
um but then once the enormous amounts of
money started flowing in uh through
through GoFundMe
um and you know people were energized
around that uh
it opened up other options of what this
protest could could look like is that
fair
I believe that everyone that that was
involved and that joined was was in it
to be listened to be have their voices
heard as far as the mandates and the
restrictions and the lockdowns went
but it made other things possible like
you you were able to get the stages and
the sound system and uh the resources to
to cover Fuel and so forth for a much
longer period than you had originally
anticipated correct
that the the donations that came into
GoFundMe as we specified in the
description was for fuel to get them to
Ottawa and home right so yeah yeah so
but once you had a lot more that opened
up options that you could keep getting
fuel to the trucks for a while while
they were here that was part of the idea
I guess that's fair
and
um
we saw some or I've read a news story
about some texts that you had with Mr
Barber yeah I presume you're aware of
aware of the news story in those texts
yes I am and in those texts it's my
understanding that you had some
exchanges uh with Mr Barber on or about
January 30th
um about a strategy meeting uh at the
command center about gridlocking Ottawa
can you tell us about that
well I can tell you what I remember
which obviously isn't much gridlock is
not a term that I would normally use so
um and as the text message clearly
states uh that that was not up to me
that was not never something that we
advocated for sure so and you have to
understand that there was lots of times
where we would have meetings but we'd go
in there and have a meeting about
something totally different right
but there was a talk about that is that
this is should be the strategy going
forward is keeping the trucks in the
streets uh gridlocking downtown that was
part of the strategy at that point no
no we never wanted to gridlock the city
uh it was always as I said especially as
we saw the momentum growing and the
support that we were getting uh safety
became our number one priority and as
you heard Mr marazzo testify that was
especially important to him having a son
that that made frequent ambulance trips
to the hospital
right unfortunately we heard that he
didn't necessarily know about all the
streets he didn't know about Kent Street
for example which even Mr Barbara
acknowledged was shut down the whole
time
um so but you didn't have any visibility
into that that wasn't part of your
responsibility okay
now I want to ask you some questions
about the horns you testified yesterday
that at some point even for you the
horns became a bit too much uh you
couldn't even carry on a conversation on
the sidewalk when all those trucks were
blaring that at times yes yeah and um
the uh I think I'd seen
a video Once where you're talking when
when all the semi trucks when they blow
their horns it's it's just crazy that
was that was the experience was it not
well I think that's taken out of context
are you referring to the video that I
made yes yeah and I believe I said it
was music to my ears that was within a
couple of days of getting there and
there was a lot of excitement and
uh it was a very jovial atmosphere
but
Ms leech I know you strike me as a very
reasonable person you'd agree with me
that uh you know having a big rig a
semi-truck idling uh right in front of
your house
24 hours a day emitting
diesel fumes honking horns prolonged
periods during all day sometimes at
night that's not reasonable to a person
that lives there would you agree
as I said yesterday when I was in my
hotel room I didn't really notice it
the horns honking and and I was right
downtown
but you wouldn't want a big rig to pull
up for example in front of your parents
home and park and idle for 24 hours a
day for several weeks honking their horn
you wouldn't want that would you miss
leech
well Mr champ my ex-husband was a tool
push on a drilling rig and I've spent
many times many days on the site of a
drilling rig and there's a lot of diesel
fumes and there's a lot of noise yeah
it's not pleasant is it
it is it is what it is yeah but then you
get to go home and you get to get away
from that noise and those diesel fumes
right uh not when you're living on on
site nope
now I want to ask you some questions
about the injunction we uh
on February 4th to the 5th you heard
about that there was a motion from the
the residents of Ottawa to get an
injunction to to stop the the horn
honking correct yes
and uh we heard from Mr Wilson a bit
about that that there was a meeting of
the board or the leadership group about
what to do and there was a decision to
oppose the injunction correct I've never
opposed the injunction well you sworn
affidavit to oppose the injunction Ms
Leach let's let's be clear on that well
once it was imposed of course we weren't
going to go against the injunction well
no there was a court hearing on Monday
February the 7th where Mr Wilson
represented you and Mr Barber and Mr
Victor who were named individuals on it
to oppose the injunction you were you
weren't aware that that's that's what
the position you were taking I don't
recall that but if you say so then and
you swore an affidavit and support uh of
that position which I should say sworn
affidavit that the injunction should not
be granted
if you say so I've sworn a lot of
affidavits so if you say so is it fair
to say there's a lot going on there was
a lot going on it was hard to follow all
the different things that were happening
yes and you may not have known exactly
what what the team was doing on some of
those issues
um I guess that's fair to say okay now
Mr Wilson told us yesterday that on the
board there were some who there was a
bit of division on the board some felt
that yeah the horns are a bit too much
you know maybe we shouldn't oppose this
injunction and some were like no we we
should oppose it do you recall that
meeting
I was probably there but as I said I was
in and out of a lot of meetings so I
don't recall that specifically okay and
you testified yesterday that once the
injunction was issued you worked very
hard or worked really hard to see that
it was adhered to you recall your
testimony yeah the truck captains did
for sure yes right
right um but you yourself you didn't do
anything directly uh to ensure that the
the order was adhered to did you I don't
believe I did no no you didn't post any
videos or make any statements on your
social media account attempting to
discourage the truckers from blowing
their horns uh my Facebook page was
um deleted about the first week we were
here
but you didn't put up anything on it
before it was done no I did not no
and um you also you never posted a copy
uh of the Court's injunction order or
the terms of it in any way on any of
your social media correct I don't
believe so no and uh were you aware that
there that was a term of the court order
that you were supposed to do that I
don't believe so okay so Mr Wilson may
not have communicated that to you he may
have
um again it was it was very chaotic
times
now February 4th
uh that's Friday that was the foreign
I'm sure your days were crazier than
mine but uh I have a bit of a sense of
what you're going through
um February Friday for Friday February
the fourth that's the day that GoFundMe
issued this statement saying they're
shutting off the shutting down the um
the fundraiser and they were going to
return all the money to the donors you
recall that day I do
and uh when GoFundMe shuts you down you
you lost what was potentially access to
10 million dollars correct correct
and GoFundMe put out a statement that
day saying quote uh this previously
peaceful demonstration has become an
occupation do you recall that I do
and by that point uh you would also I
gathered been following some of the news
stories some of the reporting talking
about the negative impact that the
protest was having on residents you know
caused by the blocking streets and the
honking were you following that I didn't
have a lot of time to read the news to
tell you the truth
and on that Friday February 4th uh after
GoFundMe took away that 10 million
dollars you learned later that day that
you were being sued for 10 million
dollars is that right yeah it was
probably around that same time yes
uh so that was a bit of a rotten day
losing 10 million being sued for 10
million
uh you could say that I guess yes
um now did you consider or talk about
with anyone else maybe working on an
exit strategy at that point
we've been in talks about that was
shortly after the legal team arrived
actually
and and after that one day when GoFundMe
shuts you down uh did um
did you
would that have been a time for you to
start thinking about shutting down the
protest or coming up of saying hey guys
we sent our message and going home was
that ever part of the discussion
not to my knowledge as I said yesterday
we were waiting to be acknowledged by
somebody in the federal government who
was willing to come and listen to what
we had to say right
but and but you told us yesterday also
another factor is that the the lawyers
from the Justice Center for
constitutional freedoms they had showed
up and they were they were giving you
good advice they were supporting him by
that point is that right yes sir they've
been there a day or two by that time yes
sir and is it fair to say that without
them you might have considered packing
it in
that's really hard to say
so on the Friday February the 4th
GoFundMe shuts you down you're sued for
10 million dollars uh then uh on the
Sunday February the 6th the city of
Ottawa declared a state of emergency do
you recall that yes
and then the next day on Monday the 7th
the court issued the horn injunction
um so did you start thinking then or was
there any discussions then but maybe
maybe the protests should start packing
it in
there might have been I know again to
reiterate we were very focused on on
being heard and having our concerns
listened to
and then on February the 11th Premier
Ford in Ontario they declared a state of
emergency about what was happening in
Ottawa you recall that not specifically
the date but I do recall that happening
yes
weren't you getting the message you
testified yesterday uh Miss Leach that
well no one told you to leave the police
weren't telling you to leave uh all of
these things uh you know the premier the
mayor the courts GoFundMe that wasn't a
message the the city of Ottawa residents
suing that wasn't a message that maybe
it was time to leave
well we had a message too
yeah
and so
and that was that was more important
than what
the people stories that I heard coming
across Canada
that were absolutely heartbreaking after
two years of lockdowns and restrictions
now you reached the deal with the mayor
around Sunday the 12th I believe yes 13.
13th I think something like that that's
right and uh the freedom Convoy put out
a statement about the deal you recall
that yes I do and in the statement you
said things like you never wanted to to
impact the the residents of downtown
Ottawa that's correct and you wanted to
agree to the deal to relieve the
pressure on the people in downtown
Ottawa absolutely sir right because
there had been pressure on the people of
downtown Ottawa by that point well as I
said we didn't want to create a big
disruption to them we wanted to be
respectful to the citizens of Ottawa for
sure because from January 29 until
February the 13th you you recognize it
wasn't very respectful to the people of
downtown Ottawa well what I will say is
that I was approached by hundreds of
Ottawa citizens who had come out to
support I was approached by federal
government employees who were donating
items to the to the protesters
um
we had a lot of support in Ottawa
from the Ottawa citizens except for
those that were suing you I guess I
guess yeah and the mayor who who was
elected by the citizens of Ottawa he
apparently wasn't supportive of you
staying in downtown
he wasn't and gave him great credit for
be willing for being willing to sit and
talk to us yeah and let's just be clear
here Mr Ms leech no one was asking you
to leave completely it was about moving
the trucks and having the truck stock
idling out in front of residences and
blowing the horns all night and day that
was the big message wasn't it yes
foreign
now you testified yesterday that um once
the emergencies act was issued and it
looks like there was going to be a ction
law enforcement moving in uh you
testified that you encouraged people to
leave is that right that's correct uh
but you didn't do that on social media
in any way correct I did not so it's
just people who you saw face to face you
were telling them to leave yes primarily
are people from our team also you didn't
uh you didn't think maybe it would be
better you had so much influence uh on
on people who were here in Ottawa
protesting that you should put it out on
social media that hey you guys maybe
it's time for us to leave
I I obviously I didn't
well and obviously another thing that
you did Miss leech is uh from I
understand your testimony yesterday uh
you suspected you're about to be
arrested and you went out to the street
to ask the police officers or have
someone ask the police officers if
they're looking for you right yes that's
true and you went out with someone uh
who could record the arrest when it
occurred right
everybody has a cell phone these days
for sure and when you were arrested I
didn't hear commission counsel ask you
this but uh as you were being arrested
you were yelling hold the line correct
yes well the the one of the road
captains that I was with said it and I
repeated it back to him yes right uh and
by that statement I take it you weren't
encouraging the other protesters to
leave Ottawa were you you were
encouraging them to stay to hold the
line correct
well you know that's a matter of
perspective my perspective on hold the
line means stay true to your values in
the face of diversity
right
but uh you'd agree with me was leech
that some people uh who are protesting
who are following you at that time when
they saw that message they would have
interpreted to hold the line to to stay
Hold the Line don't leave Ottawa some
might have interpreted that way would
you agree
I can't speak for what how what other
people think
you don't think that's re well when you
speak and you've got that kind of a
platform you recognize that people are
listening to you have a great deal of
influence on those people
well again it comes down to how you
define the term I suppose
so just assist me this message I'm just
I'm trying to reconcile when you're
telling us that you were encouraging
people to leave but you didn't put
anything out on social media but then uh
you were with only one or two people at
time you arrested uh someone that you
know you knew who recorded that video
Don't you I do yes yeah you know that
person personally I do yeah yeah and so
uh they recorded it uh you you were
aware you saw them recording right yes I
did and then you yell Out Hold the Line
because you wanted the people to stay in
downtown Ottawa is that right again I
was repeating what one of the road
captains had said to me
Ms Lee just uh one last Point
um for for for
reasons that remain utterly unclear to
me commission Council asked you
yesterday about the impact of your
arrest and your charges against you and
I just want to make clear you weren't
charged with an offense under the
emergencies act were you it's my
understanding you've been charged under
the criminal code I believe so yes all
under the criminal code right you were
charging the criminal code for mischief
and charge for uh an interference with
lawful use and enjoyment both under the
criminal code is that right
Mischief counseling Mischief
intimidation counseling intimidation and
a few more right but no offense under
the emergencies act no and uh the
indictment talks about activities from
February the 7th up till February I
think 19th or the date that you arrested
is that right
perhaps or the start of the date is
before the invocation the emergencies
act right I'm not sure
okay next is the government of Canada
thank you commissioner good morning Miss
Leach good morning I'm Andrea gonsalves
I'm one of the lawyers for the
government of Canada
and you've told us in your evidence that
you were not
um one of the founders of the freedom
Convoy uh but you became involved
because you wanted to help yes ma'am
um and primarily your your role was
fundraising and you were quite
successful with that right yes
um you you told us you're not a trucker
you don't have a truck I do not
um and in the time you spent in Ottawa
there were obviously protesters truckers
who were sleeping in their trucks I
believe so yes uh but you didn't you
were staying in the hotels I was yes I
didn't have a truck here to sleep in
right and during that time you've told
us it was incredibly busy and surely
exhausting for you very much so uh Lots
going on you said you were in and out of
different meetings
briefings
um on various calls you were dealing
with the uh crowdfunding platforms
switching campaigns for instance yes
ma'am
um you were dealing with the funds being
frozen setting up bank accounts that all
took a lot of your time it did take some
time yes
and
setting up the finance committee and the
various Administration administrative
aspects that went along with that also
took portions of your time yes
um and you were through all of this
you've told us constantly meeting new
people there were new people arriving
all the time that wanted to meet with
you yes there was yes yeah lawyers
advisors accountants Canadians
um uh Mr Wilson the other jccf people Mr
Eros were just some of the names you
gave us right yes
um and you said this was a lot of
pressure for you you felt cold in
different directions I yeah there was
times when it was definitely very
chaotic and very crazy
and participated in many of the press
conferences you were getting put in
front of cameras yes ma'am
um uh people were putting you forward as
the leader Mr Wilson you'll recall
describing you as the spark that Lit the
fire I do recall that yes
and you also said people you felt at
times people didn't see you they just
saw the money uh yeah there was times
when I felt that way
and all of these dealings
um we're consuming a vast amount of your
time during the days and weeks you spent
in Ottawa yes yes it was you I gather in
all of this couldn't leave your hotel
very often
uh in the beginning in the early days no
um but as as the days wore on I was able
to get out and and to the crowds yeah
and occasionally and get out and talk to
the truckers and stuff like that
occasionally you spoke
um up in Parliament Hill I did yes
and you understand that the the protest
occupied quite a large physical
geographic area of Ottawa yes yeah um
Wellington right out to sjam yes we've
heard um Parliament South as far as
Somerset
I'll take your word for it I don't know
the streets are that well yet sure
enough and the evidence is in the record
um uh you've heard there was
um trucks parked in the streets by the
market in the Rito and Sussex area yes
um for a period of time in the early
days anyway they were out in
Confederation park there was an
encampment there yes I believe so and
the one out in uh Coventry Road at the
parking lot yes Stadium
as well as those that were a bit further
out of town
um 1500 Bronson Road were you aware of
that one I I'm not sure of the addresses
but there was someone at Town yes you've
said yesterday something about 88 that
would be exit 88 off of the 417. uh I
think it's by ambrum and sorry yeah yeah
I believe that's the one yes oh arm
prior you heard about Van cleeg Hill yes
yeah
um
and you with all the demands on your
time we're not spending the vast
majority of your time in any of those
places right you just couldn't I visited
them I visited them but yeah not as much
as I as I wanted to yeah
um and I think I've seen you here
throughout the hearing you've been here
almost daily yes ma'am
and we've heard some evidence about some
of the things that were going on in the
protest crowds
um I take it this was evidence you were
hearing information you were learning
for the first time like the threats to
the mayor of Ottawa
I didn't know he was receiving threats
you didn't know that Chief slowly had
received death threats no you didn't
know that Minister uh sorry Deputy
Minister Deputy Prime Minister Freeland
had received I learned of that uh the
other day a couple days ago and the
Prime Minister was receiving threats I
was also receiving death threats
um were you also learning for the first
time as you sat through this hearing
about numerous weapons related arrests
and connection with these protests or
did you know that I did hear something
about Coots but again I didn't follow
those stories that closely I I had I was
too busy here and
weapons related arrests in Ottawa
there I was far as I know there was no
weapons related okay well there's
there's been uh some evidence about that
and if if that's the case that would be
the first time you learned about that
yes I don't I don't recall hearing about
weapons no
um we've heard evidence about protesters
surrounding police and bylaw officers
who were trying to do their jobs is that
something you knew was going on at the
time no no
um and this uh document was introduced
into evidence Yesterday by my friend Mr
Diana but no one spoke to it so perhaps
we'll pull it up it's opp401819
it's a OPP intelligence report for
February
14th
um and if we could please scroll down to
page two
and just sorry the very first
paragraph there in February 14th of
course that's a big day uh that's the
day that the emergencies act invocation
was announced by the prime minister
right yes and the first bullet point
there says Ottawa Police Service
identified an online video in which a
driver at the blockade had made
inflammatory statements referencing
violence such as such as using a truck
as a weapon the video also showed him
displaying a protective vest which he
claimed would stop an armor piercing
round he claimed that it brought but he
brought it with him to protect himself
and that he had worn it at the blockade
uh OPP field officers have spoken with
this mail and his truck has been
positioned in front of Chateau Laurier
since the beginning of the protest
and I take it that's new information for
you as well that is new information for
me yes
you've you've testified in this
commission that you had to believe
everyone who was getting involved
was doing so for the right reasons that
they were joining with the best of
intentions and these are at least some
examples of people who maybe didn't have
the best of intentions right correct
which is why I continually was online
advocating for uh peace to remain
peaceful to abide by the law and to
respect our law enforcement right
um and in the various press conferences
and press releases that um you were
involved in and that were being put out
in the name of the freedom Convoy
um the message was repeatedly being
communicated that uh the Convoy was here
to stay in Ottawa until the mandates
were lifted right yes as long as that
took was the messaging yes yeah
um
and
uh you testified both yesterday and in
response to questions from Mr champ this
morning about the deal that uh the
exchange of letters that you engaged in
with mayor Watson
um
and as I understand the broad Strokes
um he sent a letter
to
your team with the assistance of Mr
Wilson
um you sent a letter
back or a letter was sent back in your
name right yes ma'am and let's pull up
that letter
it's hrf6045
while we're waiting or it's there but
while we're waiting for that um why did
the letter go in your name do you know
uh I was president of the board of
directors at that time
okay
and the letter that's written
in your name
um if we just go down to the
sorry a little too far third paragraph
starts we have made a plan
and you write we uh or the letter says
we have made a plan to consolidate our
best our protest efforts around
Parliament Hill
we will be working hard over the next 40
24 hours to get buy-in from the truckers
we hope to start repositioning our
trucks on Monday
and that's worded that way because at
that point the best that you could offer
the mayor was efforts to get buy-in from
the truckers right well we needed to go
out and speak to them and talk to them
about about what we thought was going to
be a good idea yes right and after these
um letters were
released publicly
we heard from Mr dector in his testimony
and I believe you testified that you
knew at the time from him that he had
received
many many many reactions uh on social
media from those who were unhappy with
this deal right yes yeah
um you also were aware that
Pat King had immediately put out his own
messaging
undermining this deal right yes
um
and it was important to you I take it to
make clear
that
what had been agreed to
was nothing more than moving the trucks
out of the residential
neighborhoods right
it was a step one that's how I viewed it
it was it was progress it was the more
progress than we'd seen since we arrived
you at that time
would not have put your name
on any letter that agreed to a meeting
if it meant you had to force protesters
to pack up and their protest and go home
right
sorry can you repeat that yeah
maybe I'll
do it a little differently the the
understanding you had with mayor Watson
was that you were going to make best
efforts to help get the trucks out of
the residential neighborhoods yes and
then he would sit down with you for a
meeting yes
you were not going to agree to a meeting
if it meant you had to tell all those
truckers get out of Ottawa end your
protest go home
sorry can you repeat that again please
you did not and you would not have
agreed to a meeting with the mayor
if the condition for that meeting was
that you and other
leaders would have to tell the
protesters
get out of Ottawa go home end your
protest
well that would have been something that
we would have had to talk about that's
well what if
and when you messaged this deal you
remember
um
Mr Wilson uh drafted up the freedom
manifest that was going to be used to
help communicate to the truckers what
exactly they were being asked to do and
what the deal was with the mayor right
um and so let's pull that up that's
hrf401285
foreign
this is a document you had reviewed and
you agreed with at the time right
and uh in the fourth paragraph what
you're communicating here is we have to
stay in Ottawa for the Long Haul to
reach our destination just like we do
every day with our rooting Logistics we
have to plan for the road ahead yes and
that's what you and freedom Corps were
saying to explain the deal to the
protesters that going along with what
was being asked moving those trucks out
of the residential core to other areas
in Ottawa
was a step necessary to make sure you
could continue your protest for the Long
Haul correct yes we definitely would
would have loved to have stayed and
continue to
protest peacefully
thank you those are my questions
thank you next is
[Music]
the Ottawa Police Service
good morning commissioner good morning
Miss Leach my name is David mitchikovsky
I'm a lawyer for the Ottawa Police good
morning
um you've been very clear in your
evidence that it was your intent to plan
a peaceful protest correct correct
and that was very important to you as
one of the organizers yes and you did
not plan to disrupt the lives of Ottawa
residents or businesses no
and you obviously consistent with that
obviously didn't plan to break bylaws
honk your horns continuously defecate on
people's Lawns harass people or block
emergency lanes that wasn't the plan was
it I did none of those things and it
wasn't the plan was it as one of the
organizers you wouldn't have been in
favor of condoning that kind of activity
would you no
and because it wasn't your plan and you
in fact had a code of conduct uh you
wouldn't have expected the police to
turn the Convoy away when they came to
Ottawa would you
no they were excellent to deal with
right from the start
um and if that had happened and none of
the trucks were allowed in we've heard
from Opp witnesses that that likely at
that point would not have deterred the
Convoy because some had driven from very
far away is that fair
if we had would have been told that we
couldn't have driven up here I I don't
believe that we would have we would have
found alternative places I guess I'm
saying that if when you got here on the
28th and the 29th the city was
barricaded and you couldn't go anywhere
the opp witness indicated that that
wouldn't have turned the truckers away
because they'd come pretty far for this
I don't know how to even answer that
question I guess if there was barricades
in place how could we how could we have
done that
um and no one from the Convoy organizers
to your knowledge was on social media
before the Convoy encouraging
anti-social Behavior
not to my knowledge right and you've
seen the Lawton book about the freedom
Convoy I have yes and in his book he
says that the Convoy organizers did not
intend to be on residential streets yes
and you would agree with that I would
agree with that
but in fact that is what happened
there was some residential streets that
had lots of trucks on them yes sir there
were staging areas uh but they were too
far away from parliaments and people
wanted to be closer correct a lot of
them did want to be closer but there was
also trucks that were out there too in
those locations yes
and you've been very clear in your the
affidavit you filed in court that there
were truckers who came from all over
yes sir and you indicated
um specifically in that affidavit which
is that we don't need to call it up but
for the record it's
jcf0012 in paragraph two and three that
you did not control the truckers
those are your words
yes you know we didn't they're all human
beings
I don't control anyone sir I open up a
dialogue with them you're agreeing with
me
I didn't control anyone
I'm sorry I did not control anyone you
didn't control the truckers no
um and superintendent uh Drummond
attended a meeting he's heard with um
some of your representatives on the 13th
of February that was after the date of
your letter with the mayor those were on
the 12th correct the meeting oh yeah
sorry the initial meeting was I believe
Friday yeah and so yes correct
okay and so the agreement with the mayor
was reached on the 12th of February I
believe so and then we saw that there
was a meeting on the 13th that I believe
Mr Wilson uh may have attended but the
mayor yes I believe office
and uh superintendent Drummond records
in his notes and again I'll give you the
reference but I in the interest of time
I won't call it up but it's Ops
14455 at page 47 the Convoy organizers
at the representatives at that meeting
explained that they did not control Rito
Sussex
I wasn't at that meeting but you're
aware that that was said right yes at
that okay and that your representatives
also said they didn't control Coventry
Road
yes
and so that and they also said they
could not be certain if the truckers
there would move
uh that's correct I believe yep and even
for those groups whom you did have some
control or influence on I guess
influence we've heard that truckers are
pretty independent-minded people yes
they are they can't be made to do what
they don't want to do
yeah I guess so and in addition to not
controlling the truckers you also did
not have control obviously of the
protesters on the street and whether
they could block trucks moving for
instance
uh we didn't have control but no and but
we worked very hard and very diligently
with the with the gentlemen and women
that were down there to open up a
dialogue and and
a system and opening up that
intersection and in fact we heard about
a previous effort by Mr Wilson and Ms
chippyuk on February 10th at Rideau and
Sussex where police were going to move
the barriers so trucks could mood but
the crowd Dynamics got in the way and
the crowd stopped the trucks from moving
because they didn't trust the police I
was down there also yes you were there
as well and so you saw that you agreed
that that would be dangerous then
I didn't feel like it was it was
dangerous there was a large crowd
presence there and they were
I think they were feeling that they had
been lied to by the police
uh there was a lot of mistrust there
and
um they were down there singing O Canada
enchanting freedom
and you agreed it would be dangerous to
move the trucks in that scenario
because the crowd swelled there was a
lot of people there yes yes and um we
have um heard that notice was given to
the demonstrators in advance that they
would have to leave you heard that
evidence
uh which which what are you referring to
you've heard quite a bit of that
evidence that demonstrators were told to
leave I have never been told to leave so
you didn't know that okay
um you're familiar with the plts correct
I am now
um I'm going to show you some PLT logs
and you understand that the plts were a
liaison with the protesters
Excuse me yes sir
and would communicate with them
yes sir
okay I'm going to call it up I'm not
going to start by taking you directly to
it but I will take you to a particular
passage of the document is uh Ops
uh one three zeros 14053
and so while that's being called up Ms
Leach those are PLT logs as of February
25th and I can take you through them in
detail and show you but in order to save
some time I'm going to attempt to
summarize what they say on the issue of
notice that was given to the truckers
and protesters before the public order
unit moved in to clear the intersection
and so what I see in those is on
February there were various zones in the
city
and I see on February 16th the plts
attended uh sjam and gave those present
the letter and were told by protesters
uh that the latter wasn't legal because
it didn't have a signature
that's sort of similar to what you said
exactly just excuse me a minute yes uh
if my friend could actually take the
witness to the part in the document that
states that so that we could see it I
don't know if that's what it says or not
I apologize I I will take her to it
where it's necessary if she doesn't
agree she doesn't agree that's fine I
don't wish to use my 15 minutes uh by
going through the document in detail if
she can't agree I will take her to
portions of it sure let's do that take
me to portions please
um so uh PLT say they attended sjam and
they were told by the truckers that it
wasn't legal that notice and it wasn't
uh significant do you know about that I
wasn't there sir okay do you have any
reason to deny that occurred as noted in
the PLT logs I have no reason to
okay and um I understand from those logs
that the next day on February 17th they
attended again and delivered the message
again
and they attended again on the 19th and
delivered it again to those who remained
any reason to deny that that occurred I
was not there as as a matter of fact by
the 19th I was already in jail okay and
so you weren't being uh you weren't on
the 17th
were you I was arrested that day yes
right and I'm pretty confident because
you were one of the organizers that the
truckers were communicating with you and
telling you what was happening
from sjam
all over the city
you know not necessarily
and then in zone two and this is on page
seven
of the same document
um Mr marazzo uh met the PLT on the 16th
and the message was delivered to him and
then it was delivered on Wellington
Street and the plts described hostile
and screaming at the police and the
police then had to withdraw due to the
hostility
any reason to disagree with that I was
not present there sir any reason to
disagree with it Sir with respect my
friends asking a witness who has no
knowledge of something whether or not
she disagrees with the document of which
she didn't draft of which was drafted by
the police and then asking if there's
any reason to disagree with something
she has no knowledge of that's not a
question sir that's permissible it's not
relevant
um this witness well this is all going
on was in jail without any form of
ability to access phones and texts Etc
it's not an appropriate line of question
uh the witness can answer if she was
aware of it or not she wasn't uh yeah I
don't I think it's quite proper
cross-examination I'm not sure it's very
helpful uh in the sense that
I'm not sure what you're getting at she
can neither confirm nor deny because she
has no knowledge right to say can she as
she and he
I mean any the the questions relating to
whether she received Communications
about any of this
may have some relevance and she's
answered that so
um well I mean I go ahead but you're
you're in my submission it is highly
relevant because the witness said that
no notice was given
and I'm going to suggest to you Ms Leach
that the plts went to every single site
and gave notice to everyone and you're
saying you didn't know that is that
right if you say so
okay
I'm going to ask that we turn up Ops 12
205
page 60.
yeah just at the top where it says Swiss
Hotel
I'm going to tell you something and
maybe you'll remember this Ms leech PLT
peace gym and Ops PLT Meg attended Swiss
Hotel and met with uh leech and bulford
and O'Connor message was delivered and
explained all parties were upset and
leech was crying in regards to how
unfair she felt this action was PLT
advised them to depart and message this
out to others all parties were upset
when it was explained that people who
are helping Logistics can also be
charged and helped accountable all
understood messaging they do feel that
this message will harden participants
resolve as they feel that is a tactic of
dictatorial government suggestion was
made to have children leave the red zone
seems pretty clear to me that you were
given the message right
I was never told I needed to leave
so the plts uh that's fabricated I
remember I remember when they came in
and we had the discussion or um
and I as it says became very upset I
believe I said something to the effect
of I cannot believe that you're about to
do this to your own people we were there
protesting peacefully and I the rest of
that interaction I I was upset and I was
crying and I
right oh my God you were upset and you
were crying because it was over and they
told you to leave
I was upset and I was crying because of
what they were proposing to do to
Canadian citizens and they told you to
depart and they told you to message that
to others
I recall them telling me to message that
to others or that I was that I needed to
leave I'm sorry it was suggested
it seems to me your memory is selective
when I take you to something that
implicates you you have no memory that's
inflammatory and I've my friend wants to
take the stand and become a witness and
Give opinions about credibility that's
fine but that's not a proper question
sir
um I'll move on
um
you would agree you've talked about the
fact that you didn't know the truckers
or control them
and you didn't police them I did not
know you weren't surveilling them no you
didn't know their past you didn't have
intelligence information about all of
them
I am not an intelligence expert right
and you would agree with me that there
may be other individuals or
organizations that would have more
intelligence information about some of
the protesters than you did
such as
would you agree with that
could you ask me a question again sir
yeah I said you would agree with me that
there may be other individuals or
organizations that would have more
intelligence information about some of
the protesters than you did yes
and you would agree with me as well that
you have no background or formal
training and crowd Dynamics and what can
incite a crowd to take action I don't
know or how do you prevent a crowd from
escalating or preventing violence
no I don't
and so just two more areas if I may just
have two more minutes uh commissioner
um hrf
uh four zeros one five one zero
if I may have that document Mr clerk
please
is an email from Eva chipyak Eva chipyak
was one of the Convoy lawyers
yes sir and so this is on February 15th
uh she indicates and for some reason we
have not been given the attachment
although we've been told that solicitor
client privilege was waived but in the
email it says I've drafted something on
the right to protest and have taken a
very cautious approach because I don't
exactly know what the emergency's orders
are but it's my understanding that they
can limit the right to protest and while
that can be challenged in court at the
moment people who do not comply may be
arrested I think if we're advising
people it's important to let them know
all the risks they're facing and let
them make their own decision
you've seen that from one of your
lawyers I've seen it since in these
hearings so two possibilities either
your lawyers didn't give that advice to
you or they did give you that advice to
you sure there's individuals see seed or
that emails too she's not in it and then
the next day or just in two days she's
not like I you should first ask her if
she got the email
God sorry I'm sorry my friend will have
a chance to examine this is quite proper
cross-examination yeah I think I think
it would be helpful to know if she
received the email before you questioned
her on it
okay
um I will get to that but I uh there's a
reason why I'm asking in the way I have
okay so two possibilities either your
lawyer didn't give you that advice or
you did get that advice from someone
I did not receive this email and I I
don't recall as I said there was a lot
of chaos we had a lot of conversations I
I can't recall okay so you don't recall
whether your lawyer gave you that email
or not I don't I don't believe I've seen
it before okay
and um
I understand that you've been charged
with several criminal code offenses
correct Mischief obstructing justice
counseling others to commit Mischief
intimidation correct that's correct and
I understand
um
you understand that the purpose of this
inquiry is not to determine your guilt
or innocence correct of course not and
you've received disclosure of documents
from the crown or partial disclosure I
believe you said yes I have and you
understand
um because the criminal process is
ongoing there's a principle a case
called wag and so as a result of that
you understand that I am not allowed to
rely on documents that are part of the
criminal brief the crown brief in this
proceeding you understand that correct
if you say so again I'm this is a new
world to me
and so you understand that if that's the
case I may not be able to challenge some
of the statements you said sir my
friends arguing that principle of law
I I am not familiar with this system so
okay um if I may just ask one final
question then
um you talked about concerns for safety
correct yes and that would include uh
concerns for officer safety absolutely
and so we've heard evidence of police
officers being swarmed by protesters and
I assume uh that you would be concerned
about that I I never witnessed that but
that I would be concerned right
um
but you don't have sufficient control
over the truckers or the protesters to
prevent that if that's occurring I don't
control anyone sir
thank you very much for answering my
questions
thank you next is the council for uh
former Chief slowly
thank you commissioner Ms Leach Tom
Curry for former Chief slowly good
morning I just have a few questions yes
sir can I just show you the uh one thing
that my friend for the Ottawa Police
Service was speaking to you about just
so that the you have the full picture
yes sir could I ask please Mr Registrar
of the witness to be shown hrf
uh four zeros one five two zero I think
this is the attachment that was referred
to
just in case this helps your
recollection what is being projected now
is a document uh with the title the
right to protest
and I'll have you seen it I appreciate
you going to take a second to look at it
but just let us know please if you have
seen that memorandum before
I I don't recall seeing this attachment
no sir
and it it I I gather from the record uh
that it is the attachment to which
um is Chippy X email or that was along
with Miss chip yuck's email and refers
to the
um the the limits of the right to
protest that were expressed in that
cover but that doesn't that's not
something that you saw or heard I don't
believe so no it does not look familiar
thank you just a couple of things and if
I could the commissioner one of the
things that the commissioner has to
consider is recommendations about
dealing with
um the emergencies act and presumably
perhaps even the right to protest and
some of the some of the limits that
we've heard about could I just have a
couple of additional facts from you
um you you and Mr Barber met I think you
told us on the 24th of January to begin
the trip yes that is correct here in and
you left from Red Cliff redcliffe
Alberta yes and arriving in earn prior
the 29th we got into iron prayer the
evening of the 28th I believe the Friday
evening I believe that was the 28th 28th
Ottawa the 29th yes sir and what I'm
interested in knowing is
of course first of all the the numbers
of protesters
exceeded your expectations
is that fair yes wildly exceeded yes uh
and you you I think you told us that you
imagined that you might be able to raise
twenty thousand dollars uh for this for
this Convoy and of course the the
financial commitments that you garnered
were far in excess of that but that then
in terms of the
the the numbers of protesters who you
you considered and I presume Mr Barber
considered in his conversations with you
we're not in the numbers that filled up
the streets of Ottawa in the way that
you found them on the 29th is that fair
oh sorry could you repeat that sure the
the your expectation when you got to
Ottawa you saw far more people than you
believed would be in attendance
yes
and am I right that you were not the
person primarily or even at all
communicating with police about how many
people were going to attend
I I don't believe so I know the road
captains were in constant communication
with with law enforcement though got it
and uh and insofar as you know the the
road captains would have had
um some information about the numbers of
of members of their individual convoys
that they had but they would not have
had a picture of the entirety of it
because people were coming from far and
wide is that fair we tried every day to
get to get solid numbers and like with
people joining and leaving you know some
people would travel with us for 200
kilometers some people would travel
across the province and turn around it
was it was very challenging and as much
as we tried to count it was next to
impossible so much so that when you got
here you you the as much as you tried to
understand how many would be there
um you were you missed the mark yes now
then just a couple of other things in
terms of the company the the
not-for-profit Inc it was incorporated
January 30th I understand I think it was
the 30th or the 31st but it was right
around there yes sir and then I think in
the record the bylaws organize it were
prepared by February 3rd so that was a
that the company and the and the
governance model that you had imposed
was evolving
only once you got here yes yes then
finally
um terms of the the description I mean
you called you you and Mr Wilson have
both called the scene chaotic
um can you tell the commissioner when
did you when did you
first appreciate the sense of chaos that
you have described was it when you
arrived on the 29th it was sitting on my
kitchen table when we were organizing
and because I had messages coming in and
emails coming in and phone calls and it
was uh it was
um
very busy times right very busy times
and so by the time you got here and saw
this situation in Ottawa
was it chaotic at that time as well
there were times when it was chaotic as
you referred to there was a lot of
people here when we got into town I just
saw a lot of smiles and a lot of flags
and
people hugging each other
but there was yeah so I don't
necessarily mean chaotic all the time as
a negative term but it was you know a
mixture of both understood just one last
thing I think one one of the questions
that you were asked about what would
have happened as you approached
Ottawa if the city had been I think the
language was blocked or barricaded
um having regard to what the numbers of
people coming far and wide and your
inability to control them is the
likelihood that those Convoy protesters
would have just made their protest where
the blockades were
again that's kind of a what if question
that I I can't really speak to I yeah I
don't know right fair enough thank you
commissioner thank you sir
thank you
next is the city of Ottawa
Alice Tompkins for the city uh the city
has no questions for this witness thank
you
Ontario Provincial Police
good morning commissioner the opp have
no questions thank you
uh democracy fund
jccf citizens for freedom
good morning Mr commissioner Miss Lynch
my name is Antoine de Council to
Citizens for Freedom representing
peaceful protesters in Windsor
in yesterday's testimony you indicated
that at the beginning you were tasked
with some of the fundraising and that
you thought that a fundraising goal of
two hundred thousand dollars was way too
much and that you expected maybe twenty
thousand dollars in donations is that
correct yes
and and that you certainly did not
expect the level of financial support
that uh that the Convoy did receive over
that period of time is that correct I
think we were all quite shocked about
that yes perfect
do you agree that many Canadians who
were unable or otherwise unwilling to go
out and protest in the streets instead
donated to the Convoy as a as a tangible
demonstration of their opposition to the
government mandates
I do and I remember
I remember saying I think it was maybe
to Mr Wilson that it wasn't even about
the money it was about the statement
behind the money
right and so is it also your
understanding that contributors to a
GoFundMe campaign may leave a message of
support when they donate yes and did you
review some of those statements of
support very briefly I I did scroll
through some yes but so then based on
your experience would it be fair then to
characterize the act of donating to the
convoys fundraising efforts as a form of
political expression I would
and encouragement and support
I think as it grew people wanted to be a
part of it in in any way that they could
show support and that was one way that
people that couldn't attend or be on an
overpass or drive to the side of the
highway were able to support
instead
and and is it true that the GoFundMe
campaign for the Convoy was active for
less than a month
yes
it was and were you ever made aware that
the convoys fundraising campaign in that
limited amount of time enjoyed more
donations from more Canadians than the
Liberal Party of Canada did in either
2020 or 2021
I believe somebody had mentioned that
we're talking about large amounts of
money here right yes
and are you aware of any other
Grassroots fundraising Campaign which
has raised comparable amounts of money
since March of 2022.
not to my knowledge but I haven't also
looked any up fair enough yes
and lastly we heard about some of the
conditions and restrictions that you are
now subject to while you wait for your
trial next year
in addition to those conditions how many
days have you spent in jail since you
started fundraising for the Convoy
49 days in total
those are my questions thank you thank
you
okay
um and uh now for the Convoy organizers
sir I'm wondering if we can take the
morning break a little early I have to
talk to three separate lawyers behind me
about certain areas of examination uh if
I we could take the morning break I'd be
very much appreciative
uh only if you make the commitment to
have a
focused questioning so that it's useful
use of the break absolutely sir okay
well we'll take the break early then
um take 15 minutes please
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
I got one time
two yeah
foreign
three times
I didn't hear anything
foreign
[Applause]
yes
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks guys
the commission is reconvene the
commissioner from
okay
the Convoy
organizers
[Applause]
morning
for the record Brendan Miller appearing
as counsel for Freedom Corp and I think
you know who I am as I'm your lawyer
good morning so I just want to start out
with some just general questions
at any time during the protest had you
been given
uh court order injunction to move the
trucks or leave or what have you
uh what would you have done and how
would you have acted
I would have
obviously followed the injunction I
never intended or came here to break the
law I would have asked if there was a
way that we could remain if there was
anything that we could work out so that
we could remain and continue our protest
okay and you heard yesterday the
evidence from Mr dickter did you not
I heard some of it yes right and he
testified about not knowing about the
deal that the uh Convoy Corp or Freedom
Corp and the board were going to enter
into with the city do you have any
comment about that
I believe uh he he was obviously not
able to attend because he was in a cast
um but I believe we had dialed him in
um on the phone to be present at that
meeting
right and so at that meeting what was
discussed
I believe that was the deal with the
mayor okay and what if any board members
objected to the dealings with the mayor
I don't recall anybody objecting to it
yeah and you heard him give evidence
that the board members were scared of
the lawyers and what they were dealing
with do you have any comment in that
respect
that was news to me okay have any of the
other board members expressed such a
fear to you
no okay thank you
um my friend Mr champ discussed with you
at length uh the injunction uh when you
should have known you should leave and
though I haven't given notice of this
I'd like to bring up document hrf
073 which is the injunction order from
February 7th
and if we could just scroll down to the
terms
teeth
right and so if I can just direct you to
paragraph seven of the injunction
can you read that
yes sir and what's your understanding of
the injunction in this order at the time
when it was obtained
my understanding was that so long as we
remained peaceful and complied with the
order we were permitted to stay right
and then there was a subsequent order
and I understand that term which states
that provided the terms are complied
with the defendants or other persons
remain at Liberty to engage in peaceful
lawful and safe protest I take it that
that term was in that order too is that
correct I'm sorry what I didn't hear all
that sorry I apologize I'll speak up uh
the term at uh term seven there where it
says that it provided the terms of the
order complied with the defendants and
other persons remember about Liberty to
engage in peaceful lawful and safe
protests I take it that was in the
following uh injunction order as well is
that right I believe so and I think that
was February 16th but I'm not sure thank
you and so uh my friend with the
government of Canada uh discussed with
you what your knowledge was of violent
offenses Etc uh that was going on in
Auto at the time if uh Mr register could
bring up the document you just discussed
p-o-e Dot hrf
a whole bunch of zeros too
if we could just rotate that
and so the cut the coloring on this is
gone but and this is already in evidence
but between the date of the beginning of
the protest and the invocation of the
emergencies act there was a total of
four violent offenses uh individuals
were charged with in that time period
did you know any of those individuals I
did not okay did you hear about
individuals being charged with violent
offenses
uh since we've been since the Convoy
okay and my friend had asked you
questions about some of the statements
that have been given in this proceeding
as well uh as in the media about all
these awful things that happen to people
and you've been here for this entire
time have you heard from any witness
that they in fact were the victim of an
assault or witnessed an assault or
anything violent
the only thing that I've seen and heard
was not violence on the behalf of
protesters
it was the video footage that I saw when
the when the Crackdown came
could you agree that if there were
victims of actual violence
given that they know who's charged
it would have been relatively easy for
those witness to be procured to testify
before this commission
David I withdraw for the withdrawal I
withdraw
um
now I just want to talk with you about
the
letter and some of the reactions that
you got from some of the protesters of
course we know that Mr Victor didn't
appear to like uh the letter and Mr King
didn't appear to like the letter what
was your uh General responses that you
were getting at the time with respect to
the letter and the the deal that was
going to be done through the city well I
can't speak to other places I know that
we printed off that letter and I went
out to 88 and spoke with the gentleman
that owned the property out there and
some of the truckers that were there
their response was very positive I think
that everyone felt that as I stated
earlier this was this was a step one
okay and again what was the sort of
responses though that you were getting
on uh the street from some of the
truckers after that deal was announced
I I don't remember was can you remember
if it was was there some negative
responses was there some positive
responses that you personally witnessed
I didn't witness any negative responses
no okay
and
I understand that Mr marazzo as you you
sat through his testimony
he stated that the purpose of the
meeting and the goal of Freedom Corp and
its board uh was not really to get him a
deal with the mayor was to or to him I'm
meeting with the mayor but it was to get
this deal to make things work peacefully
can you elaborate on that
can you repeat that please so it the
actual goal uh with respect to uh
Freedom Corp as well as the the
protesters that you were representing
their actual goal was not to achieve a
meeting with the mayor but it was to
deal with this in a peaceful manner can
you elaborate on that
yes well that was obviously our goal and
and again to get the trucks off the
residential streets
um we were hoping to find a way that the
the trucks that did have to move their
vehicles out of the city uh would have
be able to come back in and and continue
the protest
and again we felt it was a step in the
right direction and
meeting with the mayor was not one of my
goals but I thought again it was a way
to open some dialogue with somebody in a
position of authority
okay and just on my last Point here
part of this
commission is about coming up with
recommendations and things like that
uh I take it
when you came into Ottawa and we've
heard evidence that a lot of the
truckers were directed where to park and
that's where they kind of stayed
throughout the proceeding or throughout
the protest
and so there is this issue and what we
what I refer to and what's referred to
in some of the jurisprudence is a
Speaker's Corner have you ever heard of
that
I don't think so okay it's it's a
it's a a place a location in a in a
government area particularly out front
of parliament or what have you where
protesters are permitted to go and it's
a designated area for protest
um I take it when you were trying to get
the protest moving most of the uh
protesters were wanting to get onto
Wellington because it's in front of
Parliament and they were protesting the
federal government Fair correct all
right and what is your understanding of
the current state of Wellington today
I believe there's it's blocked off right
and if that area that's blocked off
became a Speaker's Corner
or individuals at any time could go and
protest the federal government
uh what are your thoughts on that
I think that would be a good idea I I
think Canadians have a right to exercise
their Democratic their Democratic rights
and they have a right to have their
voices heard right and my friends from
the government of Canada put to you a
whole bunch of evidence that you weren't
familiar with until you got here with
respect to threats
can you elaborate on any of the threats
you've received ones that you know
members of the protesters received as
well as your the legal counsel and even
any of the legal counsel in this room
uh since this proceeding started
I know well I heard when I was at the
ark that the ark was receiving death
threats against me which is one of the
reasons why one of the reasons why I
left that location
I have messages on my phone from an
Instagram account from a young man that
wanted to not just shoot me but also
shoot the rest of the protesters or the
Convoy organizers
um
I know that my my criminal lawyer has
received some very nasty emails I
believe Mr Wilson has received death
threats and threatening emails
right and so it's fair to say then that
there has been a lot of threats on both
sides
that's fair okay but do you know anybody
who's made death threats to any of these
individuals
of course not
and when you walk in here every day for
the past few days there's a there's a
protester outside and I'm sure you've
heard everything she's been saying and
she's a counter protester and is against
uh your cause what are the sort of
things that that protester has said to
you well you've been coming in and out
of this hearing
well it's been very hard to hear because
there's a lot of construction I just
hear her shouting my name a lot I heard
her say something I think just now about
she can't wait till I go back to jail
but other than that I haven't really
did she mention anything about terrorism
I believe that's right on her sign and
what's it say it says go home terrorists
okay thank you
okay any re-examination
no Mr commissioner
okay uh I
I just have one one question that you
you were taken to a chart and
told there were uh charges for violent
offenses
yes do you know who was charged
do you know the four Island defenses
yeah four people I have no I know I
don't not that I can recall anyways so
you don't know if it's someone you know
or someone you don't know I don't I do
not sir okay
um well thank you for your testimony and
uh you're now free to go thank you um
thank you very much
okay so that uh when we move on to the
next which is the uh I believe uh the
panel of uh two witnesses and there's an
issue uh to be discussed about uh the as
I understand it the relevance of that
correct
um so uh maybe we'll deal with that now
if that's agreeable sure thanks very
much
um so I'll remain seated here at
commissioner that's fine just identify
yourself because
it's the same the reporters have to know
who's speaking sure it's uh David
mishakovski Council for the Ottawa
Police Service
um we have a um very real concern with
respect to the witness panel of Chris
Dearing and Maggie um
dingmer I believe there is now a
different name and I apologize
um
it's uh hope Braun I believe
um
those two individuals and our concern is
essentially one of procedural fairness
um
those two individuals were not on the
list of witnesses provided by the
commission
and so last Friday you mean you mean
they weren't on the original list
correct and what we found out um was on
last Friday October 28th at 12 37 p.m we
received an email from the commission
saying that these two individuals would
be called as Witnesses and attaching two
statements from these individuals no
information had been previously provided
about these individuals or about the
issues that they were going to testify
about which are the how their arrest was
handled nor were there any documents uh
provided by the parties including the
Ottawa Police Service about the uh
manner of arrest it appears that both of
these individuals from their statements
are going to give evidence about the
circumstances of their arrest by unknown
officers I've been able to determine in
one case that it was not an Ops officer
one of them but we are trying to find
out information these are arrests that
took place on February 18th after the
invocation of the emergencies act these
individuals were not arrested pursuant
to the emergencies act they were
arrested based on common law powers and
the criminal code and my concerns really
are twofold firstly the information we
say is not relevant to your mandate
under the ACT
and the second question is one of
procedural fairness
there were over 275 arrests made by the
police in that period of February 18th
to the 20th
none of the police Witnesses were asked
specifically about those arrests no
documents were requested the last police
witness who testified in this proceeding
was on Wednesday October 26th had those
witness statements been provided prior
to the completion of the police
Witnesses then at the very least we
could have asked our witnesses to
provide evidence with respect to the
arrest plan with respect to the
circumstances of the arrest of the those
two individuals and the other
275 people who were arrested I am not
faulting commission counsel I understand
that the statements were provided to
them and they provided them to us
immediately after but it was two days
after the last witness testified those
statements were in the ha um those were
Witnesses who are here represented by
Council they had an obligation to
produce documents they chose
deliberately or otherwise to not present
that evidence
um and not allow me then to respond to
it and it's obvious that some of that
information they had beforehand and in
fact to add to the uh procedural
unfairness last night we received an
email from Council for the Convoy
organizers attaching seven more videos
that also would have existed that were
not disclosed there's no explanation for
why the Convoy organizers have not had
to follow the same rules as everyone
else
those statements even if they were
relevant uh and I don't concede that
they are should have been provided prior
to police Witnesses testifying it
creates a serious and irreparable breach
of procedural fairness to have you left
with two arrests out of 275 which I am
unable to provide evidence in response
to both those specific arrests as well
as the arrest plan in general
and there are I say two possible
solutions the first is to not allow that
evidence to be heard it's not relevant
to your mandate and even if it was it
would be very difficult to draw any
conclusion from the evidence of two
individuals out of 275 arrests when
you've heard no evidence about any of
the arrests of anyone else or the arrest
plans or any explanation of those two
particular arrests
alternatively if you are inclined to
allow that panel to testify including
adding new documents that um were not on
the database and were provided last
night then the Ops must we say as a
matter of procedural fairness we allowed
the opportunity to call another witness
to provide evidence about the arrest
plans and the exercise of use of force
options in connection with the exercise
of police Powers generally and
specifically with respect to the scene
that in the officers encountered on
February 18th you have not heard about
what is involved when a public order
unit has to exercise tactical options
the commission didn't lead this evidence
nor did we
similarly we didn't provide any
documents surrounding those arrests so
while my first submission is that you
should not allow this evidence as an
alternative if you are inclined to do so
then I would ask for the opportunity to
call evidence so that In fairness the
police witness says can address what
should have been put to them uh by the
Convoy organizers and which for some
reason was not
those are my only submissions thank you
very much okay thank you any other
Council wish to make submissions
in response okay I'm just I'm just
canvassing first so he's like yes
commissioner
okay
go ahead should I go ahead Emily tamman
I take it you're you're uh supporting
the The Proposal that or the objection
that's right yes we agree just on behalf
of the uh Ottawa Coalition of residents
and businesses we share the view
conveyed by the Ottawa Police we
understand that the commission is
working under difficult constraints and
there have been
um limitations in the in council's
ability to get documents and
um other evidence to the parties in a
timely matter manner but in this case we
would agree that there is Prejudice and
and that the um evidence at least as it
pertains to the arrests uh should not be
admitted thank you
any other
uh yeah
Commissioners Chris Diana for the opp
can you hear me yes
the opp agrees with the position of of
our friend Mr majakovsky uh both the the
main position or the alternative
position at this point we don't know if
the opp was involved or not in these
incidents and based on procedural
fairness we should either that evidence
either should not be permitted or we
should have a chance to respond to it if
I won't add anything further to the
comments by my friend but the opp
supports that position
okay
any other
submissions in support
okay and then as I understand it the
Convoy Pro the Convoy organizers are
opposing
were were of course in support of the
witnesses testifying and all of the
evidence being put before the commission
I'll deal first with the point of law my
friend raises about relevance and
materiality with respect to the terms of
reference under the order and Council in
this commission it this commission is to
look at the efforts of police and other
responders prior to and after the
Declaration so with respect to whether
or not there was police brutality or
misconduct Etc it's relevant material
within the terms of reference
second with respect to my friends
allegations of prejudice and it not
being fair
um with respect they have not called a
single victim or a single eyewitness to
any of these purported violent crimes
that they're trying to lay at the hands
of the protesters as a collective
um I don't see how our clients being
able to find some witnesses of which
they had no control of and which
approached them uh and trying to be able
to call actual evidence of actual
violence that isn't just an assertation
uh and in my respectful view it's
relevant and material if you find that
there is some form of prejudice suffered
um what my friend is essentially
alleging is a violation of the rule of
brown and Dunn if this was a court that
leaves the the court with various
remedies and one is to permit the
recalling of a witness in rebuttal with
respect to the rule of brown and Dunn I
did put issues with respect to arrest
Etc directly to chief Bell who is in
charge of the operation at the time and
acting and asking questions about what
was actually done we've now provided the
videos of those actual arrests I
understand that all the police agencies
don't want that to be in the public eye
and with respect I would submit that the
public has a right to see these videos
it is in the public interest and any
Prejudice is easily repairable by
permitting my friends to call a rebuttal
witness if they so choose subject to any
questions sir those are my submissions
okay and then the other uh party is
opposing the uh the application
how to care for the Justice Center for
constitutional freedoms uh we support
the freedom Convoy organizers position
and if I could just make a few points
um so first
the terms of reference and the
emergencies act do require investigating
and looking into the appropriateness of
the measures that were used
interim Chief Bell testified that using
emergency Powers were used to create an
exclusion Zone and then that they relied
on that Authority and so I would expect
that these witnesses as arrestees would
have evidence that would be relevant to
the implementation of that Authority uh
also to the extent that my friend made
the point that these are but two
arrestees of many uh we did hear from
two Ottawa residents Who provided their
experiences as examples and uh that
would then represent a broader class of
individuals so this would also be to
arrestees providing their experiences
which would then be emblematic of others
in a similar position and I would just
like to add on
um
my friend uh Mr honner from the
Democracy fund provided submissions
through email he's not here I would just
briefly read it in just to provide his
perspective as well uh the Democracy
fund submitted that the evidence of
these Witnesses is relevant to the
commission's Mandate specifically the
commissioner has been directed to
examine issues to the extent relevant
relating to the efforts of police and
other responders prior to and after the
the Declaration superintendent Robert
Bernier and others testified about the
mission statement contained in the Ops
operational plan of February 13th which
speaks to enforcing legislation with the
quote utmost respect to the individual's
Charter of Rights end quote there was
evidence before the commission that this
plan evolved after the Declaration of
the emergencies act and there was also
evidence that the Ops found the powers
available to them under the emergencies
act to be useful the commission should
hear evidence from these witnesses as it
will speak to how police enforcement was
carried out during the state of
emergency from a protester perspective
if there are objections as to relevance
as the evidence unfolds those objections
can be dealt with orally if other
Witnesses need to be recalled that
decision can be made after the hearing
of evidence from the Witnesses in
question so that was Mr Hunter's
submission which the the Justice Center
also supports
commissioners
any other who are opposing
or rather supporting the motion
Mr commissioner at some point commission
Council would like to provide some
points of context but uh if you're still
canvassing we can wait until until
that's done okay you'd like to add
something yes if I'm a commissioner
Emily tamman again for the record I just
wanted to respond to one point made by
my friends regarding
um the absence of evidence uh with
respect to residents of Ottawa who
experience violence in the Convoy and
for the record would just like to note
again that uh the Ottawa Coalition was
very limited in the time that was
allocated to tell the story of residents
of Ottawa I would also note that there
are many residents who continue to fear
for their safety in being identified
publicly as um as opposing the Convoy
and and with that said I don't think
it's appropriate to
um infer from the lack of evidence on
that point uh that there that it didn't
happen and I would also note um in
response to me that's you're getting
into argument now
um well we're dealing with whether or
not there is relevance to the evidence
that's being tendered that's right but
one of the bases of upon which it's
being asserted that it is relevant is is
that there's there's been no evidence
um in relation to violence experienced
by residents and that's something that
my friend put to misleach this morning
and also Mr Miller noted it in his
submission to you just now
okay yes Mr Wichita
um the one point I want to respond to
um that has not with respect been
addressed by my friends and which is
highly problematic I suggest is um
the Convoy lawyer has indicated that he
put an issue with respect to an arrest
to
um Chief Bell
and that is correct
um however he provided no information no
details no indication of who it was when
it was it came out of the air and what
makes that more problematic is that
obviously that information was in his
possession and there was no
documentation provided beforehand this
was sprung after the police Witnesses
had already testified when we then got
these statements had the rules been
followed that witness would have seen
those statements would have seen
documents we would have had the
opportunity to put in documents and call
evidence or ask to call evidence in
response final point I note is that my
uh one of my friends indicated that two
of that several of the Convoy witness or
several of the coalitions witnesses
um testified and that is true the
difference is the rules were followed
and everybody knew before they testified
what they were going to say so the
Convoy organizers had procedural
fairness as did everybody else in this
case procedural there is a serious
denial of procedural fairness and that's
what we say
must be addressed thank you okay and
commission Council you wanted to provide
some context and among other things
I don't know what the Witnesses are
going to say so uh to what degree is it
is this one of the witnesses that we saw
the video about or is this something
different
uh
so maybe
you go ahead and sorry I didn't mean to
um cut off uh my friend
um this is not the witness
um that one was also uh unfair but we
were at least able to get instructions
and able to deal with it in
cross-examination okay so okay that was
a red herring then okay yeah I was I was
worried that you were this was the same
person no I have no objection by the way
um for you reviewing those statements so
that you can understand the nature of
the evidence okay commission Council uh
thank you Mr commissioner John Mayer
commission Council just two points of
context
again we haven't heard the evidence yet
but commission Council uh expect that
well there may be some evidence given
about the arrest that's not the focus of
the evidence don't expect it to be the
focus of the evidence the two
individuals who are being called
commission Council understands uh
participated in the protests both before
and after the invocation of the
emergencies act they are not individuals
again as we anticipate who identify
themselves as organizers to date the
commission has uh has has called
individuals who have identified
themselves as organizers and this is a
different perspective and one that we
anticipate exploring and then the second
Point Mr commissioner is that there has
been evidence given by police Witnesses
about the measured responses in terms of
ending the protests in the Red Zone in
Ottawa these are some of these matters
have been before the commission and
prior to today without objection
okay
thank you any any further submissions by
anyone I'll be being very generous about
submission time
just one more sir and I just want to
emphasize uh but don't repeat though I'm
not I'm not going to repeat
um I always worry when someone says I'm
going to emphasize I'll take it back I'm
going to point out uh that you know when
it's with the commission under the
inquiry act and its provincial
equivalence it is an inquiry and it has
different rules and it's much more
liberal when it comes to the permitting
of evidence and though I understand
my friend's argument uh there is many
more remedies available for a breach of
the rule of brown and done if you find
that it had occurred then not permitting
the evidence and I would submit simply
that the least intrusive remedy in the
truth seeking function of this
commission would be to allow the
evidence and on whatever terms you see
just thank you
thank you
would you just give me a moment
okay I'm going to uh allow the panels to
go ahead uh on Mr mitchkowsky's first uh
point about whether the information is
relevant
um
I think the there is certainly uh
evidence that it uh maybe I haven't
heard it but it may be relevant as to
the use of the emergency act and in
particular the notices that are have
apparently uh there's lots of evidence
were circulated as recently as
this morning so the the
use of the notices uh the setting up of
exclusive exclusion zones is squarely
within the mandate
and therefore I I think the information
May well be relevant I also note that
there has been evidence of police
as to the fact that the
protest was ended
in an orderly manner and quite properly
I believe uh inspector Bowden talked
about that I believe
another witness maybe Chief Bell last
talked about the fact that was ended
without burning of police cars Etc so
the manner of ending is relevant and
this may go to some degree I think I
think that
and there was also cross-examination or
or in the in I believe of Inspector
Bernier as to the arrangements that were
made and the processing how the
processing was done the so there is
evidence about how
the operation if you like uh was uh
uh carried out including the how the
detainees were treated and the system
arranged
now having said that the impact and
relevance
diminishes to a point where it's it in
fact becomes questionable uh as we get
further along further from the use of
the emergency act notice Etc because
this commission is not
mandated to deal with uh arrests that
were uh were or were not done uh in
accordance with the appropriate police
procedures and so on that's a matter for
similar Criminal Courts if there have
been issues in that regard so I I think
I think it moves quite
uh well I would say of marginal
relevance if any to what the commission
is doing when you talk about the actual
uh manner of arrest as opposed to
what I've described that is more
squarely in the relevance so having said
that I'm not prepared to accept uh that
it is that these this panel is not
relevant
uh I expect the accent will be on what I
have set out is clearly relevant and
what's related to that and obviously
there'll be some context
context has been provided by other
Witnesses sometimes uh and uh and while
I may hear that it may not
become an issue that I have to deal with
now on the second point the procedural
fairness point I I have some concern
about that because obviously it is uh as
I've said many times and I'm going to
repeat it the public
wants to get to the bottom of this and
and that means fair to all parties and I
am concerned that there may be
unfairness to the uh to some of the
parties in particular the the police uh
forces whether it be the opp or the uh
or the Ops or in fact to former Chief
slowly or or anyone else so fairness is
is front and center in my concerns and
if after we hear this evidence there's a
need to call further Evidence uh we've
said we would set evenings uh and we
will sit Saturdays we will we will get
to get the information that the public
needs to know and that will uh lead to a
fair treatment for all but
uh that's I guess that's my ruling now
if you want something more formal in
writing I'm happy to do it but uh
I I since the panel is here waiting and
we want to get we all
want to make sure we fully use our
Friday
um I thought I'd give my ruling now if
if any party wants it in writing and
expanded upon I'm happy to do that but I
think that sets out really my thinking
uh in a general way and with respect to
whether we will have another panel or
another witness I think that's something
we can deal with after the evidence is
heard with respect to the videos I'm a
bit concerned about the videos I haven't
seen them and uh
I I would hope we're not going to get
too far afield of what's relevant to
the issues I need to deal with and and I
I don't mean to minimize any
issues about how an arrest was carried
out those are obviously significant to
individuals involved including the
officers but that's not Central in fact
is is
is Mor anecdotal I think in terms of
what this commission is dealing with but
it is part of the record so far
um some of the the evidence relating to
that so that's that's my ruling
um and we can proceed with the panel I
believe and uh I will uh expect uh the
parties if there are concerns about the
ruling and you wish it in writing uh
please notify commission counsel
well it will be in writing because it'll
be in the transcript but expanded upon I
mean sir I don't believe the witness
chair and desk are set up for two
witnesses right now they need to get
another mic as well as okay well it will
take five minutes then uh to to set up
the panel
the commission is in races for five
minutes
foreign
a lot
order a lot
the commission is reconvened the
commission on a plan
okay go ahead
good morning Mr Deering and Ms hope
Braun my name is Stephen Armstrong and
I'm commission counsel
thank you for coming today I have 45
minutes to ask you some questions and
because you're a panel
um I'm going to ask questions mostly one
at a time but when I have questions for
you as a group
oh sorry you have to be smart I forgot
about that I got too eager
Mr Deering
well you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm I wish you
affirm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Christopher
Gregory Deering
[Music]
c-h-r-i-s-t-o-p-h-e-r-g-r-e-g-r-y-d-e-e-r-i-n-g
do you sell me a
family of the whole truth and nothing
but the truth I do
mom do you wish will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm the Bible please
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Margaret hope
Braun m-a-r-g-a-r-e-t-h-o-p-e-b-r-a-u-n
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth to help you God so help me
God thank you
so good morning again uh as I was just
explaining
because it's a panel uh I'm going to ask
questions mostly one at a time but when
I have a question for you as a group
I'll try to make that clear okay
so I understand and this is for the
panel I understand that you both
provided statements to your Council
that's correct
and have you had a chance to review
those statements uh before testifying
today yes yes
and
um did you want to make any questions to
those statements no no
okay and so in the interest of time I'm
not going to put them on the screen but
for the record Mr deering's statement is
produced at
hrf0001598 and Ms hope Braun's statement
is produced at hrf0001606
so I just want to ask some questions
about your background really quickly so
Mr Mr Deering understand that you're a
veteran of the Canadian Armed Forces yes
sir
and you served a tour of Duty in
Afghanistan yes sir
yes sir and I understand that you were
wounded on that tour
can you briefly tell the commissioner
about that event
sure
I joined the military quickly in 2007.
uh finish my training very quick I was
deployed to Afghanistan in 2008 so in
less than approximately two years I was
in Afghanistan four months into my tour
my vehicle was hit by a IED
which took my vehicle
sorry it blew my vehicle about 100 feet
in the air
killing three occupants immediately
and leaving me seriously wounded
I came back to Canada and
sorry
lost my train of thought I'm sorry
that's okay thank you I also saw sir and
we'll take a moment
I saw that you're you're wearing Metals
yes sir can you just explain what the
metals are
so left to right uh left would be my
queen Jubilee medal uh it was lost
during the uh protest uh with the
scuffle of the police
um second is my campaign star for my
tour to Afghanistan
and My Sacrifice medal that I earned
were being seriously wounded in combat
and I understand now that you're retired
from the Canadian Armed Forces yes sir
and you reside in Han wild New Brunswick
I do thank you uh and Miss hope Braun
I understand that you're from
Peterborough Ontario yes
yes and you studied Environmental
Studies at Sanford Fleming College so
Sanford Fleming sir Sanford and you're a
mother to two children yes
thank you
um so if I can if I can ask Mr Deering
um
understand that you travel to Ottawa to
protest with the Convoy what made you
want to come to Ottawa and protest
it
it really wasn't that I wanted to come
to Ottawa is that I felt it was my duty
and that I had no choice to be there
seeing what was happening over the last
few years
was troubling
and I felt that I was there two weekends
first to on the between February 11th
and 13th
uh in which a bunch of veterans took
down the fence that was wrongly praised
placed around the memorial
and then I went home and then within
days the emergency Act was being
was looked at being enacted and I rushed
back to Ottawa to
do what I could to protect the peaceful
citizens of the of the a lot of the
protests
and so when you travel to Ottawa what
did you understand that you were there
to protest
the mandates uh was there to protest the
mandates
and why was that important to you
because for the last two years
uh personally as a as a wounded veteran
I couldn't do anything I couldn't take
my family to a restaurant I couldn't
take my kids to gymnastics I couldn't
grieve
my comrades in Nova Scotia because I
wasn't allowed to cross the border in my
own vehicle by myself to a cemetery
where no one was living
and lay my flowers
for my mental health and I was denied
that for two years
there's many more reasons
again my train of thought is lost I'm
sorry
that's okay I I'll ask some questions uh
now to miss hope Ron I also understand
that you traveled to Ottawa to protest
what made you want to come to Ottawa
protest
s yeah it had been
going on two years of of mandates and
they just seemed to get more and more
restrict restrictive
um
I had
tried every Avenue available within our
system to communicate
um the difficulty that I was seeing
around me and experiencing to our our
government at various levels and nothing
was a effective and the tone was not
changing coming from the federal
government
um and I was just losing hope and
um
really looking for options on on how I
could find more uh
a more
peace and safety for my family and um
felt really isolated and then seen
the Convoy begin
um
I also lived out west for 10 years so I
have a lot of a lot of my support
network is there and I couldn't travel
there and um
so there was a lot of people who I know
personally that were sharing stories
about how it was affecting them where
they were and I just felt since I'm
three hours away from Ottawa I I have a
duty to go as well and not just
represent myself by many Canadians who
could not come and felt passionately
about this
and so when did you come to Ottawa I
came
um
I came the second Saturday
um
I came the Third
weekend for the entire weekend and I
came back
that Wednesday and stayed
um until until the end so
and can you tell the commissioner what
your experience was with those protests
oh
um well when we first arrived um
I came with a girlfriend for the
Saturday
and it was just a lot of energy
um
I had was seeing people from all
different
um
uh backgrounds and
um
cultures different outfits and
uh
you know cultural outfits that I had
never even seen before in Canada
um
I
there is lots of hugs and there was
walking up there was just grown men
crying and giving hugs and
um everywhere and it was emotional and
we cried we had spent a long time
feeling like we were really alone
and not being able to go out and really
not being able to even talk or share our
experience and our family gatherings
because we were our we were not welcome
to speak
um
openly about what we were experiencing
and
um so to be it felt like this was our
our family and
um
I
I
saw so many good things I could just go
on for an hour on that
um
I saw lots of flags I saw
um
yeah I think that's good for now and if
I could ask Mr Deering uh building on
that what was your experience with the
protests and how did how did it compare
how was it similar to or different from
this bronze Miss hope bronze my
experience was that when we got to autos
on the way to Ottawa to actually when
the Convoy was was making their way to
Ottawa we we attended a few um
there was a lot of people would stay on
the bridges to show support and so where
we lived we live close to a military
base and there must have been four to
five thousand people on this bridge
waving flags and it was amazing it was
just
the amount of support was was incredible
um
we made our way sorry we made our way uh
February 11th the first weekend
um
just to kind of we wanted to see for
ourselves what was going on because when
we watched the news there was one there
was one narrative
and we want to see for ourselves because
on Facebook and social media you'd see a
whole completely different other story
so we wanted to go there for ourselves
so our first instance was myself and my
wife we went up to see what was going on
uh we I participated in the fence
removal
um again I went home
the following it was the February 17th I
left my Residence at 5am
um to go to the protest uh Victorian
protest it was again there was Hogs
there was homeless people being showered
with food I had read that crime was down
it was uh
is the most amazing experience I've had
in my life
and I don't regret going or being there
one bit
and I'm sorry if you refresh my memory
on the question again uh just asking for
your experience and and so sorry did you
have anything more to add or were you
were you done
there's a lot more I could pack into
that but it was just it was it was the
True Canadian spirit that was there
please do yep okay okay
um yeah the first weekend that I came I
came with my uh a female friend
um and
she stayed at my house the night before
and we were reading the news the global
news and they had something in there
about we haven't received a police
report yet on how many how many
additional rapes had taken place in the
city since the Convoy arrived and um
and
[Music]
that just really shook me that they
would go to that extent to make just
anyway that way but when I got here the
experience was
um like the the positive masculine
experience the way that the men were
behaving they were complete gentlemen
and
um you know I felt not unfaith
whatsoever in the city and when my phone
died and I went back I wasn't familiar
with the streets
um I was approached and walked to my car
and just treated with such
Respect by the men that were here
and and so for for the panel I
understand that you both
you were coming to Ottawa and then going
home and coming back once the
emergencies Act was invoked why did you
uh want to either come to Ottawa or
remain in Ottawa
so I remember when they were voting on
that and my wife and I were laying in
bed
and we were
terrified how the vote was going because
we knew
or we felt
that the evidence would would not be
able to substantiate such a call
I felt there was a
a great need for me to be there not just
as a veteran but as a seriously wound
veteran to be there to protect the
Canadian people from what could
potentially happen
Ms hobron could you repeat the question
so after the emergencies Act was invoked
why did you want to come back to Ottawa
or remain in Ottawa if you were already
there yeah I came to Ottawa
um
for Valentine's Day so that was the day
that it was invoked February 14th if I'm
correct that day I
witnessed
um
hundreds of roses being
offered to the police officers there was
a lot of love there was a lot of trying
to heal the divide that was trying that
was being created between us and the
police and um
the streets of Ottawa were covered in
roses that day and further to that just
listening to the Senators give their
speeches I felt that um
that as they were supposed to approve it
but then it was removed before they had
a chance to approve it or not
um
it sounded like there was good reason to
stick to what I felt was right and and
stay and
I don't believe that if
a government passes a
a law it means that we have to go
against what we believe is right we
should still
um you know we still have a right to
peacefully protest and assemble and if
we can't do that in front of the
parliament in Ottawa I don't I don't
know
you know and so building on that Miss
hope Braun once the emergencies Act was
invoked what was your understanding of
your your ability to lawfully protest in
the downtown area
well I believe that we still had
have a right to protest
in the downtown area or anywhere
that we were peaceful and as long as we
remain so we had a right to assemble and
um
yeah I had another point to that but
you could repeat the question again well
that's okay we can come back to it I'll
discuss Mr Deering what was your
understanding once the emergencies Act
was invoked of your ability to lawfully
protest in the downtown area
my understanding is that it was a
mandate
um in my eyes it was an unlawful mandate
I'm a free citizen of this country I'm a
taxpayer I'm a veteran I'm a good person
and I felt I had the right to be there
with my Canadian citizens to try to
protect them
and so Mr Deering I understand that on
February 18
2022
you were in Ottawa protesting as well
correct yes sir
and where were you staying uh in Ottawa
that day at that time so I drove up
February 17th I left my house at 5am
because it takes me approximately about
10 at the drives 10 hours with my back
and my foot my conditions I have to stop
every few hours so
I arrived at Ottawa sometime that
evening I parked my car I remember on
Bank Street
I walked up to the memorial to just
congregate with the veterans
I went back to my car and knowing me I
got lost for an hour and a half I walked
around the city I eventually found my
car which is where I slept we had came
up the previous weekend which was about
a thousand bucks for the hotel and food
and I didn't really have the means to
pay for more hotel and lodging
so I slept my car the previous night
do you recall where on Bank Street you
you parked no I don't was it in the
downtown area I believe so
and and so you when you drove in did you
pass any police checkpoints or anything
like that
I forget
okay Miss hope Braun um
I understand that you were in Ottawa
protesting on February 19th is that
correct that's correct
where were you staying at the time or
how did you how did you find yourself in
Ottawa I was a hotel
um
that was very close to Metcalf and uh
Queen I believe so I'm not sure the
names I was at a hotel that weekend
and when did you begin staying in that
hotel
it would have been on the Thursday night
before the that weekend
17th Maybe
not sure okay and Mr Deering uh on the
18th uh and I'm gonna stick with you for
a few questions uh on the 18th where was
the the protest that I understand you
participated in do you recall where in
the downtown it was so I was at the
memorial uh that day around eight in the
morning I had my coffee I was
congregating with a few different bets
and then uh just let's say North
or South my navigation's law
off but uh just about a hundred feet
from the memorial is where the police
started to line up
and that's when the call out went and uh
all the veterans so there's about 20 or
so of us
we line right up we linked arms and the
consensus was we're going to stay there
and try and protect the Canadian people
and why did you want to do that
it was our duty when I joined the
military I swore in an oath to protect
people
I I went to a war zone to protect those
people and I never thought that someday
I would have to do it on Canadian soil
but I did and I will again I would
were you told
um at any time or informed at any time
that
um you couldn't be there or it was
unlawful for you to be there
no
and I understand
um that you were arrested on the 18th is
that correct I was
can you can you tell us briefly how you
came to be arrested sure
so
I remember about 12 45 is when we we
lined up we linked arms
12 25 sorry and uh
we had a chance before the police
decided to make their push we had about
15 minutes to kind of Converse and I had
the chance to speak with four or five
officers I let them know who I was why
we were there what we were doing the
fact that we were peaceful
um I showed them the photo of my creator
of my bomb just to give them some
reference so that if they did arrest me
and I again I mentioned to every
policeman I talked to I said if you
arrest me keep in mind I have a really
bad back please
um that's where if you can repeat the
question again sorry just asking about
uh how you came to be arrested okay
right so
I had a chance to converse with the
police
um
multiple police after I spoke with them
they would move down the lines they
didn't want to really have anything to
do with me
um finally there was one member that
came up uh he didn't know my situation
as much I did have a chance to refresh
to give him my uh reference points my
photo and my story quickly
but um about 45 minutes into the pushing
um I kind of underestimated the amount
of physical toll to take on my body
after 14 years of
uh not being able to do what I could do
when I was 20. my muscles and my body
was just I had given up I was I was
finished and the video would show that
I used to come and I gave myself to the
police and as the police took me down
again he knew he needed me in my side
kicked me in my back
I was laying down I was in the fetal
position on my back he kicked me in my
ankle my foot
as I was laying down I had my hands
completely up I'm saying I'm very
peaceful and peaceful I'm not resisting
I was then punched four or five times in
my head
I had a knee on my back to keep myself
down
I was on the ground for one and a half
to two minutes
my hands were zip tied
the officers slowly picked me up
and then we slowly proceeded to the
processing line
we get to the processing line
the day was -20
I had no gloves on
at the beginning of the processing line
we were standing there
and I had asked so and sorry
the duration of the processing line was
one and a half to two hours so I was
standing there in the cold for two hours
I asked the policeman who was on both
sides of me I said do you mind you know
my conditions is it okay if I sit or
kneel because I'm in chronic pain it was
obvious my face was flush and I cried
multiple times and I don't cry ever
I was it was the worst pain I had felt
since I've been blown up
the fact that I couldn't sit or stand
was to make cruel and unusual punishment
we would go 15 20 minutes without even
moving
I also asked if I could have my
medication in which I had my
prescription and my medication on my
person so that if I needed it I could
ask
I asked and I was denying my comfort my
medication to come from my duress
we finished the processing line after
two hours
police took my uh on the Whiteboard they
put down my name they took my photo
they then placed me in the back of the
squad car they read me what I was being
charged with was with was Mischief uh
public mischief and um
sorry I forget another one um public
mischief and
sorry one minute
take your time
public mischief and
it's okay Mr Jay your your statement is
in the record so if I could actually
move you back in time
um
what were you what were you and your
group doing
um just before you were arrested what
what activity were you taking part in so
we were again we were linking arms uh we
were standing we were not moving we were
not progressing moving forward
um
we were telling the cops what they were
doing was it was it was it was an
unlawful order
um we had every right to be there
under our Trevor rights of freedoms to
peacefully protest which we were doing
they had no right to do what they did
and at any time either before you were
arrested or after were you given the
option to
um go to another place in Ottawa to
protest no
okay Miss hope Braun I think as we said
earlier I understand you were protesting
on February 19th in Ottawa
where was that protest that you
participated in um it was all
I guess at that point we couldn't really
go past Chateau Laurier so I for the
most part spent most of the protest up
on Wellington right in front of the
Parliament building I did walk around
and see the sights a little bit but um
that day uh
it was from Chateau Laurier
to
um
down Wellington and then I was arrested
when they had cleared Wellington and
protesters were then on the side streets
so I was on O'Connor
um
and were you told uh before or any point
that day or before or after your arrest
that you were not allowed to be where
you were
foreign
no not in that effect no there was
no
the
obviously we got the signs that we
weren't welcome there but I wasn't
directly told that I wasn't allowed to
be there and in that way that it wasn't
lawful for me to be there what gave you
the sense that you weren't welcome there
um the massive amount of police
and their presence was
taking over the city it seemed so I it's
and the news media and um Justin
Trudeau's words and
you know like more that I wasn't welcome
there not that it I shouldn't that it
was
not lawful for me to be there I believed
it was lawful for me to be there and I
didn't hear otherwise
and uh either before or after your
arrest were you given the opportunity or
were you told about any kind of place
you could go in Ottawa to peacefully
protest no there was no place provided
or
um
planned for us to go and not only that
but afterwards people were still coming
from
um
from across the country and places like
arm prior
they were assembling there and um
the owner of that property was
threatened with fines if he didn't have
us disperse so it wasn't even that we
weren't welcome in Ottawa we weren't
even welcome to assemble an hour outside
of Ottawa so it extended beyond that Red
Zone in my opinion in my experience and
how did you come to be arrested can you
can you tell us about that
um
so when
police had effectively
removed everyone from Wellington Street
they had all
the streets with the trucks on them at
this point and I was on O'Connor and
I had a bit of hope that they would stop
there because we were remaining peaceful
as protesters we were there from all
over the country
um and
there was a man who had the charter the
Charter of Rights or the um I guess it
was the Bill of Rights it was a document
they looked the same and they both
represent human rights and
um
and so I took three copies of that and
there was three different police units
it seemed um they had different types of
uniforms so they appeared to be so I
spoke to each unit and I said
um you may have been able to justify
this up until this point but if you if
you
if you keep moving forward and you and
you onto the people because we're just
the people now that you you have the
trucks you will be trampling our Charter
of Rights with your boots and and I put
it down in front of each one of them and
I in the middle of the street I knelt
down and in front of the charter and I
told the police officers that
[Music]
um
that
if they move forward
I'm willing to to not resist arrest and
I won't move at that point so that that
was my Line in the Sand so
and uh just coming back to Mr Deering um
you had mentioned
um just before your arrest you said
something about an unlawful order I just
wanted you to clarify what what you were
what were you referring to what was the
unlawful order
foreign
sorry can you repeat the question again
sorry you had mentioned an unlawful
order uh and I just wanted you to
clarify what you were referring to
sorry I'm just having a bit of a brain
fog at the moment uh so I I think the
context was uh I had asked you
why why you were there and you said that
you were there
um I don't want to put words in your
mouth but I understood it to be in sort
of in defiance of an unlawful order or
you weren't leaving because of an
unlawful order from what I understand a
mandate is just it's just that it's a
mandate it's not a law we didn't we
didn't vote on it the people didn't want
it
was pushed upon us
and I felt it was unlawful
and what is the mandate
the Mandate was the
was the emergency Zach sorry
and for the panel
um
can you can you just tell us uh what was
the impact of these events
so is that sorry can you say it again
was that for me what about what was the
impact of these of these events of the
impacts of the year for the past two
years sorry on on the events in Ottawa
it's all right I just need a minute uh
so for me the the impacts
um where
um I was already
I've always been concerned about our
our government
um
overreach and and we have to keep an eye
on our government that's what our duty
as people the citizens of the country
are is to be politically active and
involved and aware of what's going on
and over the years I'm just increasingly
starting to lose faith in the
institutions and um
what you know we say is is we are we are
Canadian we're a democracy we we attract
people from all over the world because
this is a place where we have rights and
freedoms and
um
and to me
um the impact was that
it was evident to me in a very clear way
and um
seen among the entire world that the
Canadian government is um
is
is not acting on the is not this is my
opinion obviously
um not acting according to what we
mandated it to
um it's not protecting us it's not
um upholding its
its job it's not doing its job and to me
it just broke any illusion of that and
at the same time I think it's important
that we see
that as Canadians in the world so that
we can fix it so that we can make it
better and we we need to kind of keep
that in check you know the nature of
being
in a world and filled with people
to balance it out and Mr during did you
did you want to answer that as well
can you repeat the question one last
time I'm wondering what the impact of
your experience in Ottawa was and how it
ended uh on you as a person
it's just it's such a loaded question
I'm sorry there's so many emotions going
on in my head in the last
the last two years it's just been
constant persecution after persecution
and I find that when
the government has a role
but
when they want to get into your lives
and tell you who you can see when you
can see them and dictate everything
about your life and when they get too
intrusive
the overreach for me was just it was
just too much
and again I just I had to be an auto was
just it was my duty I had no choice
yes Miss hope Brown
um more personally the the impact for me
is um
I after speaking to a therapist just you
know clear signs of PTSD like uh
symptoms around what happened and um
um my whole life was really turned
upside down from from that time
um forward and
has impacted my life it's a completely
different life now before and after that
day so
okay and
um I'd just like to close out with the
panel I'm going to ask both of you let's
let's start with Miss hope Braun is
there anything uh that I didn't ask you
about that you wanted to say that we
didn't get to talk about
um
I don't think so I'm good thank you Mr
Deering
if I could I like to speak directly to
you sir I think uh I'd like to ask you
and as a veteran I'm asking you that but
this never happens again
you have the power of a whole country
behind your opinion
please use it
protect the Canadian people the most
kind of misbehavior from this government
towards its people ever again
please thank you
thank you those are all my questions
okay
we I think it's the Ottawa Police
Service is going to go first
foreign
police good afternoon Mr Deering good
afternoon Ms hope Ron good afternoon
um Mr Deering um you were looking at a
statement that you had in front of you
and that's the document that's called
Canada Freedom Rights Movement statement
of Chris Deering
foreign
you have a document in front of these
are these are just my notes sorry there
so I can reference uh because my
traumatic brain injury I need some
things to reference so sure I just want
to see what those notes are is it is it
the same as your uh statement that you
were referring to yes or is that so it's
in there yes
right and so what it is it's a document
we can put it up on the screen but I
think you have it in front of you it's
called Canada Freedom Rights Movement
statement of Chris steering is that
right I'm not sure about documents are
I'm gonna look but I don't uh recall
that sure have a look at it and tell me
what it says or if you can you repeat
the title please sure it's called Canada
Freedom Rights Movement statement of
Chris gearing
press we can split it up on the screen
uh so if you can put on the screens
right okay
um
Council if it may be assistance I
believe that's hrf401598
thank you if you could just um put that
up so that Mr Deering could see it
is that what you had in yeah I don't
have that with me sir but I I have seen
it yes
so sorry did you have something else
with you no it's to reference sir these
are notes that you made when
just recently so I can remember sorry
okay
um perhaps um those notes can be filed
uh at some point as well those are not
notes you made at the time of these
incidents right no sir okay I didn't
realize I thought you had your statement
in front of you when you were testifying
but you had some other notes yes sir
okay
um Ms hope uh Brown
um I believe your statement also says at
the top of it Canada Freedom Rights
Movement statement correct I don't
recall the very talks talk line Sorry
perhaps we could follow
is uh I'm sure it is if that's what
you're looking at
this is the hearing clerk just for the
benefit of the record that's hrf401606
that's correct that's your statement as
well correct yes and so those statements
say at the top Canada Freedom Rights
Movement statements
who put that on them
I'm not sure I'm not sure like if I can
answer no he did but don't worry that
questioning cross-examination go ahead
you don't know
I would imagine it would be
um
the lawyers that were taking our
statements those would be the Convoy
organizer lawyer
I don't believe so no okay it wasn't any
of the people at this table was it
I was speaking to them on the phone so
I'm not sure I couldn't see them
who gave you the statement pardon who
prepared this statement
and gave it to you yeah
it was uh I was um contacted
through the Justice Center right
and so one of the Justice Center's
lawyers prepared this statement and sent
it to you correct
it was basically word for word of they
asked me questions and I gave a response
and this is exactly what I said to them
on the phone so yes and then they gave
it to you and they typed on it Canada
Freedom Rights Movement statement of of
Chris Deering and of Maggie Dingman the
original one said okay
yeah sure I'll agree with that right and
that's the same
heading that we see on
um the statements of Tom marazzo Canada
Freedom rights movements but you don't
know what that means
I do
I don't know I'm not
um somebody who I understand that words
can be
titles for things to me Canada Freedom
Rights Movement are four words that
represent what I believe
I'm part of so
I don't know
looks like a good heading to me
I see what I'm trying to figure out is
every most of the other Witnesses here
were interviewed by the commission and
then we have statements that are on the
public order emergency commission
letterhead you were not interviewed by
the commission's lawyers to prepare
those statements correct
I was interviewed by a lawyer who is
here working
on working with the commission
so I don't know these you don't remember
and how about you Mr Terry
uh everything everything in this is
correct uh I wrote everything myself
um
again I do forget also
um who assisted with me that's backed my
traumatic brain injury I'm sorry
and neither one of you have criminal
charges against you correct no no and so
you told your story to a one of the
Convoy organizer lawyers is that right
the Justice Center the Justice Center
Technology
and neither one of you as I understand
it has filed a complaint with the Ottawa
Police Service about your arrest
not yet no not yet
and neither one of you has contacted the
crown to say a excessive force refused
with me
I have not contacted him no
yeah at this point I've tried to contact
the government so many times that I kind
of
gonna you know it's very frustrating
I've spent a lot of time trying to
contact government agencies and have
assistance and have not gotten anywhere
for many years at this point so
and um complaints against the police can
be filed with um an office a government
office called the office of the
independent police review directorate
oiprd
neither one of you filed a complaint
with them correct no no not yet
and the SIU that's the special
investigations unit you can investigate
situations in someone in which someone
says they've been seriously injured by
the actions of the police and so I just
want to be clear there haven't been any
complaints or investigations by the SIU
out there
no not twenty not to my knowledge
and um I understand
um Mr Deering that you have some notes
and you're going to share those notes
with me correct sure sure
um and I understand
um uh Ms hope Ron you do not have any no
not here with me nope
um and you haven't filed any notes with
your lawyers or the Justice Center
lawyers I provided them with um a letter
from my chiropractor who spoke to the
state of my back afterwards
um also with uh
um a trauma specialist a psychologist
filed a letter from that professional as
well and I believe that's all the the
notes that I've provided them and I
didn't see that trauma specialist note
in the database but perhaps I missed I
don't think it was submitted it wasn't
so you did not give any documentation Mr
Deering I understand
from your evidence
sorry that you were in Ottawa on
February 11th and then returned on this
evening of the 17th and 18th
yes sir
and at that point the emergencies Act
had been passed
correct sure and there was an exclusion
Zone
you knew that correct I didn't
you did sure
um and you knew what the newspapers were
telling people not to go there unless
you have an exemption I didn't write the
newspapers sorry
I'm sorry I didn't read the newspapers
or listen to the news because they were
lying constantly sorry
and none of the sources on which you get
information were telling you uh don't go
into that zone can you say it again
sorry
I'm sorry can you say that again sorry I
just yeah none of the sources from which
you get information were telling you
don't go in that zone
sorry I'm gonna have to ask you to
repeat one more time I'm sorry that's
okay
um Ms hope Braun uh you presumably knew
that you were told not to go into that
area unless you had specific reasons to
be there
hmm
that's not what I was gathering from
from it no
wasn't you didn't turn on the radio you
didn't read any social media you didn't
go on Facebook I I knew that they wanted
to clear the area I was aware of that
yeah and you knew that the emergencies
act had been passed
well they were still debating it in the
house the day that I was arrested so I
wasn't really
um what day were you arrested on the
19th yeah the emergencies acted okay it
passed but it it was still being debated
and it hadn't passed the Senate so
and so
um both of you you were in the area you
did not live in the area you were not on
your way to an appointment correct
no no I had a hotel though booked so
I was
and you both I believe fell to your
knees and refused to move while the
police operation was being carried out
correct no it's incorrect I was I was
pulled down and beaten sorry
I'm sorry I didn't hear you I apologize
or sorry I said I was pulled down I was
not on my knees I was pulled down and
beaten right you you were on your knees
and you refused to move no I was I was
standing up sorry I was I was pulled
down
and um Mr Deering you indicated
um that one of the police officers even
told you uh to hide that's correct so he
gave you some advice and in spite of
that you stayed there
that's correct
and in fact you wanted you believed as a
veteran you should put yourself in the
way of
um other protesters because
um veterans are better able to withstand
what was about to come you said I
wouldn't say better Abel I just said uh
we're more accustomed to it most
civilians are not ready to be beaten
um
I was ready for it
it was me who was on the knees sorry
and um you were on the road Mr
Dearing correct
uh at what time yes I was on the road
what's uh what's the question
you were on the road when you were
arrested I was on the road yes
that's hard to say it was a lot of snow
so I I don't know where I was on the
grass on the road I'm not sure right and
so were you uh Ms hope Brown weren't you
everyone was on the road right and so
you understand you're obstructing a
roadway correct
and the big please if I could ask
everyone to
not uh
act out
um that would be appreciated we're
trying to keep this civilized
go ahead I'm sorry everyone was
obstructing a roadway that day so
everyone all of the protesters who were
arrested were obstructing a roadway
correct and the police were also
obstructing the roadway and if you think
of it like that and there were also
announcements made in both official
languages uh telling people to move
yeah didn't hear that I did
and you were there Mr deer and you said
15 minutes before and you saw the police
were looking violent and aggressive you
said and so you decided to stay on that
roadway correct absolutely
and you're both aware I take it I'm just
gonna finish off
um that there is an online fundraising
campaign for uh both of you run by a
group called Cafe
but I'm not aware of that until just now
wait Derek Sloan he's actually sitting
in the audience
that's wonderful you're aware of that I
am now
I am now and I will be happy to
and in fact I see on that fundraising
um that he is fundraising for Chris
Barber Maggie Dingman Bridget Belton
Chris Deering Danny Beaufort and Tamara
Leach you know all of those people
correct
I've only just met them
um
here you see Mr Sloan today
I do yeah right and in order to benefit
from that fundraising I take it it's
important that you tell the story that
you just told correct
I'm not sure sorry can you benefit from
can you say that again in order to
benefit from that fundraising it's
important that you tell the story that
you've just told correct
I'm sorry I'm not really very familiar
with what you're speaking to right now
everything's happening very fast so I'm
Mr Sloan is associated with the Ontario
party I understand right
okay
um thank you very much uh I have no
further questions thank you both thank
you thank you
okay next uh are the Convoy organizers
good afternoon Mr commissioner good
afternoon Chris and Maggie my name is
Bathsheba Vandenberg and I'm Council
representing Freedom court and the
protesters
I'd like to start by asking you Chris a
few questions about what happened to you
on that Friday February the 18th 2022.
I understand that you were wearing your
medals when you were arrested is that
correct I was
and did they get damaged when you were
arrested they did um the first 20
minutes I had my medals in my jacket and
with the shopping with the police at one
point one of my medals my queen Jubilee
medal broke off and I lost it
could I call up hrf
four zeros one five six six
just to um perhaps
um there are a lot of documents
obviously David michalkovsky sorry for
the Ottawa Police
um perhaps um before my friend
introduces one of the documents she
could just confirm whether it was
something that was uploaded last night
for the first time I know there are
seven uh videos that were sent to me
last night that were not on the system
so if we could just indicate for the
record whether that is one of those
documents because I may have specific
objection to that okay given given the
late
disclosure apparently could could you
make sure you tell us beforehand what
what it is we're going to just so we can
if there are problems we can outline
them in detail
yes Mr commissioner I can confirm to my
friend that I'm going to refer to a
video that was presented in the document
list by the commission
and it is a video of the arrest of Chris
deary
um
what was produced um in the last couple
days correct no it was a producer a
while ago my friend and it was produced
as part of the list by the commission
okay we'll address that later thank you
thank you
Mr click the numbers again uh for this
video or hrf okay you got it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we can pause the video thank you
Chris can you confirm that that is you
that's being thrown to the ground and
beaten by the police yes it is I'm not
sure about that question let's let's be
a little careful with how we do that
please
can you confirm that's you Chris excuse
me can you confirm that as you in the
video it is me thank you
now I'd like to ask you Maggie a few
questions about what happened to you on
Saturday February the 19th uh 2022 and
I'd like to bring up a document and this
is a video that I did uh
disclosed yesterday and it's a video of
the
rather as a photo it's a photo of when
uh Maggie was kneeling in front of the
police David mitchowski for the Ottawa
Police for the reasons I've already
articulated that should not be allowed
these are things that should have been
disclosed long ago and we've had no
explanation I I get it sometimes things
come up at the last minute but we've had
no explanation for why this was not
disclose
okay well let's see what the the if it's
just a photo of uh the of Ms uh hope
Braun kneeling is that all it is that's
all it is and Mr commissioner okay I'm
not sure what the Prejudice would be but
uh let's uh let's go ahead
and the number uh the number for that
photo is um
hrf
zero zero zero zero one six one two
just confirming to the right in the
green jacket that you kneeling
yes and the charter is in front of me
and there's several people also kneeling
and praying
thank you or what do you mean however
there okay
now I'd like to call up a a video and
this is a video of the arrest of
Maggie and she spoke about it and I
think it is important Mr commissioner
that everyone here sees it it's simply a
video of what she already described and
put into evidence
David mijikovski for the Ottawa Police I
understand that is one of the videos
that was disclosed last night as well
that
that's correct and it's also a video
that was available to the public at
large by the newspapers
and it can you for the record explain
why it is these things weren't disclosed
till last night Sir if I may pop in um
unlike some of the institutional
individuals and and representations here
uh we of course have no control over
Witnesses they approach us we get put in
contact with them
um it's we get the evidence when we get
the evidence and we put it before you as
quickly as possible these Witnesses have
no connection uh to our us as a party
they were folks that were heard about
and were asked to put in contact with
this is how that works sir it just
unfortunately didn't happen until I
believe we even got here in Ottawa I'm
sorry I did I wasn't I maybe I missed it
are you saying you didn't get this video
till yesterday
I understand that there was uh
essentially maybe best uh Vandenberg can
explain the background but at the end of
the day I I think we provided it as soon
as we could we didn't uh have reference
to it per se I'll let Miss Vandenberg
speak to it yes Miss commissioner that
that's correct as I did only have notice
of it yesterday and I tried my very best
to share it with everyone as soon as
possible
okay well let's have a look at it and
see where we go thank you Mr
commissioner
the numbers for this video are hrf four
zeros1614
and Mr clerk I'm going to ask you to
pause at two seconds so to play the
video and then pause at two seconds
[Music]
thank you uh Maggie can you confirm that
that is you in the green jacket and the
blue Duke
it's me thank you
uh do you agree uh that the meaning
because I'm going to go into we're going
to actually just let's continue playing
the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
do you agree that that appears to be a
snatch and grab method snatch and grab
meaning snatching and grabbing
and personally this is this is a little
bit leading which I don't think you're
entitled to do number two
I'm not sure this is a witness who can
talk about police tactics and
I think now you're getting into
something that's a bit unfair so I mean
it
you don't have much time in fact
you're you have one minute left so you
might want to use it more
appropriately
I would like to uh call up a
mother video unless I'm going to get
adapted to and lose another minute
of my time
it's a video of Maggie being arrested
I'm not sure if this is really very
relevant to what I have to decide how
the arrests were actually carried out
and where there were okay no complaints
now if that's how you want to use your
last minute
I'm prepared to have a look at it
I did want to ask a question uh for the
both of you just to confirm that after
you were arrested that you were driven
outside the Ottawa city core and told by
the police that's again that's pretty
leading for uh for a phase you're not
supposed to be leading your Witness
were you driven outside of the that's
sorry
um
if you want to ask the way to ask I'm
happy to assist it's you ask how did it
how was it uh that uh what proceeded
after you were arrested
where were you taken
so tell us what proceeded after you were
arrested I believe uh last time we spoke
so uh when the processing line was
finished after the two hours of staying
the freezing cold not able to sit or
kneel
ended up my medication again I was then
I had my information taken
um I was then placed the back of a squad
car they read me uh what I was being
charged with which was published public
obstruction and mischief
um so I I said I understood uh the
police officer then the police officer
then left his vehicle for five minutes
he came back and he said well today's
your lucky day you're not being charged
so that's I said that's great I said can
I know what's why that changed he said
no you don't need to know that
so at that at that time I thought it was
my understanding that I'm free to go
because I'm not being in charge of the
name
then the next five ten minutes they put
me on a Paddy Wagon with no Direction
they didn't say anything they said go in
here so again I mean I have no choice I
go to The Paddy Wagon I'm there for 25
minutes
don't know where I'm going don't know
how long I'm there
eventually The Paddy Wagon does fill up
over the next couple of hours
uh then they drive us around for
approximately half an hour to 45 minutes
is very hard to tell because
there's no windows of course in the in
the Paddy Wagon you don't there's no
concept of time
um they then drove us to a Public Works
building that was 10.2 kilometers away
from the Parliament Hill
when they let us out of the paddy wagons
they gave us our possessions back they
give us no paperwork
the police officer came out and gave a
Stern warning and said you don't come
back to Ottawa or you'll be charged
they give us all our possessions back
again sorry
um most of us due to the cold our cell
phones had died
um no one had any money no one had any
masks we couldn't go into the building
to make a phone call so we were stranded
so we were forced to walk to a Wendy's
that was and I forget the approximate
distance so we had to walk from the from
that Public Works building in the snow
in the freezing cold
to a Wendy's I had called a friend that
I had just met prior the night on the
17th I met someone for five minutes and
he said if you need anything in Ottawa
and this is the type of people you met
in Ottawa
I met him for two minutes five minutes
and he said if you need anything you
call me and I'll pick you up right away
and whatever and he did exactly that I
picked him I called him at Wendy's I
said can you please pick us up
we have no money we have no means we
don't know where we are we're not we're
not from Ottawa
it was just
I never thought that I would get dumped
out of the sea like trash by my by the
police it was
um
way over your time thank you I was just
gonna ask if the same thing had happened
to to Maggie just to confirm
I'll be very brief so when
um after I was behind the police line
it's all in my statement that's fair but
I I
was thrown to the ground and
um there was a lot of Weaponry around
and uh I looked up and there was there
was a gun pointed it appeared to be at
my head
and from there I was taken outside the
city and dropped off and again I was at
a towing place where they were Towing
the trucks and um
there was no shelter there was no place
to plug in your phone there was nothing
and um
thankfully people came and got us so
thank you
okay thank you thank you
uh Ottawa residence coalition
good afternoon commissioner good
afternoon my name is Emily tamman I
represent the Coalition of Ottawa
residents and businesses
uh and
um you've both described to us and we've
heard from other uh
Convoy participants that um your
experience in Ottawa was uh generally a
positive one it was and that you found
it to be a peaceful and loving
atmosphere when you attended the Convoy
it was amazing it was the Canadian
Spirit it was and even between us and
the police up until that those last days
it was a wonderful experience
I'm going to ask that a video be pulled
up it's COA 50135
and just before we start it this is a
video a compilation of images uh that
were submitted to the commission before
these proceedings commenced and for the
purposes of the record the video was
accompanied by an affidavit
with the number a f f seven zeros and a
two uh explaining the origins of each uh
part of the video and where it came from
but generally speaking I can tell you
these are videos that were taken by
people in Ottawa uh during the Convoy
occupation so if we could play that
video and then I would just ask you to
reflect on whether it accurately
represents but what you witnessed well
in Ottawa
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
going along with we've come here to help
get rid of people like you from your
tyrannical [ __ ] you you're a bully and
you're so pathetic in life what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what can
I do okay okay you are so pathetic in
life that you have nothing better to do
than to enforce not [ __ ] you know that
yeah yeah so that and that makes me feel
good about yourself and that's and
that's it's sitting here it's disgusting
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
this is David alderton
it is now 801 and we just officially let
the cabinet ministers and all the people
of Ottawa sleep in are we going to have
that let's give them a wake-up call boys
give them
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
remember these people haven't been able
to sleep for 10 days okay it's kind of
funny I'm not gonna allow I'm not gonna
lie it's pretty hilarious
oh God please
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
almost out of time
yes
okay well I guess we'll leave it there
can I just ask each of the witnesses one
question please can you still have it's
it's still have a a minute or two yeah
no I understand that it's it's been
difficult to find an appropriate time to
put this video into evidence by virtue
of the limitations on cross-examination
so yeah if we could just finish it and I
would just have one question for them
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and I would just ask you
um Miss hope Braun as a mother of two
young children if a spectacle like this
was unfolding in your community in your
neighborhood in your front lawn would
you feel safe and peaceful
given the events of the last couple
years in the actions of our government
it would actually I felt very safe there
and
um I didn't ask you though if you felt
safe there if this was happening in your
neighborhood in front of your house and
you were not a part of this action would
you feel that it was safe and peaceful
[Music]
um
again I'm just going to say given the
context of the last couple years and the
actions of our government I
I
would take be there with with that yes
if it was outside of my if it happened
outside of my door and I had people and
I hosted people afterwards while your
children were trying to sleep
that would be okay with you
I won't deny the fact that that would be
um
that there was a lot of energy being
brought to to Ottawa and but I asked if
it would be okay with you
I
it would be okay with me yeah Mr Deering
if that was happening in your community
in your front lawn would that be okay
with you I'd probably join him yes
thank you those are my questions you're
welcome
okay next is the Ontario Provincial
Police
commissioner my questions have already
been asked and answered so I have
nothing further
okay next is uh Council for uh
former Chief slowly
thank you commissioner we have no
questions thank you okay a democracy
fund uh jccf
bye Mr Deering and Ms Braun I'm Rob
kittridge Council for the Justice Center
for constitutional freedoms Mr Deering I
thank Council for the Ottawa Police
Service asked you a question about
whether you saw news reports telling you
not to come to the protest area after
the emergencies Act was invoked you
replied that you weren't watching the
news around that time because the media
had been lying about the protests do you
remember that question yes I do
um but you saw news reports about the
protests before that time didn't you
I may have uh
it may preclude some of my questions but
did you see news reports that lied about
or misrepresented the protests all the
time
um did media reports suggest that the
protesters were aggressive
they did racist they did violent they
did while you were at the protests did
you see any aggression or violent
behavior from protesters
from protesters of the police story from
the protest oh no not from the
protesters no from the police boss
did you see any racist Behavior while
you were at the protests no it was a
diverse culture
um
thank you uh Ms Braun some media reports
and our prime minister have suggested
that unvaccinated people are often
racist and or misogynist could you tell
me whether you saw any racism or
misogyny from unvaccinated people or
anybody else while at the protests in
Ottawa absolutely not if anything if
anyone had any of that there was a lot
of healing with that coming together for
freedom from all over the world
and things were a little bit rushed at
the end of your conversation with
Council for the Convoy organizers but
you mentioned in passing that during
your arrest a gun was pointed at your
head can you tell me a little more about
that that's right um so from the video
you saw that I was kneeling down I had
told the officers that I was willing to
be
um arrested uh and that I would not
resist and at that point they they
I ended up on the ground with my hands
in front of me and um a very heavy knee
went into my back and there were several
offices on me and because I caught my
fall with my hands and they wanted my
hands behind my back they they kept
saying put your hands behind your back
but I couldn't because of the weight and
it took some time at least a minute at
which point I thought okay I'm going to
DARE look up and I looked up and there
there was a gun right up my head a long
rifle gun which end of the gun was
pointed at your head
um it looked like it was the barrel of
the gun
and who is pointing it at your head it
was one of the officers
um
and I remember it was a more beige kind
of camo
all right well thank you very much those
are my questions thank you
okay before I go to commission Council
uh Ms Bathsheba Vandenberg
normally the the
Convoy would be last because you're the
ones who they're your Witnesses so which
is why you can't cross-examine but uh
normally you've got them last so since I
took you or you were taken out of order
I'll give you a little more time if you
would like to wrap up
pardon me if it's okay I'll just wrap up
for Miss Vandenberg
and that's fine okay hello hello okay
and so I just want to ask you a couple
of questions about some of your other
observations uh you saw short wrap up
yeah so you saw the videos that uh my
friend
uh put up on there yes yes all right and
she asked you some questions about your
opinions on them uh other than those
incidents and and first it wasn't asked
Did You observe uh those events that
were in those videos
some of them uh but not the majority of
them I didn't there's a lot of streets
that I didn't see so right and two of
the photos in there one had a uh
Confederate Battle Flag the other had a
Nazi flag did you see any such Flags
while you were in Ottawa
no never no
all right and what if any conversations
did you have with other protesters that
you might classify uh as racist or
misogynist or any form of uh things that
you thought were inappropriate did you
have any such conversations either of
you never it was full of love unity and
joy it was it was the best time after
the last two years that I had that we
had had it was it was incredible did any
of them call for the uh overthrowing of
the government of Canada by violence no
no did any of them ever call for
violence at all no no did you see
anything uh with respect to destruction
of property
no thank you
okay and commission Council any
re-examination no re-examination
commissioner okay well thank you for
your testimony thank you thank you
we're going to be able to uh take the
lunch break for an hour and we'll come
back with our next uh with this
is it uh come back at
2 2 10.
the commission is in recess for one hour
thank you
foreign
thank you
the commission is reconvened that
commissary
good afternoon Mr commissioner John
Mayer commission Council uh the next
witness is uh Jeremy McKenzie Mr
McKenzie will be testifying via video
conference so if we could just make sure
that Mr McKenzie can hear us and that we
can hear him
can you uh hear us Mr McKenzie
yes I can answer okay good well
um
we're ready for your testimony so we're
going to have you sworn and uh I see uh
you have the council here so let's uh
should we first swear the witness and uh
okay
Mr McKenzie will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm
uh
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Jeremy Mitchell McKenzie
[Music]
j-e-r-e-m-y-m-i-t-c-h-e-l-l-m-a-c-k-e-n-z-i-e
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth
yes I do thank you okay
afternoon Mr commissioner my name is
Sharif Oda I'm counsel to Jeremy
McKenzie Mr Mckenzie was summons to
testify here
um this afternoon his testimony is
compelled I would just like to make
clear that he is invoking his
protections under the Canada and Ontario
Evidence Act
um
to protect his interests against
self-incrimination and of course he
benefits from the protection of section
13 of the Canadian Charter of Rights and
Freedoms
okay and I I will deem that the witness
uh has objected to answer each and every
question
uh on the ground uh that his answers uh
May intend to incriminate him or tend to
establish his liability
to a civil proceeding at the instance of
the crown or any person
but for the act you've been vote okay is
that that adequate absolutely thank you
Mr commissioner okay so Mr McKenzie
we're ready to go uh commission Council
go ahead thank you Mr commissioner good
afternoon Mr McKenzie can you hear me
yes sir my name is John Mather I'm one
of the commission counsel you were
appearing today via video conference
from the Saskatoon Correctional Center
is that correct
that's correct and uh we understand that
you're being held uh in relation to
charges in a matter that is unrelated to
the protest in Ottawa and Coots is that
correct
that's correct
um the commission understands that uh
you are from Nova Scotia is that correct
yes sir and where did you grow up
I grew up in Picto County Nova Scotia
um and we understand that you were a
member of the Canadian Armed Forces
that's correct from 2017 for sorry 2003
until 2017. and what rank did you
achieve in the armed forces
uh I retired as a master Court role
um and you have produced a letter
through your Council uh to the
commission and it's a letter that you
sent to the Senate
um do you know what I'm referring to
I believe so yes
so if we could pull up JMK
seven Zero's three
Mr McKenzie can you first just let me
know if you can see the document on the
screen and you're able to read what it
says
yes I can okay thank you
um and is uh this is a letter that's uh
entitled diagon's List of Demands to the
Canadian Senate did you see that
yes okay and I'll I'll ask you some
questions about Diagon in a moment
um
and can you just confirm for us if we
can scroll down to the bottom
just again for for the the commission's
benefit but also potentially yours we
see that uh it has a signature block for
you at the bottom
um do you and uh and there's no
signature here do you know if you ever
sign this letter
uh no I sent it digitally to uh to these
senate members okay did you do you
recall when you send it send it to the
Senate
it was several days before the emergency
Act was revoked by the government sorry
Andrew and sorry and with the Audio I
just didn't catch that did you say
before it was invoked or revoked
before it was revoked by the government
perhaps three days three four days thank
you
um we can take uh the letter down but Mr
McKenzie I'm going to ask you some
questions and if you need to look at the
letter just let me know okay
um in the letter to the Senate you
described yourself as a podcaster and a
comedian I take it that's accurate
yes it is and it's the commission's
understanding that you podcast under the
name Raging dissident is that correct
yes
um and uh
at one time you had a YouTube channel is
that correct
yes and do you know uh uh at any point
do you know how many followers that
YouTube channel had
I have had several that have um uh been
removed by YouTube for various reasons
um several times it's been ten thousand
twelve thousand I think the highest may
have been twelve or thirteen thousand
and you also have a telegram Channel
yes sir okay and how many followers have
you had I appreciate you were giving
some ranges there on your on your
telegram Channel
uh roughly I would say upwards to around
14 000.
um and on the YouTube and telegram
channel are you posting under the name
Raging dissident
yes
and uh I understand that you also have
an Instagram Instagram account using the
name Raging dissident is that correct
yes I do
um and uh are there any other social
media that you use
those are the primary ones uh Rumble as
well is another video sharing website
um primarily those are the uh the ones I
use most heavily
um I also have a personal page that I
typically just use for
advertising links and so on on Facebook
uh gab and um
I believe that's it and what's the URL
for that personal website
my my own personal uh.com website yeah
the one you were the one you were just
referencing
oh I have a Facebook uh just a Facebook
page uh there's a rumble website that uh
URL that my personal website is
ragingdista.com
thank you
um and do you use the messaging service
slack to communicate
no
have you ever used Slack
no I've never
um
in the letter to the Senate you identify
yourself as a founding member of The
People's Party of Canada is that correct
yes the uh when the party was uh stood
up it required a certain amount of
signatures to uh register federally I
believe maybe 250 500 something in that
range uh Mr Bernier put out a request
for people that wanted to support his
platform to see a party created to
fill out a form and sign it and mail it
into the appropriate address which I did
right and you describe yourself as an
enthusiastic supporter of the party then
um I would I would go as far as
enthusiastic but I am a supporting yes
okay so if we could pull up the letter
uh to the Senate again
jmk3
if we could scroll zoom in please
and just give me a moment
can continue scrolling down
continue scrolling down please
stop there it says here in your letter
Mr McKenzie I am also a founding member
of the People Party of Canada and
enthusiastically supported the party
through my social media so would you at
least agree with me that you
enthusiastically support the People's
Party of Canada through your social
media
foreign
could bear with us for a moment
so the technical team has said that
it'll be five minutes to resolve the
issue Mr commissioner okay we'll uh I
think uh five minute break and then come
back
the commission is releases for five
minutes
the commission has reconvened the
commissary
[Applause]
uh Mr McKenzie can you hear me right now
yes sir okay thank you and I can hear
you and apologies for the technical
difficulty and I appreciate your
patience while we sorted out uh before
we got cut off and I'm not sure when you
last heard me I had asked you whether or
not you were an enthusiastic supporter
of the People's Party of Canada and you
suggested it wasn't necessarily
enthusiastic I then pulled up the letter
that you'd sent to the Senate
um in which you say and hopefully you
can see it uh that your founding member
and you enthusiastically supported the
party through my social media
public speaking and attending events
held by Maxine Bernier as well as
personal friends Mark Friesen and Randy
Hillier do you see that
yes sir and so I take it you agree with
me that you were an enthusiastic
supporter at least to the extent you
wrote that in the letter to the Senate
correct
um I misinterpreted the question I
thought you maybe perhaps been at the
current time I haven't been really
involved in any
um Party politics since around this time
and
um in in as pertaining to the letter
enthusiastically I guess I was referring
to throughout the previous federal
election that had just transpired in the
the fall
um and on your and and you mentioned
earlier that you are a podcaster uh the
commission also understands that uh
these podcasts are often videotaped as
well and the video is streamed is that
fair
that's correct okay
um so it's not just an audio format when
you talk about a podcast
no it's it's both I usually extrapolate
the audio and then upload it after to
several streaming platforms for typical
uh working more uh typical podcasting
consumption right
um and on your podcasts
um I take it you would you agree that
you're an outspoken about your criticism
of the federal government
yes sir okay and you're also outspoken
about your criticism of the RCMP
yes and you were as a general matter
opposed to the covid-19 public health
mandates that were imposed by the
federal government
in general yes
um and with respect to the RCMP as I
understand it uh you've been critical of
how they handled the mass casualty event
in Porta Peak Nova Scotia in 2020 is
that fair
yes sir uh several days after uh that
event had taken place I reached out to
some people that I I knew um in the area
and tried to get a sense of um before I
just you know started speaking
haphazardly without really having any
you know as much information as I could
and then I released a video
um on YouTube which garnered roughly
anywhere between 500 000 to a million
views across various platforms
uh in the in the following week
um
I'm now going to ask you some questions
about Diagon again referring back to the
letter you sent to the Senate you
explained to them that diagonal is a
fictional country is that is that at
least that's how its origin is that fair
uh yes sir right
um
and
from the material the commissions
reviewed uh diagonal on the the origin
of it was something you drew on your
phone when you drew a line of over the
continent of North America from the
southeast to the northwest of the
continent am I describing that correctly
uh yes so the the concept was born out
of a um sort of a long kind of stream of
Consciousness I do a lot of
um analytical commentary on current
events politics these kinds of things at
the time I believe it was January 2021
uh the I observed as many others had uh
the midwestern United States Texas
Florida North South Dakota and so on
Alberta Saskatchewan Alaska
um geographically formed sort of an
oblique line
um that were resistant to or handling
the covid-19 approach in a different way
these are traditionally conservative
areas in Canada Republican in the United
States
so we you know kind of found it amusing
that there was there was this kind of
geographical divide almost that you
could find on a map and you know it
became sort of a joke that if this was a
pretend place a different you know kind
of parallel universe a different world
and so on and
um that's that's how the the concept was
born but the the flag the referencing is
what I created uh in the weeks following
uh on my phone just as kind of a
um as a as a mechanism for Branding
symbolism kind of thing for you know
community members and it started to
become synonymous with um myself and the
podcast kind of as a as a as I guess a
branding mechanism that people would you
know display and they could buy
couches stickers and and things like
this
to uh basically you know to know that
they're a fan of about mine so and I and
I take it from reading your letter to
the Senate and what you just said you
don't take any issue uh and you agree
that you are associated with Diagon and
the diagonalon flag
yes it came out of my imaginations yeah
yes yeah okay and you talk about you
mentioned there I think you said it it
began as a as a bit of a joke
um but as I understand it that joke has
now evolved into uh an International
Community of your podcast fans is that
fair
yes it's um also fairly synonymous with
another another thing that's been
referenced the you know so-called plaid
Army which was
um several me and several other guys
were just uh having a conversation one
day we all had similar shirts on some of
me had a joke about you know what is
this the Plaid Army so it was kind of
that evolved into it it's essentially
the same thing it's the same uh group of
people and it's just a uh
um again a kind of a branding mechanism
um a way for uh to unite uh Community
followers and so on right and it's you
specifically reference in your letter to
the Senate that it has created an
International Community of of of of your
podcast fans is that correct
yes there are followers in in fans in
the United States
um some of your
Australia
and as I understand from your letter
that these uh this community engages in
Regional meet and greets barbecues and
family gatherings
uh yes correct sometime in the uh summer
of 2021 I believe
um we kind of hosted uh
just people wanted to come out and have
kind of a meeting rate with myself and
some other guys and uh we had as you
said a barbecue um you know I had some
drinks so guys are playing guitars and
so on I observed that there was a few
dozen people that came from as far away
as British Columbia and Ontario we met
in Saskatchewan and it struck me as
um
in this time of a lot of people feeling
very isolated and depressed a lot of
them expressed me how much this meant
for them to feel as though they had some
kind of connection and
um and kinship with other people that
felt the same way as they did about
about the uh about the future and shared
their fears and concerns and so on and I
just observed how
much it seemed to help them and heal
them and make them happy so I began what
I called a find your friends campaign
so I used uh using my uh online presence
and my telegram Channel and so on uh set
kind of uh Regional areas or chat
channels to facilitate by I mean not
everyone can it can come all the way to
Saskatchewan University so if there's
people
um that are like-minded that are in your
area that share these that are a fan of
my my podcast and so on and you'd like
to meet each other and share in this
kind of uh this this kind of uh activity
then you could do so uh this way I was
just trying to create a you know an
Avenue for them to to pursue and I
encourage people to do that rather than
sitting at home looking at their screens
and you know being fed you know fear and
you know what I believe is a lot of
toxic messaging on the media and
television so on and I thought it would
be good for people to get out and you
know have real face-to-face human
interactions and relationships again and
I thought it would be beneficial to
their mental health and I saw nothing
but uh there are good things coming from
that so I encourage people to do so
okay and uh you mentioned a first or an
initial Meat barbecue in either the
summer 2020 2021
um after that have you attended
personally any of these other meet and
greets that uh you encourage people to
participate in
there was one other one
[Music]
sort of barbecue
barbecue Ontario in perhaps April this
year and there was
um another gathering outside the city of
Ottawa during the uh during the uh
Convoy uh period of time in February
and are there other former Canadian
Forces members in the diagonalon
community
yes there are I've
off commentary my
unique I suppose you could say kind of
lived experiences through through the
military by how I deal with my uh you
know the inherent trauma and so on that
comes with that it has gathered a it has
attracted a fair amount of um
other other veterans and military
personnel because they resonate with the
things I'm saying where they I'm
speaking to something that they can
understand or identify with so there is
there is a a fair number I would I
couldn't answer a number specifically
but
um a sizable portion of the community
especially early on where other guys
that knew me from work or for so long
but uh kind of spread through the areas
um because I'm smoking veteran and so on
do members of the diagonal Community
ever refer to themselves as bigots
yes they do
um this was
my doing
uh to try and kind of take power out of
the word
um as it was being used as a as a slur
as a slanderous kind of defamatory
method towards people like me and my
followers and fans and so on so um we
just kind of adopted as a
tongue-in-cheek kind of defined way of
shrugging it off is because it doesn't
you know bother us that these people are
you know I'd show that it doesn't bother
me it shouldn't bother them and they
shouldn't care what you know these
people think you know they should let
allow them to
um you know attack them in this way and
get under your skin and make them feel
bad just because they are who they are
and they like what they like so you and
your followers were being called bigots
it didn't bother you and so as a way to
show it didn't bother you you embraced
it and identify yourself now as bigots
in a tongue-in-cheek kind of sarcastic
tone against
and is that sort of tongue-in-cheek
sarcastic tone consistent with this sort
of Comedy that you perform on your
podcasts
uh I would say that yes I'm a fairly
sarcastic um person yes
and we already you already mentioned uh
the diagonal uh symbol or flag and I'm
going to pull it up just to confirm
everyone can see what we're talking
about if we can pull up com906
and again Mr McKenzie at any time if you
can't see anything that I've put up on
the screen just let me know
um so is that you in this Photograph
that's on the screen
yes it is
yes leave outside of Ottawa sometime in
February
I believe this is a still uh image from
a from a video that was taken I was
standing on top of a table addressing
the uh the people that had arrived and
attended and was just simply thanking
them for showing up and encouraging them
to keep you know taking care of each
other and you know I hope they have a
good time and so on and uh fair to say
that the the flag in the background
that's a diagonal flag
yes
okay
um and uh the commission is uh
understands that on February 15th uh
2022 you said in a video that you could
not wait until that flag is seen as a or
is is described as a hate symbol do you
know what I'm talking about
yes sir again I was being um
kind of um
tongue-in-chief in a way it because the
people that I believe are deciding what
is and what is not as a hate symbol are
uh incredibly disingenuous and um you
know kind of smear emerges
um it was would have been kind of a
kind of a gotcha trophy over them not as
not as actually in in a serious manner
of displayed as a hate symbol but more
of a more of a um you know achievement
that I you know kind of lured them in
more to uh to focus on myself
and do you see and I take it then that
this is another sort of part of your
comedy called wanting this to be called
a hate symbol
yeah yes it's because it's again
um no one in my committee would be
surprised since you already saying these
things and it certainly isn't uh a
symbol of hatred but we find it amusing
that our our uh I guess enemies if you
could say
um
do believe this and believe he's absurd
uh claims about us and it's just kind of
an inside joke at this point
you sell
diagonalon merchandise is that right
I personally
um I have a a shop that has just
recently gone online in the past
two or three months previously other um
you know friends of mine offered like
the the flags for example another man
was selling uh Patches he was making a
cost just to help promote uh Community
visibility and give people something to
I thought it would be nice for some
people have something to hold in their
hand and kind of have them bring them
some attachment and just something for
them to enjoy and display
so the people who were selling the
merchandise they were friends of yours
yes they uh they sold it with your
approval
yes it is and they are also part of the
Diagon community
they would likely identify as fans of
mine than yes
um however
um as you can probably observe it's not
a particularly complicated uh
thing to produce
um so
I don't it's not a copyrighted symbol by
any means there's no real official uh
ownership to it as of yet so people
would just approach me in
of their own uh you know voluntary
uh attention and asked like hey do you
do you mind if I make this or make that
and sell this you know for whatever and
I would say you know go ahead if it
gives you something to do if you can
make a few dollars from it and it helps
you then by all means right it's not
it's not a nuanced symbol is it in terms
of its design
no it's essentially just a black square
and I use my finger on my phone to do
this about three times with a white uh
Paint Marker selection of as you can see
it's kind of an irregular it's not
perfectly straight lines they're kind of
a regular and it is literally just my
finger doing this a couple of times and
I sent that image file off to be
produced for their
so if someone wanted to show themselves
as someone who supported your podcast or
supported the diagonal Community it'd be
fairly easy for them to replicate the
diagonal flag is that fair
I I would I would assume so yes it's uh
not difficult to uh it looks fairly
simple
so uh Mr McKenzie I think what I'm about
to say will not come as a surprise to
you but In fairness I want to ask you
some questions about it
um
the RCMP has described you in documents
the commission has received sorry I
should send me back the RCMP has
described diagonalon let me be specific
has described diagonalon as a
militia-like network with members that
are armed and preparing for violence
the RCMP has also described Diagon as
having supporters that Express
sentiments akin to accelerationism
viewing a coming collapse or Civil War
as necessary to write the course of the
country
in your letter to the Senate you denied
those sorts of allegations is that fair
yes sir yeah
um
and uh in the letter to the Senate uh
you said that you are under RCMP
scrutiny because of the criticisms that
you've made about the RCMP and as I
understand reading your letter but
please correct me if I'm wrong I
understand it I understand you to be
saying that the RCMP sort of
is is is is is looking at you closely
because of the way you criticize them
and that's why they're saying these
sorts of things about you
that that is my personal belief yes
um there is a uh most of many many of
the the followers and fans and so on are
um you could say conservative Canadians
there is um an aspect of you know
Firearms uh sporting recreational
culture stuff especially in western
Canada
um but there's certainly not any
anything resembling a militia or
anything to this extent
moving away from what the RCMP says
about diagonalon
um I appreciate you wouldn't have been
able to watch the testimony but we had
uh superintended Patrick Morris who is
the uh head of the OPP's intelligence
Bureau testify he's not a member of the
RCMP and he testified at the inquiry
that diagonalon is an extremist entity
that holds extremist views I assume you
also disagree with that statement
uh yes sir it's um my again belief and
assertion that much of this
um this narrative is is coming from
certain uh actors and members of the
media uh the Canadian 88 Network and so
on has astroturfed and kind of laid the
foundation of this this idea
um they've been certainly paid me in a
lot of attention over the past few years
and through personal disclosure
documents of mine through various uh
legal uh meetings it's been revealed
that the police are actually relying
upon articles if you can call them that
by the Canadian 88 Network as open
source intelligence so they're relying
upon what these people are saying about
me as uh you know taking it at face
value but to be fair Mr McKenzie you
don't know what the RCMP or the opp are
relying on in their entirety when they
make these assessments to you
that's correct
um I was going to ask you about two
terms one of which was the Platte Army
but thank you you've already uh
explained that so we can save that
question the next term that we've seen a
reference to is a term that you've used
sometimes called the beach and
um it is our understanding but again you
can correct me if I'm wrong that when
sometimes when you reference the beach
you're referencing D-Day and World War
II is that accurate
yes it comes from a line in a a movie I
enjoy uh Saving Private Ryan there's a
line in it in that film right before the
the landing craft to descend upon uh
Omaha Beach I believe where uh Tom
hanks's character says I'll see you on
the beach as kind of a
reassuring
um I'm I'm I will be there with you kind
of sentiment so I I'd say this is again
kind of and you know my followers are
familiar with this I've explained it
several times but that's just kind of a
call back to that film and it's
expressing a sentiment that you know
what whatever is transpiring in the
future we'll have I will be I will be
there with you to support you and and
you guys can support each other and so
it's just a message of encouragement I
suppose
uh you attended the protests in Ottawa
in January and February 2022.
yes sir and you attended them with other
members of the diagonalon community
uh yes I did when did you arrive in
Ottawa
I can't be certain of the exact date but
it was one or perhaps two days before
the main body of the uh of the trucks
arrived I believe it was a Friday
evening they showed up so so um so maybe
perhaps that Thursday or Wednesday
yeah
um so you knew the Convoy was coming to
Ottawa and that's why you showed up
uh yes I did I observed the
it was very clear to me why monitoring
social media and so on as part of what I
do for to comment on social you know
current events and you know analyze
political commentary that kind of thing
that this was going to be a very
significant event it was very clear to
me this was not going to be a in and out
you know weekend protest type of thing
there was videos of long long very long
um convoys of trucks and vehicles they
were coming in from multiple directions
there were
open
group chats or voice chats and stuff
where these people were communicating
back and forth you can listen in on it
because it was clear it was going to be
a pretty big deal
um so I uh again this was going to be
something I would be talking about would
have a lot of my attention anyway so I
decided why not go and get a close look
at it as it transpired rather than watch
it from you know relying on other
sources from home to understand what was
happening right and it attracted your
attention because the the stated purpose
of the Truckers coming to Ottawa was to
end the federal covid-19 mandates and
that's a political view you also held
right
that seemed to be one of their primary
motivations yes
um there was a lot of other that was one
of the main factors there was a lot of
other
discontent in in various groups it
wasn't it wasn't a monolithic that was
the only uh objective for people again
there was a very not really any
hierarchy or any real organization that
I could observe it very much seemed like
just a Grassroots kind of uh movement of
discontent with the federal government
with
um things that have been transpiring the
cost of living is is rising social
division
um just a lot of the rhetoric uh
officials and stuff are using on
television a lot of people are very
unhappy and having a difficult time over
the past couple of years and it um
basically it was I would describe it as
if I could use a metaphor in the pot I
just simply boil over and uh many people
have decided that this was going to be
the time that they were going to show up
and exercise their right to peacefully
demonstrate their their discontent and
their displeasure with the performance
of the federal government
and when you arrived in Ottawa you met
people there who were members of
diagonal community
yes sir and presumably if you met
someone who hadn't heard of you or
hadn't heard of Diagon you would tell
them about it you tell them about your
podcasts and and encourage them to
listen and support
yes if someone was unfamiliar they asked
a question I would just simply say I
yeah I am I'm a social media guy I'm
online I have a
podcast it's political commentary comedy
and some you know analysis and and this
kind of thing if you're interested I
have I had business cards that somebody
made out for me I would hand them out to
people and say this is the website if
you'd like to check it out and so on and
you know have a nice day kind of thing
and those business cards they would have
had the diagonal logo on them
uh yes on one side
did those sorry it might have cut out I
asked you did the business cards have
the diagonal logo on them
yeah yes they did they have it on one
side and then one of my other artistic
logos on the other side with just simply
the the website on one side and then I
think it says find the others and find
your friends on the other
and and you suggested this is something
you do if someone came up to you but
um I is it fair to say Mr McKenzie
you're in the media business and you
want to promote your media so you would
also actively hand out those cards
uh yes sir someone if someone asks or
they're interested or they express a
desire to learn like what is it doing
it's just easier to just give them this
it directs them to the website all my
social media links and so on over there
there's a short video if they can go
from there if they like what they see I
presume they'll continue if not then
it's okay
um
uh did you attend at any point in the
protest with a person named Alex vrind
or Rend apologies if I mispronouncing
the name yes sir and who is Alex green
he is uh someone I met online through
um
through the evolution of my my podcast I
suppose I met Alex in person in the
summer of 2021 I believe we spent some
time together in Saskatchewan as he was
traveling around the country meeting
people and uh As I understood he was
just kind of in between you know jobs in
life and wasn't really sure what he was
just taking an opportunity to
uh he bought a van and a dog and just
kind of went on the classic Canadian
road trip across around the country and
was meeting up with other people in the
community that expressed a desire to you
know meet them and you know uh hang out
and he'd become kind of more of a
prominent uh
prominent uh person because of his uh he
also is a content creator he makes a lot
of memes and jokes and comedic things
like this and
um so people were interested to meet him
and his content he posts under the name
fairy man's toll is that correct
yes sir yeah
um and we understand uh both from your
letter to the Senate and some videos
that your Council has submitted that
when you were in Ottawa you encouraged
peaceful protesting is that fair
yes sir I I was concerned especially
because of the rhetoric and verbiage
coming out of again the Canadian
anti-hate Network which is being
parented it started to be uh picked up
by other other uh more credible news
outlets and so on that I was concerned
that if something should happen outside
my control or
you know I can't really see the future
but I wanted to State very clearly what
my intentions were and what I expected
of people if they were going to be
representing
um myself or brandishing any of my I
encourage them not to because I wanted
this to be about Canada that this is
about the country bring a Canadian flag
this is about me this isn't about I'm
not trying to sell anything
um this is more important the bigger
idea is more important
um but if you do you know happen to have
you know something please conduct
yourself you know appropriately because
your the actions and
um
decisions and things you say and you do
will reflect upon me in the Greater
Community and so on so uh so so just I
wanted to have that in on the record
before just in case
so just just to something so uh you
wanted someone who was wearing a
diagonal symbol to act accordingly
um I've started accordingly but act as
as appropriately and peacefully
um
at this point in time were you aware
that they're either the RCMP or other
police agencies would be maybe
monitoring what you do or what your
supporters do
yes sir so you when you're giving that
direction you're aware that the
authorities are watching
I I was under I was never explicitly
given
um any notice or no one had talked to me
or spoken to anybody just it was pretty
clear just upon General observations my
own instincts that this was
we were probably on on the radar
somewhere
so I didn't want um anything to be
misconstrued I was trying to be very
clear about my intentions and you know
uh you know Jokes Aside this is about
you know protesting
um the government's performance and
people exercising their rights to do so
I didn't want this to be misconstrued in
any way we were simply there to protest
peacefully I said things like if you're
if there's a speed limit on walking for
some reason then you will walk slower
than that don't even let her don't spit
don't even throw a snowball don't give
anyone any excuse to point at you and
say that look what you've done Look What
You've you know incited or created or
fermented and so on
um because that would have undermined
the entire purpose of the of everything
everyone was trying to achieve so Mr
McKenzie I'm now going to read you one
by one a list of names and I may have
some follow-up questions but all I want
to know right now is for each name
whether or not you communicated with
this individual while you were in uh
either before you arrived in Ottawa or
while you were in Ottawa
okay you understand
tomorrow tomorrow leech
no I first spoke to Tamara Leach
potentially in July of this year July
August
Parker
no
James bouter
no
Bridget Belton
no
Benjamin dictor
I'm aware of who Mr Victor is I
personally have not had any interaction
with him
um I was aware that he was a
some kind of alleged manager of YouTube
channels for where you would set up
gofundme's and name himself as a
beneficiary and Mr McKenzie I I don't
mean to interrupt and it's just it's
just I want to make sure we get through
it and you have time and I just want to
know right now whether you communicated
with these people your Council will have
an opportunity if there's other things
that that you want to bring up
um did you ever communicate either
before a while you were in Ottawa with a
Tom marazzo
uh yes I spoke to Mr marazzo once
possibly twice over the phone uh one
says I was driving back from Ottawa to
uh to the Americans to drop off so
people that had accompanied me they
could only stay for a couple of days and
have families and kids and so on so
um I smoked in for a couple of hours we
talked about you know our share
experiences in the military and so on he
indicated to me that he was in some
capacity nearby
something resembling people that were
making decisions I guess and basically
just kind of connected and that like
someone suggested we should meet each
other and I expressed to him that if
there was anything that I could do to
help assist get a message out or
something that I was willing to do that
no one ever asked me to and
um uh likewise I told him if I saw or
was made aware of anything that I felt
that that should be that would be
relevant that they should all know that
I would inform him and and so on but I
think that was the extent of our
interaction I didn't uh have any real
meaningful interaction with Mr marazzo I
think until around April when there was
a benefit uh a fundraising dinner for
the veterans Freedom organization right
in Burlington in Ottawa how many times
did you speak with Mr morazo
at least once possibly twice and when
was the first time you spoke with Mr
marazzo
it would have been
during the first
a week I believe of when the trucks
arrived I was in the process I remember
I was driving my truck and it was over
the headset um the other guys were
sleeping in the truck while we were
talking so some somewhere in between go
back into Brunswick I couldn't say so
sometime before January 28th
I'm not sure I'm not sure the dates are
when the trucks arrived and when they
left but so sorry and and there's
evidence of when the trucks arrived but
it was some point before the trucks
arrived is that correct
oh it was after it was after how long
after
I would say roughly a week roughly a
week seven to
five to eight days perhaps fair enough
when you were in Ottawa did you
communicate directly with any Ottawa
Police or OPP
not to my knowledge uh I did have some
friendly conversations on the street you
know just Hi how are you how's it going
the cold out you know that kind of thing
but uh nothing significant
did you receive from
sorry I think there's a did you receive
from any sources
information about Police Operations or
police enforcement plans while you're in
Ottawa
yes there was a user that contacted me I
believe on telegram I would say again
summer of 2021 whom self-identified
himself as a RCMP member
um just kind of friendly expressed to
enjoy the podcast and like what I was
saying and so on so there was a loose
relationship with this whoever this
person was
and during that time in Ottawa they had
reached out to me to inform me of
to say that uh the POU which I had to
find you know if that was I didn't
understand nomenclature the northern
police officer if I understood it to be
the public order unit the essentially
the riot police
um were being
um activated to be sent to Ottawa
um and further to that
after the emergency act had been invoked
uh this person had sent me um
well there were screenshots I I guess of
either a WhatsApp group chat or a
telegram I'm not sure uh various RCMP
officers engaging in uh taking selfies
of you know drinking and eating and so
on and celebrating the uh the the
violence that they were bringing upon
the the people downtown and saying uh
wait until they hear our Jack Boots and
this kind of thing
um he said that to me and I said well is
this real and they certainly is it
seemed it looked very real and I said I
will publish this and they said that's
that's why we sent them to you
um so I did I released it on Telegram
and that you know it went out
um since then uh that person has uh
deleted their account sometime in March
and I haven't stayed in contact with
them since okay do you remember their
name on Telegram
the the user handle was like GK or PK or
something it was two initials and a
phone number I think it was an Ontario
area code but other than that beyond
that other than that user did anyone
else provide you with uh information
about Police Operations or enforcement
plans
no
if we could pull up Ops
sorry OPP one six six eight
foreign
if we could go to page five please
uh yeah scroll down more so this is an
opp intelligence brief Mr McKenzie um
you may have seen it with respect to
some of the disclosure we provided but I
I assume you have you wouldn't have seen
the document before today I'm going to
ask you uh if you look at item two uh it
says actually for context look at item
one
um it talks about a video posted to the
name is redacted but it says the name of
the Instagram account it says raging
dissident so that that would be you Mr
McKenzie
as far as you know and then item two
again talks about a video posted to the
Raging dissident account in which uh
the poster uh shares information
credited to police sources that disclose
and poor enforcement plans and then it
provides a bit of a description is that
the information that the user on
telegram provided you
yes sir okay
on the same day on the same page if you
look at item three
uh it talks about on February 8th
um a user uh posted two videos to his
telegram channel rageboard is that your
telegram Channel
that was one of the previous names of it
yes okay and if you look there if you
there's a line break and then it says
again name redacted says there's
supposed to be some negotiations taking
place with a government delegate but he
hasn't heard how it went from organizers
yet
yet he goes on to state do you see that
um no sir sorry let me I'm talking a
little quickly yeah
and take your time I want to make sure
that you're reading this uh before I ask
you questions
um so this suggests that uh
um you were aware that
um there might be negotiations with a
government delegate but you hadn't heard
from the organizers yet do you know that
that's a reference to
uh
I can't recall I remember being under
the impression that there was some form
of negotiations taking place between
um some sort of uh leadership apparatus
for the the uh Convoy and the perhaps
city city of Ottawa RCMP OPP not sure
the police and the the Convoy people
fair enough um how did you learn that
information
that was a good question I think it may
have just been kind of common knowledge
that there was something like that was
taking place more of a rumor perhaps
um the as it goes on
yeah the public work unit I was that was
a that was uh given to me specifically
by this uh by this user on telegram from
the RCMP I like that allegedly they were
right and you're talking then about the
part that's in bold after that is that
correct yes okay yes
um are you aware that Tom marazzo met
with city manager Steve kanalakis on
February 8 2022.
no sir did Mr marazzo ever talk to you
about meeting with Mr kanalakis or
meeting with any government officials in
any of the conversations you had
no I did not okay
have you ever
spoken with Keith Wilson or Eva chipyak
no sir
we can take that down thank you Mr Clerk
uh Mr McKenzie I think you think agree
with me it's fair to say that you were
critical of the federal government's
response to the protests in Ottawa and
Coots is that correct
uh yes sir
um initially uh it was I had no uh no
issue actually I thought it was able
very appropriately there was a strong
police presence but as also there was a
large number of people so inherently
there is a danger that there's uh going
to be you know something can happen so
it makes sense
um I didn't take any issue with uh
anything that I had seen until
um they started becoming a little more
aggressive here and there there was an
incident where some fuel cans were
stolen or seized or what have you but it
wasn't really until the the EMA was
invoked that they became extremely
aggressive in violent and uh that that
is that was
that was what I like this issue it
um did you ever say that the RCMP was
intentionally cutting truckers off from
essential supplies in Ottawa and Coots
that is what I had been hearing from
people yes and so and did you then
repeat that on your podcast
I may have yes
did you ever say that the RCMP made
attempt to disrupt cell phone towers to
ensure truckers cannot communicate
that again was another
um
another
uh scenario there were people having a
lot of issues with their cell phones
um that may or may not have been the
conduct of some kind of interference it
could have just been too many cell
phones on the towers I'm not sure but
that again was another kind of running
uh suspicion in theory at the time fair
enough my question right now is if you
recall if that's something you said on
your podcast that that was something
that had been was being said
and did you ever say on your podcast
uh that uh or did you sorry let me back
up did you ever distribute or know of
anyone Distributing uh contact
information about the members of the
Ottawa Police Service
and that's my knowledge no
we can pull up
ssm.nsc.can.0001575 underscore Rel point
zero zero zero one apologies for all
those digits Mr McKenzie
switch
so scroll up to the top please just so I
can give the witness some context so Mr
McKenzie this is a thesis analytical
brief uh dated February 21st 2022.
and if we could go to page three of the
brief please
and scroll down a bit further please
scroll down a little bit further please
so this this part of the brief says that
uh since the initial weekend key figures
within diagonalon have made appeals for
participation in and documentation of
the demonstrations further Vereen has
been collecting donations to allow
others to travel to participate in
demonstration in Coots Alberta or Ottawa
Ontario do you see that
yes sir uh do you have any knowledge
about whether or not Mr Vereen was
collecting donations to allow uh people
to participate in both Coots and Ottawa
uh I recall he was collecting some funds
for someone I don't think it was just in
general open to whoever wanted them I
think I think there was one or two
people potentially from western Canada
that expressed a desire to come down to
Ottawa they couldn't afford it so I I
think that was roughly what was going on
there I wasn't directly involved I can't
recall entirely but I think that's what
was going on
and then if we could scroll up in this
document
to the sorry the next page up
sorry sorry I keep scrolling up
stop there so this again
uh this is a thesis uh a document
um but it has a a box here that says in
Jeremy McKenzie's own words
um it's the first one says this is the
good guys versus the bad guys The
Showdown has finally [ __ ] begun and
it has begun in Canada you could uh you
could go be a part of the story now is
is that something you've said
it sounds like something I said yes
um and is that something you've said
with respect to the protests in either
Ottawa recruits
probably I believe so yes
and then the next quote is this is the
beach get yourself out there is that
something you said with respect to the
protests in either Ottawa recruits
probably yes okay and in this case when
you're using the beach are you referring
to the analogy we spoke about with D-Day
I was referring to the the idea that
this again a lot of people have felt
very powerless and and
disenfranchised upset depressed and
this was this was an opportunity for
them to actually go and participate and
have their voices be heard and join
these demonstrations and rather than
sitting at home complaining and whining
about it on the couch they could you
know if you can why not why not go and
be involved and I've heard you say that
Mr McKenzie I'm asking you if in this
case when you're using the word Beach if
you're it's using in the same context
when you're alluding to D-Day and the
reason I'm asking you this is you know
that uh the police and and the
government view you view your group as
potentially as extremist and so this is
the sort of thing that would grab their
interests so when you're talking about
Beach you're talking about D-Day is that
right
I was trying to
uh speak directly to my audience that
are familiar with uh my verbiage my kind
of terminology and things I reference in
the way that they would understand that
this is this is something important that
you know we should you know you can do
together it's not uh I didn't certainly
didn't mean it in any kind of violent
context or D-Day invasion type scenario
and it simply meant it as an encouraging
kind of call to the community at large
that uh hey you know if this is
something
um you know you could be involved in
rather than just again sitting at home
by yourself
so Mr clerk you can take that document
down thank you
I now have some questions for you Mr
McKenzie about the protesting Coots
um
just first simple yes or no did you ever
travel to Coots personally
no
uh did you know anyone who was
protesting in Coots in February 2022.
I was aware that Mr Chris leisak was
there
and I am Loosely acquainted with Mr Adam
Skelly who had made a couple of trips
there to deliver steaks and brisket and
so on
um there's a couple of comedians in the
Edmonton Calgary area that I know that
travel down to put on some performance I
think and then just kind of meet and
greet and leave and that was about it uh
what were the names of the two comedians
it was uh uh Brendan black here and a
Sam Walker or did maybe I'm not sure if
Sam attended but uh Brendan for sure and
uh
there was also uh Brett Forte who I
don't know personally I've never spoken
to him
um I was just made aware that they were
there because they posted a video of
them traveling there to say hi to
everybody and so uh Chris lisaic uh
Mr uh Adam Skelly uh Brendan and Samuel
are they members of the diagonal
community
no
they may identify as fans uh Mr leisak
would
um
Brendan probably would uh Sam
potentially Mr Forte I've never met
um or spoken to it if you're a fan of
diagonal you're part of the community
right
again it's just kind of a
self-identifying
you could say it's as simple as you know
as identifying as a Toronto Maple Leaf
span by putting a sticker on your truck
um it's really it's really that simple
so the answer to my question is yes
high school so yes
were you communicating with the
individuals you just identified while
they were in Coots
no
how do you know Chris lisac
Mr lysock has been a long time uh fan of
the podcast
um
I met him personally in Saskatchewan uh
in the summer of 2021 I believe that
first
first uh meet and greet get together I
mentioned and a subsequent one uh later
in the year perhaps September
um there was a few dozen people
um
we you know had a very mistake you know
with all these people took a photographs
together at one of the one of them and
uh that's pretty much it did you talk to
him when you were at either of those two
meet and greets
yes I talked to dozens of people yeah
yeah and I take it the topic of
conversation at these meet and greets
include the similar topics that you
discussed on your podcast is that fair
um I generally don't like to engage in
that I find it kind of exhausting and
I'm trying to just make it keep it kind
of a social you know meet and greet uh
you know
casual kind of uh social event I don't
really try to talk politics or anything
like that
um but presumably but presumably your
fans when they meet you in person they
want to talk to you about what they they
hear you talking about your podcast
that's fair isn't it
sometimes yes
should we pull up uh com
uh five zeros nine zero seven
so Mr McKenzie um
can you please identify the people in
this photo
yeah that's uh that's the photo I just
mentioned I posted to my Instagram page
that's myself on the on my left and uh
Mr alongside on the right right and this
was this at the first event in
Saskatchewan
I believe so yes okay
and just to be clear Mr McKenzie other
than that event in Saskatchewan and uh
and then the other event in September
2021 is there any other times you've met
with Mr lizac
no did you communicate with him at any
time other than at those events
um Mr leisak may have been in some
larger uh online group chats where
there's 30 40 other people involved
um never to my knowledge never directly
uh one-on-one he has called me
twice I think since he's been
incarcerated just simply to
say hi and I just try to offer something
offer some encouragement to him and hope
that he's doing well Etc
so you spoke to him after his arrest
yes sometime this summer
um and
I asked you generally about the people
you identified who you knew in Coots but
with respect to Mr lizek specifically
did you understand him to be a fan of
your podcasts
yes sir and you understood him to be a
member of the diagonal community
uh yes
um
are you aware that Mr lisac or at least
there's been reports that Mr lisac had a
diagonal flag flying outside the house
in which he lived with his father
so if we could pull up com917
and so uh have you ever read this
article that's on the screen Mr McKenzie
um I may have it's a tough recall it's
an it's an article in the Toronto Star
and you're quoted in it do you remember
giving a quote to the Toronto Star with
respect to an article they were writing
about Mr Isaac
I think so I've spoken Toronto Star
several times yes okay and if you could
go down to page three just so I can show
you just
you'll see in the middle of the page it
says when reached by the star this week
Mackenzie said in an email that he'd met
Chris along with thousands of people
by now through my podcast and travels
around the country which is as you
explained so we can take that down
Mr because you're aware that on February
14th the RCMP executed a search warrant
in Coots Alberta and arrested 13 people
and as a part of that arrest They seized
several weapons and body armor is that
something you're aware of
yes sir and how did you become aware of
that
I was being aware of it by once it hit
the media under that evening or the
following day
um and when did you become aware that Mr
lizac was one of the people who was
arrested
it was right around the same time that
uh
word had spread around the community
that he had been arrested was as part of
the
13 or whatever many other people were
arrested
and are you aware that Mr lizac was
charged with conspiracy to murder
uttering threats and possession of a
weapon
yes sir
after the arrests as the commission
understands that you posted a video in
Ottawa where you talked about the people
who'd gotten arrested in Coots do you
know what I'm talking about
uh yes sir I think so what I'll do is
I'll pull it up I'm not going to play it
for you because of our time but if if
you can identify it as as a video that
you participated in that would be
helpful uh com
uh five zeros911
[Music]
actually might play the first maybe 30
30 seconds
they got arrested we haven't heard from
her we don't know what's going on uh
there's some rumors they're good they're
getting [ __ ] charged with some heavy
[ __ ] I don't know what's going on there
I I don't know I know as much as you do
but okay you can stop it there
so is that a video you posted Mr
McKenzie
from one of my podcast episodes probably
shortly after that had taken place
um at the time and still presently uh
I'm very skeptical of law enforcement
um especially considering the political
nature in which there appears to be a
lot of interference going on in the
country
um I was concerned that uh
from that aspect of what was happening
out there
um again
um I don't know anything other than
what's been posted in the media and
what's been said other than that they've
been charged with what they've been
charged with
um of course if it uh evidence does
appear or is presented that uh proves
that these allegations are in fact
correct obviously that is something I
would denounce I don't uh stand by that
as I said this is not something that is
uh supported by myself it would
undermine the entire uh purpose of these
of these protests
um and until then I I hope they get a
fair trial and we'll see what happens
and you're correct Mr McKenzie the
matter is before the courts
um and so it is yet to be uh adjudicated
in the appropriate setting
um the media reports are uh that the
people were arrested there was concerned
by the police that some of them were
intending to use the weapons uh to harm
police officers or murder police
officers again that is going to be dealt
with another matter but I assume if if
that was someone's intent you would
denounce it is that did I hear that
correctly
absolutely yes
um in the video you can take it down
thank you Mr clerk you mentioned the
boys in Alberta uh when you're talking
about the rest other than Mr lizac do
you know anyone else who got arrested in
Alberta
no sir
I'm just to be to be clear I'm going to
read you the names and I just want I
want you to say yes or no yes I know
them no I don't know them
Ursula Gwen Allred
no
Luke Burke
no
Christopher Dean carbert or Carver
no Evan Banning coal nut
Johnson Chi Chao law
Jacqueline Francis Martin
Miss Martin I did have a conversation
with maybe in June or July I mean she uh
was in one of these uh video chats and
introduced herself and mentioned that
she was
um
or maybe that wasn't her Martin and Mr
McKenzie just to stop you there I I'm
interested in people you knew
as a as of February 14 2022. okay
um yeah no Justin Lyle Martin
no
Jerry Mitchell Troy Morin
yeah
Easton Stewart bowler
Anthony George Olynyk
Joanne Lynn person
no Jenks Anthony zaremba
no okay
um
Mr commissioner I'm almost done if I
could have a few more minutes please
okay uh
Mr McKenzie I'm sure you are no doubt
aware that the RCMP released photos of
the the weapons and body armor They
seized
um and uh why don't we pull up uh two
photos first with com915
and if we could just scroll out and this
is just to give you some context Mr
McKenzie this is the larger photo
showing the weapons and the ammunition
and the uh the the vest that received
and then if we could pull up com916 and
what I'm going to show you is a photo
that's zooming in on the vest that if
you're looking at the photos to the
right
I expect you know uh what I'm going to
show you at this point Mr McKenzie so
this was this is a zoom in of of the
photo we're looking at and that's one of
the pieces about that's a ballistic vest
as I understand it is that correct
uh it appears to be some some kind of
tactical vest um if it was a ballistic
it would have to have some kind of uh
ballistic plates or Kevlar or something
it's inserted into it it's not clear
right fair enough
um you see on there there's two patches
with the diagonal symbol correct
yes it does appear that that is the case
however um I was made aware of this
shortly after this took place
and uh after some scrutiny and taking a
closer look at the photos they don't
appear to be as I said there was a man
in uh Prince Edward Island who was
making these and selling them at Costa
whoever thousands of these uh went out
across uh Canada some of the United
States some to Australia
um these ones however appear to be
homemade or made by someone else as as
of now I don't recall anyone coming
forward to say that they had produces or
where these came from
[Music]
um
uh so I can't really speak to it as
their Origins right but you you agreed
with me earlier Mr McKenzie that
any one of your fans or anyone who was
in the Diagon Community who supported
you could very easily made a patch that
looks just like that isn't that right
yes
if we could pull up and this will be the
last document Mr commissioner PB dot NSC
dot can dot zero zero zero eight five
zero eight underscore r e l dot zero
zero zero one
so Mr McKenzie again this is a document
this one's from the rcmpk division and
it's a a form of report
about
um
uh the the arrest that we've been
talking about in Coots Alberta and if we
can scroll down to where it says current
situation
uh it says in the second bullet point a
ballistic vest was seized during the
search warrant at the residence in Coots
which contained a patch reflective of
the diagonalon flag It is believed that
this vest belongs to one of the accused
Christopher lizac open source
information has linked lizac to redacted
name so Mr McKenzie this isn't your
report I know you didn't produce it but
you would agree with me that from the
rcmp's perspective they believe that the
vest with the dialogue diagonal symbol
was Mr Liza's correct
sorry your Council had an objection so
yes it's unfair to this witness to ask
him to speculate what uh is in the
rcmp's mind and their perspective about
intelligence
uh I think maybe the question wasn't
that well framed but the the quote
speaks for itself if he could ask
whether he agrees with with the quote is
is is on the rcmb letterhead I mean it's
really not much further than that I take
it no I I actually withdraw the question
Mr Cruiser I agree that he has no uh uh
he he doesn't know why the RCMP made
their observations so I agree with that
and I withdraw it and those are my
questions thank you okay
so uh now we'll go with the first the
Convoy organizers
Convoy organizers are seeding their time
to Mr McKenzie's counsel sir
okay
uh government of Canada
foreign
Mr McKenzie my name is Stephen aylward
I'm one of the lawyers for the
government of Canada
Mr McKenzie you described Diagon as a
Grassroots Community do I have that
right
um no I would say it's Grassroots it's
spread from from my imagination and uh I
create the the content from which the
the uh Lord Amusement entertainment and
so on attracts people to to it in which
they were then either self-identify as a
fan or not
okay and you've described yourself as
the de facto leader of Diagon
no that's not correct I've never
described myself in that manner that's a
that's been put forward into the media
Again by people at the Canadian 88
Network again this is a figment of my
imagination in a fictional world
you can't really lead a fictional World
exactly but the letter to the Senate
that a commission Council brought up
earlier you had described yourself as a
de facto leader in quotes if I take it
then you're saying that was being used
ironically in that kind
yes I was trying to to identify myself
as the person in question that they said
it was
um debating about and and the House of
Commons were talking about uh which
alarmed me and uh I was acting in the
interest of protecting
um not only myself but other people that
identified as fans and followers of mine
and it was clear that this was a uh an
issue of national importance that I felt
obliged to say something about it rather
than um the ignorant right and you have
no formal authority over anyone who's uh
part of the diagonal Community is that
right
that's correct there's no hierarchy
there's no uh rank system Membership
Code of Conduct uniforms anything like
this it's a very informal uh again I
would positive if you're a fan of the
the calamary Flames or Montreal
Canadians or not or something it's just
as simple as saying you like it or you
don't
okay and you you view yourself as
somewhat of a calming presence within
the Diagon community
no I
I was the the I guess central figure
from which the rest of it sort of orbits
okay earlier you agreed with commission
Council that you had put out messages
urging people in Ottawa not to use
violence or to act unlawfully you agree
with that
correct I did use my platform to
try my best to again put put forward
messages and
messages uh responsible messaging yes
and you were putting out those messages
because you were concerned that some
members of the Diagon Community would
use violence or would act unlawfully
my concern was that something could
happen outside of my control and I would
rather have had say something on record
of what I would expect people to you
know to behave lawfully and peacefully
um so that they if they follow me listen
to me and they've heard that and then
chosen to act on their own and do
something
um something outside the desires of you
know myself and that's uh not really
something I can control I can't control
what other people want to do but I
didn't want to make it clear that this
was this was my intention was a peaceful
demonstration
and you explained that there were other
members of the diagonal Community with
you in Ottawa at the time of the freedom
Convoy
that's right how many would you say
um there was a um a property that uh we
were staying on outside the city limits
that had been offered up by by someone
who um was a fan he had a vacant uh
building no furniture but you know it's
got a roof it's got heat so you could
stay there at times there were three or
four or five of us other times as many
as 20.
and were there other people that you saw
in Ottawa with diagonalon uh
symbols who weren't part of that group
I didn't personally observe any uh one
one individual I did see that had had a
flag but outside of that I didn't see
any uh any symbolism or Flags or patches
or so on and I did encounter a number of
people that recognized me and wanted to
have a picture and talk and shake hands
and so on
could we please call up
ssm.nsc.ca n Dot
six rows seven nine
underscore Rel dot zero zero zero one
um Mr McKenzie are you aware of reports
that members of The Plaid Army put out a
YouTube video in which they expressed
the hope that the
Freedom Convoy in Ottawa would be the
Canadian version of the January 6 riot
in Capitol Hill
I believe I I know the the clip that
you're referring to which is again taken
out of uh context of a much larger uh
presentation broadcast of which I was
not uh
party to
um obviously um I can't speak to that
person's intentions or what they meant
by that but um I will reinforce that I
again it was not my intention to see any
kind of violence political violence or
or anything like that because it again
undermines the intentions and uh you
know objectives of the protesters which
was to peacefully demonstrate their
discontent
thank you if we could actually pull up
the next uh documents a video uh PB dot
c a n dot four zeros1820
underscore Rel point zero zero zero one
and if we could start the video at the
55 second mark
please
I just while we're calling that up
um you're aware that there was a deal
that was struck between some of the
protest organizers in Ottawa and the
City of Ottawa
I don't believe so no
um
Council if you'll just allow brief
Indulgence uh we're having a bit of
difficulty locating that
foreign
maybe I'll move on to the next topic and
then I'll come back to that
um
in terms of the Coots incident that Mr
Mather was just discussing with you were
you aware that there were a number of
individuals who traveled from Ottawa to
uh who were at the freedom Convoy event
in Ottawa who then traveled to Coots
no sir
and in particular to clarify referring
to individuals who are charged as part
of that RCMP operation
yeah sir when just a moment ago when you
were describing the uh we were looking
at a photo of a uh some sort of body
armor that had the uh diagonalon symbol
on it and you were expressing some
concerns about the authenticity of the
Diagon uh symbol there uh just to be
clear were you suggesting that uh the
diagonalon symbol had been planted there
by law enforcement
uh again uh at the time and still I am
skeptical of um of the RCP in
particularly but a law enforcement in
Canada there is a history of things like
this taking place
um it's not outside the realm of
possibility that something like that is
very easily replicated could be planted
I'm not suggesting that it certainly has
or has not but I would leave that open
to possibility yes
yeah
I take it there's still some issue in
pulling up that video
correct Council
is it going to be a while or should uh
should this be put off to a little later
um this may take a little while
commissioner so maybe if if you're
agreeable uh you can complete your
examination subject to this video and we
can slot you in uh a little bit in maybe
10 minutes whenever this is sorted out
yes that's fine is it I did have one
other video clip that I wanted to play
is it possible to pull up
the uh a different video clip
oh sure Council I can assist uh if you
have the doc ID uh yes okay it's
com50911 the video that was played
earlier
and if we could just start that around
the 30 second mark
with that uh thanks you know from uh
media
as a federal agent
[Music]
do what I can do cheers guys thank you
so much I appreciate it I hope you had a
good time anybody
[Applause]
[Music]
oh did we succeed in that
and as as promised I want to play you
this video uh this is that my good dear
friend Greg arcade you're a legend and a
wonderful man uh I love you brother
thank you so much for the work that
you've done and continue to do for this
country and your people uh you're an
underrated person and uh in the words of
the federal uh
and so earlier you mentioned that there
were some videos in which you had urged
people in Ottawa not to use violence not
to
uh unlawfully do you view your comments
uh you you want to dance let's dance or
uh hold uh I believe it was hold the
[ __ ] down uh do you view those comments
as in line with uh with your earlier
messaging
there was no attention to uh convey that
the the protesters and the demonstrators
have no intention of relinquishing their
right to peacefully demonstrate it was
clear at the time that the
Rumblings and things I've been hearing
and seeing that it was the intention of
the federal government to use uh to use
Force to dispel these people so as I
said in the video and I've been saying
for for a long time is you know to force
the timer to act like one you simply
refuse to to uh
to to bend to their will and they will
reveal themselves to be who they are in
this case they deploy the uh RCP and
various police forces and beat people
with batons and shot them with tear gas
canisters and trampled in indigenous uh
elderly woman with a horse another man
was dragged lifelessly through a crowd
and so on so that was the price that uh
people were willing to pay and endure uh
for for the Canadian people to show them
um the true face of what it was they
were standing against
okay thank you uh subject if I might ask
for just two minutes later to address
that issue with the video I think it's
now available oh so so celt I believe
it's been renumbered to
poe.doj6014 okay it's an eight minute
long video correct yes that's right okay
uh if we could start it at the 55 second
Mark please
um
I'm sure a lot of people have been
seeing this Randy Hillier has spoken
about this already
um tomorrow allegedly there's some kind
of deal being signed or agreed upon by
you know the quote unquote truckers uh
with the city with the government
however they're gonna move some vehicles
or relocate to this kind of stuff
um
it's been expressed to me by by people
you know connected inside the inside the
uh the movement there to the actual
Truckers
um
that
the the this this this leadership cell
of uh you know political operatives like
uh Victor and Dagny
um
are not playing uh they're not on
they're not on side guys
they are so they haven't released a dime
of the money
at all
um these guys are sitting out there you
know they're paying they got nine
thousand dollars a month they're making
these payments on these trucks they're
not they're not getting paid
um you know they're missing mortgage
payments now
um and this this deal tomorrow
is uh fraudulent
um a lot of the names that are attached
to it
um people you know have
uh so does I I mentioned a deal earlier
between protest organizers in the city
does that video does that refresh your
memory about that issue
uh yeah
I was unclear as to what you what you
were referring to it's something I there
was a some kind of negotiation was
taking place to move some trucks from
one place to another
um I don't again I wasn't intimately
involved I don't know exactly the
details of that but
um
to some extent I think I'm not uh not
sure exactly safe to say you were urging
your followers not to go along with that
deal
I was expressing
expressing um there was a number of
names that had appeared that somehow
had uh gotten into the
leadership Cadre or something as you can
describe that I was very skeptical of
their intentions and I had some
skepticism and fear that this was uh
so things were moving in in a malicious
Direction
thank you
okay thank you
next I think it's the uh
Ottawa Coalition there of residents and
businesses
uh good afternoon Mr McKenzie I'm not
sure if you can see me there uh my name
is Paul champ I'm a lawyer for the
Ottawa Coalition of residents and
businesses the people from downtown
Ottawa um just have a couple questions
for you look
um you mentioned uh in your testimony
about getting um the screen captures of
of text group texts uh from RCMP
officers you got that from a current
RCMP member is that right
at the time it was uh delivered to me I
understood that to be the case I can't
speak to if this person is still
employed or not okay
okay and um do you occasionally have
interactions uh of people who are fans
or are interested in what you say or
supporters who are current uh members of
law enforcement
yes that's correct
and uh while you were in Ottawa where
you uh during the the Convoy protest
were you in communication with some of
these uh individuals who are current law
enforcement members
and our supporters of yours
not uh not directly no
and have you ever been uh
um in contact with or anyone
communicated to you who is a current
member of the Canadian Security
intelligence service who's a supporter
of you
or a fan of you
I've actually made
um numerous overtures and offers to
speak to the Canadian Security
intelligence service to try to um
shed some light on on you know myself
and this community that they seem so
concerned about and as of today is the
first day that I've ever been asked a
single question by anyone in any
official capacity about it right
right
um and you mentioned that uh you had
um three or four people or sometimes as
many as 20 people staying with you in
the same location in Ottawa is that
right
correct yes and those were up to 20
people who were uh uh supporters or fans
of yours
yes that's great and uh some of these
people were former members of the
military or current members of the
military
Veterans of yourself
do not think so
um I have to go through a list of
refresh my memory but no one's jumping
out at me I don't think so I believe
they're all uh civilians
uh did any of them uh uh did any of them
uh bring any Firearms with them
no sir I actually went out of my way to
make sure that was adamantly very clear
that that would uh not be something I
would I would uh endorse and it's not a
good idea and again it would be a very
dangerous situation it's illegal and
it's undermining
um the objectives of the protesters for
sure
um yeah you were concerned about that
right that um some some people in the
protest uh might undermine the purpose
of the protest by becoming violent you
didn't want that to happen correct
that's correct and that's why you made
that message out to people to to not be
violent is that right
yes sir because you you knew some of the
people who were there could be volatile
and could be uh violent is that right
I understand that uh in great numbers of
people and tens of thousands of people
there is uh always going to be outliers
of folks who you know may be unhinged
they may be mentally ill there could be
any number of factors that may uh
contribute to something and and I was
just doing my best to mitigate any
potential any influence that I have
um to try to you know push things in a
positive direction rather than you know
say nothing or or Worse contribute to
you know something uh negative happening
and
um when you were in Ottawa did you have
contact with Mr Randy Hillier
once maybe twice
um it didn't have much of a voice he was
feeling under the weather but you know I
I met him once twice while you were in
Ottawa
correct
and
um
when you got the information about the
rcmb text did you pass that on to anyone
uh in the Convoy uh leadership
uh no sir I looked at it I sat with it
for about 10 minutes and I just um
decided to publish it on my telegram
page for everyone to look at and from
there it went to
uh Charter signal canvex team Rebel news
took it uh various other
um various other independent journalists
and so on took uh took note of it uh
notably the Legacy Media CBC and so on
did not comment or provide any coverage
or inside of that but I simply just put
it out there and it you know went off on
its own Into the Wild
and uh you you met with Mr Hilliard did
you meet with any other
um elected political officials uh while
you were in Ottawa during the Convoy
protest
uh no sir either federally or
provincially
yeah
and uh you'd indicated in your testimony
that uh you met Miss uh Tamara Leach
this summer
I spoke to her on the phone I did see
Tamara Leach briefly she walked by me
um somewhere in a hotel lobby but I
hadn't had any formal interaction
conversation or anything with her until
I slipped her on the phone sometime and
I want to say August
and the two of you uh you were
discussing uh what was what was the
topic you were discussing this upcoming
inquiry or other issues
no she's actually called to express uh
concerned and so on for my uh legal
situation
for your legal situation
I'm sorry that this
okay thank you very much Mr McKenzie
okay thank you
next the uh Ottawa Police Service
good afternoon Mr Mackenzie my name is
Jessica Barrow and I'm counsel for the
Ottawa Police Service can you see and
hear me all right
candle excellent
um I'm going to start with something
that you testified to earlier and you
indicated that uh in the lead-up to the
events in Ottawa you are of the view
that this was not going to be what you
referred to as an in and out event but
just to be clear you were not one of the
organizers of this event correct
that's correct I I believe I may have
been misconstrued as such or perceived
to be a bigger personality in this
simply because of my social media
presence and a video that I've released
basically reacting to
um the convergence of the trucks moving
towards Ottawa I was you know kind of
excited by it and interested in what was
going to happen that that video achieved
a fair amount of attraction in place so
I think maybe people Associated me with
that for that reason uh however I know I
had no time but I have any contact with
any organizers I didn't ask for any
money take any money if you have any
money I had no hand in logistics
planning anything like that I was simply
uh there of my own volition to observe
and you know just be there for the
experience so you really had no
knowledge as to the specific intentions
of the organizers except for whatever
perhaps you were seeing online is that
fair
the
as far as the intentions were concerned
I was uh
basically just collating the information
that I could find in social media what
people were saying I was aware of who
some of the people were
um uh for that reason and um they were
echoing the same you know similar kind
of sentiments they were there to you
know to protest and show their
discontent and exercise their rights
um to do so and so on um I didn't have
any I hadn't seen anything disagreeable
with that I didn't see any
um intentions of you know uh violence or
so on
right but with respect to your comment
in terms of this not being an in and out
event
um are you aware that the organizers or
some of them testified earlier this week
that this event become became much more
significant than they had really
anticipated
um no I was not I haven't been able to
uh view much of it or hear much of uh
what's transpired earlier it was
apparent to me just simply because of
the
Canada's very large country and uh the
effort required just to Simply go to
Ottawa from Alberta and British Columbia
um Indian Halifax and so on
um indicated to me in the numbers of
which people were going indicating to me
that this was not going to be a a quick
uh trip to the city as we were are you
aware that similarly that some of the
organizers testified that they had not
anticipated staying as long as they
ultimately did
uh
I'm going to move on to the issue of
social media obviously we heard some
testimony from you today about the your
particular use of social media would you
agree with me that social media is a
tool that some people use to influence
the actions of others
yes of course in fact it's actually a
career now being a social media
influencer
uh yes some people uh make a living that
way
and it's a tool that's used to encourage
people to buy things or used for social
advocacy
uh yes I think it's empowered a lot of
people to um
Express their voice in the world and
establish themselves as as such if they
want to act similarly to the way that
corporate broadcasting and larger
companies and stuff do to push whatever
products ideas and things that they want
to they can now compete with them in
that same kind of uh that same kind of
space I suppose so then I take it you
would agree with me that social media
has the power both unintentionally and
intentionally to influence the actions
of others
I I would say that anything that anyone
is paying a large amount of attention if
you just hold on about your your council
is is standing up here I'm not sure
social media can have an intent I'm not
sure the question is precise and I'm not
sure how relevant it is in the
circumstances perhaps social media users
could have
that kind of power but
my client
I don't think it's fair for him to
testify about the power that social
media has in terms of intent and lack of
intent I was speaking specifically to
social media influencers but I'm happy
to be more clear if that's required I
think we have to be more clear social
media is something we should be looking
into but uh sure try and rephrase the
question happy too so to be clear Mr
McKenzie I'm speaking obviously
specifically to the users that are using
social media and in terms of influencing
others my question was would you agree
with me that those using social media
can both intentionally and
unintentionally influence others
uh yes of course I would I would imagine
that any any form of uh media whether
it's social media television movies
music and if they're inundated
especially
um
you know in in sort of
um a way that that becomes a large focus
of their their day-to-day lives and then
it would have an impact on the way that
they uh
view things of course
and you indicated earlier that depending
on the platform and depending on the
specific post
um that anywhere between tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
people have followed you
it's unclear and there's no real way to
to measure
um but tens of thousands would would
probably be a fair assessment yes I
think you've you may have indicated that
one of your YouTube videos may have
garnered up to half a million views do I
have that incorrect
uh no several of them have in the past
yes okay so I'm not going to take you to
this um specific document but for the
record it's OPP 835 and it's a document
published by the Canadian anti-hate
Network which I take from your earlier
testimony you disagree with but it
describes dagelon also referred to as
plaid Army as a conspiracy-based network
that is increasingly evolving into a
militia
comprising neo-fascists who anticipate a
violent revolution which Stables these
power I take it you disagree with that
assessment of the organization is that
fair
yes I disagree and I I don't agree that
this is an or my imagination is an
organization of any kind I'm not clear
on what neo-fascist accelerations means
um and in my opinion the Canadian ta
network is not a credible uh
uh news or information or research
source fair enough but I take it you
would agree with me that at least some
people might interpret your messaging in
that way because obviously the Canadian
anti-hate network does
again
um sure uh I can't control how people in
interpret or don't interpret uh you know
any number of things I can only control
the things that I say and and conduct
myself the best that I can and if it's
interpreted the wrong way and I'm happy
to clarify but I can't again
be expected to control the
interpretations of other people fair
enough I'll just ask one more question
because I believe I'm getting the signal
that I'm out of time but as a follow-up
to that there were a few veiled
references to violence that we saw
earlier Council take you to and you
indicated in response to those that it
certainly wasn't your intention to
promote violence and that your followers
would know that is that a fair
assessment of your answer
but it's true that you have not
obviously spoken to all of your
followers right
well I don't exactly take attendance so
there's there's no way to know who is
listening to me at any number of times
all I can do is use my platforms
accordingly and if it's listened to or
Not by individual people is not within
my control and so you obviously couldn't
know how they are interpreting your
message
uh you know
okay thank you those are my questions
okay next is the Ontario Provincial
Police
commissioner I have no questions thank
you
okay next is uh Council for uh former
Chief slowly commissioner also no
questions for the witness thank you
okay next is the government of Alberta
okay the Democracy fund
jccf uh
xant for the citizens for Freedom
um our group would like to seat our time
to council for the witness
oh that seems to be a popular person uh
Mr foda I uh I guess it's your turn they
seem to have
collected a lot of support
I won't need all the time Mr
commissioner but I'm happy to commence
now go ahead thank you sir
good afternoon Mr McKenzie can you see
me
this is the first time you've seen me
actually on video
that was correct
I want to start off with um just
covering some of the questions that you
were asked by the last Council Council
for the Ottawa Police Service
okay the Canada anti-hate Network
you were asked about sort of the
information that they've put out there
about you are you aware of the Canada
anti-hate network has itself spread any
information misinformation during the
Convoy
uh yes as a matter of fact the the
president or the the chief as I
understand it Mr Farber was on the
national television advising the the
nation of Canada that anti-semitic
Flyers were being distributed throughout
downtown Ottawa as a result of the the
nature of the people involved when in
fact that was a screen grab from an
event in Miami Florida that had taken
place weeks earlier
and do you know if um the Canada
anti-hate networks views about you have
been relied upon by law enforcement or
other senior officials in the federal
government
yes I have through again legal
disclosure documents referenced by by
law enforcement and open source
intelligence and so on there are a
number of uh pages and articles and
things written by the Canadian NTA
Network used as justification for their
assessment of me
and
um
have you ever had any communication with
anyone from the Canada nt8 Network
uh I have actually
um one of their journalists
uh Mr Smith I believe uh reached out to
me in um just as late as February uh of
this year previous to that no one had
ever approached me for a comment or or
explanation these were content to just
publish things sometimes with no bylines
whatsoever written by ostensibly no one
um I attempted to explain and and uh
kind of level you know man-to-man with
Mr Smith about you know who I am and so
on uh that didn't really go anywhere I'd
also been in contact
UM informally casually with Mr Kirk
Phillips over uh over Twitter
um over the past uh several months
and it was bad
and did your conversations have anything
to do about the Convoy or your alleged
extremist activities
no they were
um pretty casual in nature
um just about uh kind of surface level
things about things about uh other you
know personalities and stuff
um other baby casualties sometimes
different beers that we enjoyed things
like this
um you were asked
um questions about social media and
social media influence influencers and
their ability to either unintentionally
or intentionally influence others what
are your views on
um Legacy Media being able to do that
well um again yeah with seeing the size
of the platform that it has and the
amount of funding that's being dumped
into it from the Canadian taxpayer it's
um one of the the bigger microphones
that exists and it's my opinion that it
has
um an extreme amount of bias and has
been almost weaponized in that way to uh
push state and government messaging to
influence and you know perhaps correct
the way that uh people are thinking as
it benefits uh the people that pay their
bills
uh I I'd like to pull up uh poe.jmk
seven zeroes one
it's an article from the Globe and Mail
can you see this article on your screen
Mr McKenzie
yes sir are you familiar with it
uh no I've never seen this before
okay if we could scroll down a little
bit
and stop right there for a moment can
you please um read that Mr McKenzie and
tell us when you're done
uh yes sir you want me to read it aloud
or just twice no just to yourself I'm
gonna just cover some of the content in
that
okay
yeah I've got it thanks okay if we could
go down a little bit further
okay and a little bit further
foreign
okay and then just a little bit further
[Music]
great so
um this uh this was an article that was
published around February 16th after the
emergencies Act was invoked by the
government
okay and there are comments made by
Public Safety Minister uh about
um that were later clarified uh by his
spokesperson Mr Mendicino didn't name
any any organization during the news
conference but his spokesperson
Alexandra Cohen uh later said that The
Minister's remarks were in reference to
diagonal
if we could go up just a little bit
further to the comments that were
actually made by Mr Mendocino for no
further up please
um right there so quote it could have
been deadly for Citizens protesters and
officers we need to be clear-eyed about
the seriousness of these incidents and
indeed several of the individuals at
Coots have strong ties to a far-right
extreme organizations with leaders who
are in Ottawa how many members
uh sorry how many of the individuals at
Coots did you have any ties to
uh just the the again the Mr Leicester
equipment uh twice and would you
consider that to be strong ties
no uh would you consider this to be an
example of misinformation or no
yes I would
um I'd like to
um pull up some of the clips sir that um
Council have referenced but that we've
not actually gone over with you if I
could first ask that
um
JMK
uh zero zero zero I think there's seven
zeros and four
this is a clip I understand from your
social media dated January 23rd of this
year sir
so as long
as long as everybody just keeps their
head
don't do anything stupid say anything
stupid I mean nothing illegal don't even
speed don't give them anything
where was that video taken sir
uh that video was filmed uh outside uh
downtown the Waterfront and picked on a
Scotia where I live
and what was your intent in putting out
that video
that was
um the day or two days prior to being uh
heading down to Ottawa I know a lot of
people were on their way they were
excited to go and so on I was it was my
intent to try and set a tone of of
extreme levels of um of of a situational
awareness and attentiveness to the fact
that there would be a lot of scrubby uh
on on everyone and so it was imperative
that people conduct themselves in a
responsible and lawful manner
if we could play another clip please uh
seven zeros to JMK seven zeros two this
is a clip I understand Mr beaver and uh
if you sorry if we could just go back to
the beginning Mr McKenzie I understand
this was taken on January 28th if you
could please just watch it
please be on your best behavior and uh
if you see anything odd or strange or uh
makes you nervous or uncomfortable uh
leave leave immediately and
um keep your you know your your phone uh
your camera is probably your your best
defense now if you see anything strange
uh you know film it
where was um this video taken sir
uh
first of you take it in in the uh the uh
residents I mentioned earlier that we uh
stayed at a large amount of time uh
outside the city of Ottawa
and what was the message that you were
trying to convey
um I was just trying to keep people safe
and again if they'd know I obviously
would want them to intervene into
something that seemed uh you know unsafe
or dangerous but if they could you know
I believe that the is
as dangerous they could be the the
smartphones that people have can be
their best defense they can film uh you
know what's happening around them and
protect themselves in that way and and
uh if they were to encounter or see
anything
disturbing or or frightening or alarming
um then they should uh leave and get
away from that and then
um potentially even report it to uh
authorities if necessary
speaking about reporting things to
authorities have you ever reported
extremist Behavior to authorities
yes can you please tell us about that
one example
um
this would have been fall I think of
2021
um there was a group online identifying
themselves as links something it was
armed man in the woods with masks one of
them specifically said uh this is a call
to Arms which as I understand is an
illegal thing to do
um it was very clear that they intended
to
um we're promoting the idea of arming uh
arming people arming citizens I think I
think it was acronym for liberating our
neighborhood or something like that
um and to engage the you know forces of
the state in violent confrontation they
were
commenting on my videos and inferring
that they were trying to connect with me
and so on uh I found this very alarming
and again putting my potentially myself
at risk but other you know people that
uh follow me and it could be exposed to
this and spared in whatever was going on
there so I once I became aware of the
video I immediately called the the the
amount of police about it
and did you receive a response
I did they called me back they they
asked me you know what I knew about it
um you know if anything I said all I
know is what I've seen on the internet
I'm simply bringing it to your attention
because if I were you this is something
that would concern me
um and that was pretty much the end of
that interaction I'm not sure uh
whatever took place
after that but um
you didn't have follow-up after that
um
I don't think so I think there was one
Constable from from Saskatchewan that
may have called me to say they may have
more questions in the future but uh that
was the end of that interaction were you
willing to have a continuous
relationship with law enforcement to
assist them in identifying legitimate
threats to Public Safety of course if I
could if there was anything for me to to
give them or assist them in any way I
would have this
um
I'd like to play another clip jmk701
and my understanding is that this is a
clip from February 5th
[Music]
don't do anything stupid and don't give
in to their uh attempts to goad you into
into uh anything they can use against
you
because this is literally all they have
at this point it's
a couple of couple of sentences out of
context on the internet and uh an old
man in a casting
it's ridiculous you know meanwhile uh
the the high horse they stand on oh
we're so much better people we're so
much better people
will look real morning Superior said the
man in blackface
foreign
where were you when this video was taken
sir
uh I believe I was driving traveling
back to Ottawa from from the maritimes
okay can you please tell the
commissioner
um sort of what your
um itinerary was during the Convoy
protests
um from the beginning to end or
yeah my understanding is that you were
not in Ottawa the entire time can you uh
sort of just go over in general terms
your itinerary
so I uh he left the maritimes um again a
couple of days I arrived one or two days
before the trucks showed up I picked up
a couple of uh friends and Associates uh
they wanted to go they just carved kind
of a carpool idea so I would take them
uh we went down
um met up with some people stayed at the
location I mentioned and then after
roughly five days or so uh these these
gentlemen had to go home I drove them
home I only intended to stay uh for that
length of time
um and then when I got home I decided I
was it was it was it was uh unclear how
long this was going to go on so I
decided to go back
a few days later
um that's around the times when I made
that video and then I stayed in Ottawa
the Ottawa area for the duration until
probably
three to four days after the uh
invocation of the emergency act and
everyone was clearing out of downtown
um then uh my partner and I
um
left and uh when we headed back to the
maritimes
when you were in Ottawa did you engage
in any illegal activity
no did you bring a vehicle
yes I drove my uh my personal vehicle to
a pickup truck where did you park
um either on the the farm where we were
staying or Hotel parking lots that you
know would stay on or if it was in the
interest of going downtown to to uh to
see the protest I would park in parking
lots and that were available as close as
possible and then walk the remaining a
couple of blocks did you pay for parking
yes did you assault anyone while you
were in Ottawa
no threaten anyone while you were there
no did you engage in violent Behavior
no sir were you armed
no were you charged with any offenses in
relation to your participation to the
con in the Convoy in Ottawa
no sir do you believe or do you know
whether or not you're public uh
political commentary has drawn the ire
of officials
that is my belief yes
sir you were asked questions about
uh whether you had any whether a Diagon
had any
um
structure I think you were asked if you
had any formal authority over anyone in
the diagonal community and I believe you
indicated that there was no hierarchy or
no formal structure
correct to be fair you have a vice
president
uh yes could you tell the commissioner
who your vice president is
uh
the vice president is of diagonal which
is of my imagination he is a uh a my
sidekick that has evolved over the years
he's a demonic goat figurine named
Philip with a
very very serious narcotics problem and
uh time traveling ability
do you think any reasonable person who
consumes your content either regularly
or semi-regularly would actually
consider Diagon to be an organization
I would think not no
how do you explain
what is included in intelligence reports
and what is expressed in uh National
media and expressed by Ministers of the
highest level in our country
it's my opinion that
the
foundational work by the Canadian to
hate Network as
pertains to targeting me as a previously
government-funded and has enjoyed a fair
amount of government funding to Target
and smear people
um
that they you know consider perhaps
politically inconvenient or people that
just uh will want to shut up
um they regularly engage in defamatory
statements uh libless action things like
this out of context statements they'll
take a clip here a sentence there and
Stitch it together and make it appear as
as something that is not
um from there some media Outlets Legacy
Media Outlets um lazily unfortunately it
appears uh took it at face value copy
paste print the story
then which is uh consumed by
um police officers which uh again
unfortunately rather than doing any
digging themselves or investigating or
asking me a single question take these
things at face value and compile these
reports and up the uh up the network it
goes until it lands on the desk of the
public safety minister or you know
perhaps even the prime minister's office
where they're faced with these uh
scenarios that have no basis in reality
um I consider this entire situation
entirely avoidable this um none of this
needed to happen it's absurd and I
consider it the single most embarrassing
and grotesque intelligence failure in
National History
Mr Mather
um when he first started asking you
questions clarified that you're you're
obviously testifying from in custody
yes sir okay and my understanding is you
have no criminal record
how do you intend on pleading to all of
the charges that you face
they're not guilty those are my
questions
okay thank you any re-examination uh no
Mr commissioner thank you okay well
thank you for your testimony uh Mr
McKenzie and good luck with your trials
thank you
okay next uh we're going to take the
afternoon break and then we'll come back
with our Final witness of the day end of
the week
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
order a lot
the commission has reconvened the
commissioner Pro
thank you commissioner uh Jeffrey Leon
co-lead Council for the commission the
next witness is Daniel bullford
okay go ahead
Mr Beaufort will you swear on a
religious document or do you wish to
affirm on the Bible please
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out
Daniel Joseph Wolford b-u-l-f-o-r-d
do you swear that the evidence to be
given by you to this commission shall be
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the true self of God I do so swear
thank you
good afternoon Mr Beaufort uh uh clerk
could you please put up hrf40-1553
um
you recognize this as a statement that
you prepared for the commission
yes sir I do okay we will
uh put that in in evidence and if you
ever need to refer to the statement
while I'm asking you questions you'll
let me know okay yes sir you can take
that down now
I understand that um you were
born in Saskatchewan and resided in
Northern Alberta for several years
yes that's correct and
is it necessary that Council
speaks to the protection
he's already given that uh okay thank
you protection but he may want to do it
again uh sir that protection has already
been marked as an exhibit you're listed
in the invocation thank you simply for
the record I'll refer to the
statement that's in the record and the
fact that you are under subpoena
from the commission and as a result
it will be deemed that you've objected
to each answer to seek the protection of
the relevant Evidence Act okay thank you
commissioner thank you for that reminder
uh
now I understand that you spent uh 15
years in the RCMP that's correct and uh
tell us briefly your career in the RCMP
I joined the RCMP in August of 2006. I
graduated from the depot training
academy
January 2007 I was posted to White Horse
Yukon as a general duty Constable for
roughly four years
in December 2010 I transferred to Mayo
Yukon a smaller more remote Community
four hours north of white horse
I was posted there for roughly two and a
half years
and then I transferred to Ottawa where
for the remainder of my career I was a
full-time sniper Observer on the
national division Emergency Response
Team
you and you resigned from the RCMP in
December 2021 that's correct and why did
you do that
I spoke out publicly against the federal
government vaccination mandate for
covid-19 vaccines
and
after speaking out publicly my security
clearance was revoked
and I knew that I would be
subject to disciplinary action
and after I reviewed what my options
were in regards to that
I discovered that if I was terminated
for misconduct which I suspected would
be the case
I could potentially lose roughly half of
my pension transfer value so I made the
decision to resign oh to
out of fear that I would not be able to
set my family up
Finance adequately financially in the
future
thank you and
beyond that has have the covid-19 public
health measures affected you or your
family
yes sir very much
can you say briefly why
well the obvious beginning is that I
felt it necessary to leave my 15-year
career which I was
provided 15 dedicated years of service
to the Mounted Police I was not a
complainer I worked hard I was
passionate about my craft
I I think I had a reputation of being a
hard-working professional
then beyond that
my
my wife and I were no longer permitted
access to public spaces that we as tax
paying Canadians were helping fund
and that prevented us from being
involved in our children's activities
such as minor hockey which we were both
heavily involved in for
a number of years roughly six years
um
we couldn't travel
to see our family in Northern Alberta
which you know living in the second
largest land mass country in the world
was problematic so it's roughly 40 hours
of drive time
and
we lost neighbors and friends who were
perfectly fine to
have relationships with us until the
vaccine passport deadline kicked in
and then we were no longer worthy to
speak to
and beyond that uh
there was a very heightened state of
anxiety about how much further
the situation in Canada would degenerate
and what I mean by that
is that
the dehumanization effort had begun
and that was in I believe that was in
August of 2021 when the Prime Minister
had initially announced the federal the
impending Federal vaccination mandate
and then he was campaigning into
September for his snap election
and he was making comments
regarding okay sir we only have an hour
okay uh can we I think the commissioner
understands what you're saying the
ultimate problem was that
the Canadian population was led to
believe that people like myself and my
family were a threat to other people and
their children which was not true by his
own admission in July of 2021 on camera
hey can you're a member of
an organization mounties for Freedom
that opposes Public Health measures and
specifically covid-19 vaccine
that's correct and also police stand on
guard for thee which are police officers
active and retired who State admission
includes to repair and regain public
Trust
being damaged or lost due to the
enforcement measures of
emerge or sorry due to the enforcement
emergency measures correct
that's correct and then you're also on
The Advisory Board of taking back our
freedoms that's correct and we've heard
uh taking back our freedoms about that
organization uh in the evidence in
previous evidence I take it it was
founded to push back against covid-19
vaccine man mandates
foreign
I would say that's accurate but and in
general the
the covid measures that were
resulting in a segregation of our
society
so not just the Mandate but the passport
as well
and its Mission has expanded to focus on
rejuvenating Canada's democracy and
institutions correct that's correct
now
when did you first learn of the freedom
Convoy
at least one week prior to its arrival
in Ottawa probably before that
saw circulating videos on social media
about it it's growing
size and travel across Canada
and did somebody contact you to become
involved with the Convoy when it arrived
in Ottawa
so
initially
I was supposed to work in a volunteer
security capacity
for a number of the doctors
that were speaking out against the covid
19 Health measures and vaccinations
because they had received a number of
threats
so myself and a number of other
individuals with similar training in
close protection were going to be
providing a volunteer security service
to them
and and who asked you to do that that
was uh through taking back our freedoms
and was there somebody specific that
asked you George George Bears thank you
and I take it that uh before the Convoy
arrived Your Role you were asked to take
on an expanded role is that right
yes so
I was it was the I believe it was the
night of January 25th
I was called by a personal friend
asking for help with volunteer security
for adopt a trucker
so I met with the adopt a trucker
volunteers the following morning
uh with Mr Chris Guerra was there that
was the first time I'd ever encountered
him
and
based on what I
saw
from this small group of volunteers that
had very little time
to prepare for this major major event
that was about to land in Ottawa I felt
that
I could be
better put to use in assisting them
and I could pass off the doctor security
role to others and he became in charge
of VIP security
no that so that was the role that I
passed off to others I did you have a
title in in this new position
again the title would be volunteer
security coordinator and then I ended up
becoming a police liaison as well
and when did you start uh do you recall
the date that day January 26th okay and
um
were you told how many vehicles were
going to arrive in in the convey no I
was not there was
you're getting varied numbers from
circulating social media you know
anywhere between 10 000 Vehicles upwards
of 50 000 vehicles I had no idea of an
accurate number
and did how long did you understand that
the
Convoy would be staying in Ottawa
at that time my understanding was that
the Convoy intended to come to Ottawa
and stay until mandates were lifted
and you mentioned that you uh became a
police a liaison did you have
communications with the Ontario Police
Service
I sorry the Ottawa Police Service yes I
had communication regularly with the
Ottawa Police Service
the Parliamentary police Protective
Service pardon me
the opp and the RCMP
and just generally what function did you
perform uh in liaising with those police
forces
well there was a tremendous amount of
information coming in to me on any given
day and so what I viewed my primary
function what I spent the majority of my
time doing was triaging information that
could have been any type of threat to
Public Safety anything that I felt had
any kind of credibility or something
that could was beyond my scope to verify
I would forward that to the police
all of the different police Liaisons I
was connecting with
and I take I understand you were working
out of the
Swiss hotel where there was an operation
and logistical Support Center that's
correct and you formed a an incident you
command using that model
yeah that's correct so there was a
number of us volunteers that
um had worked in first responder type
jobs
you know police paramedic some uh a lot
of uh firefighters from with outside of
the city of Ottawa and what we did
was we tried to establish an incident
command system
like a network and uh
a model incident command model so that
it was easily identifiable who was
responsible for what
so that it would make our communication
more efficient and
just uh
overall streamline our day-to-day
operations
and one of the other individuals working
with you was Vincent Garces have I got
that right yes
Vincent he came to the Swiss Hotel very
early on and we connected
and what eventually happened so he my
apologies he came to the Swiss
he was there for
the first weekend maybe
not a very long period of time he
returned home and then he came back to
Ottawa at which time when he asked me
what he what he could do
I asked him if he could go over to the
ark hotel and support them
thank you and then
um who was the first
police person that you communicated with
Constable Isabel sear pidcock of the
Ottawa Police Service
and did you call her or did she call you
I called her on the 26th and could you
tell us about that conversation
yeah I contacted her I gave a brief
description of who I was and what I was
going to be doing in support of the
Convoy uh Mr Guerra had
advised me that he had already been
communicate in communication with her
and that we were expecting a map package
from the Ottawa city police
as to where the trucks were supposed to
enter into the City and where they were
supposed to park and Stage
and
did she tell you uh anything out
anything else let's say about emergency
vehicle Lanes
we may have discussed that on the phone
call but it was definitely there was
Specific Instructions delivered within
the in the map package that she did end
up sending me on the 27th of January and
so could you put a please hrf0001313
and if you could go to the next page
please
is this the map package she sent you
yes I believe so and we see it says uh
under Ottawa truck Convoy take direction
from police whenever applicable
leave open space for emergency vehicle
access at all times no closed trailers
permitted on Wellington near Parliament
Hill
all staging areas must be kept and
adjacent emergency access Lane
and emergency routes
that are listed there no Convoy access
at any time
correct correct and you and and did you
communicate those instructions to anyone
yes I emailed this map package to Tamara
leech
with the understanding that they would
be receiving a briefing in armed prior
the night before entering the city
and how did you know to uh email them to
Ms Leach
well miss Leach had contacted me
prior to the Convoy arriving in Ottawa
not in regards to this but for support
with monitoring and responding to social
media
which I said that the I agreed that the
mounties for Freedom could help her with
and so I forwarded that her contact
information off to we had a social media
committee at the time
and then
so I I was already aware that she was
like I would call a describe her as the
face of the Convoy
and so that's who I communicated the map
package to thank you and if you can just
scroll to the next uh page please
this is one of the maps there were one
two three four five five Maps if you can
scroll up
and again what were those Maps
of
what is what was that telling you
these are the entrance routes for the
various convoys that were approaching
from different directions
and the they where they would be
directed to enter the city and where to
park
and if we can go to the next page please
this is uh
from uh Constable Sarah Pittock and it
says roots to staging areas
and what did you understand that to me
exactly what it says
and so you knew that they were you
understood there would be certain
staging areas
I did and if you can go to the last page
or sorry the
next page over
sorry one yeah there
um there are certain instructions there
um including no parking on Elgin Street
from Wellington to Highway 417.
and and so forth and all of that you say
you passed on to to Ms Leach yes
what police force was uh
was Constable uh seer
uh critic with
Ottawa Police Service
and where were you when the convoys
started to arrive
I was in the Swiss Hotel
now we've heard evidence that
that from time to time some emergency
lanes were blocked either on a
short-term basis or for example on Kent
Street
um
for on a long-term basis What
observations did you make about
emergency lanes
I did see
when I would do a let's refer to it as a
Perimeter Walk
that the only place that I ever observed
at the emergency lanes were blocked was
for
roughly I would estimate two maybe three
blocks north and south on Kent Street
and that was it
that's all I recall like
okay and then um
I I apologize
perhaps at Rito and Sussex as well
okay we'll come to to Rito and Sussex
um
if you can turn up please Mr clerk PB
Dot N S C dot c a a n dot four zeros one
three six seven
and go
and if you can go to page 10 please
a little further
up
sorry let me try page 11.
oh no if
excuse me for once
well let me just ask you the question
um
at uh on
you did you have a further conversation
um with members of police forces on
January 28th
as referenced in this document
uh yes let me just turn it up for you
it's
excuse me at one moment
all right it's page 11 at the bottom
see it refers to you
that you're organizing the volunteer
security for the group War Room
canada.net what was that
that was the initial website domain that
Mr Guerra was operating adopt a trucker
through
and it says on Friday January 28 2022
you reached out to points of contact
within the RCMP OPP and the ncrcc
seeking information obtained by open
source on the demonstration
do you remember that
yes I don't recall reaching out to the
OPP
that early
I could be mistaken but I definitely
reached out to Ottawa Police Service
uh PPS
and the RCMP and
when it references the ncrcc
that's a command center that was at my
old building of work yes and so the
specific person I reached out to from
the RCMP
I believed to be working out of that
location and do you remember who that
was
Constable Chris Angel and uh
did you remember who you uh reached out
to in the PPS
Constable Emily Gosling
and did you reach out again to
constables here yes I believe so
uh and uh perhaps by that time I already
had learned of uh Constable Paul Askin
from the Ottawa Police Service as well
and if we go back to uh the document
um
it says in his email bullford noted the
Singas largest single largest concern of
everyone involved is that outside
influences will attempt to instigate an
action that will damage The credibility
of the official Convoy group and
supporters what uh why was that your
main concern well I've worked many of
these large events in the NCR over my
career and
consistently the biggest concern from a
protective policing standpoint was
always the potential for a lone wolf or
a small group
when you have a large crowd of people
coming together like uh like in a
similar event like a Canada Day or A
Remembrance Day that was one of our
primary function from my old unit
was to be in positions where we could
observe anything of a suspicious nature
that could potentially become a loan
actor or a small group attack
and I understand that you reached out to
on January 29th to uh Sergeant front of
the Ops do you call that
Sergeant Frost
uh
I believe it was front do is the name
cross
the the Ops Ottawa Police Sergeant yes
that was a man by the name of Pat
Sergeant Pat Frost Frost I'm sorry it
was a typo and um
what did you discuss with him
so that would have been very early in
the morning
I received a call from some of the
truckers down at the intersection of
booth and Sir Johnny McDonald Parkway
they were frustrated that they had been
blocked from
continuing further up onto Wellington
like up towards the Supreme Court
and so I went down just to see what
would be possible and while I was there
I ended up speaking with uh two of the
Young office uh
one of the officers was a younger man
and I spoke to those officers asking if
it would be possible to have some of the
trucks that were extended along sir
Johnny McDonald Parkway to condense
closer
to the
I would call it the main body of the
Convoy parked on Wellington at
Parliament and
because there was a large gap
I I if I recall correctly there was a
large gap kind of around the Supreme
Court of Canada all the way down the
hillside of Wellington and then
extending West yeah to the booth and S
jam and so
they those officers got me into contact
with Sergeant Pat Frost
and so I met with him at the Ottawa
Police Headquarters
and I we drove around downtown Ottawa
together because he and he relayed to me
that he had managed a large tractor
protest in the city of Ottawa before and
so he we were touring around down the
downtown core trying to determine what
potential locations trucks could be
brought in closer to Parliament
and and you know establishing what was a
hard no-go you know like such as a
primary bus bus routes and emergency
lanes
and what were your general observations
uh of the the protests during the the
first weekend
well I didn't get out of the Swiss Hotel
very much those first initial days but
when I finally did it was
the largest event I've ever observed in
downtown Ottawa in my time here
and what about the con conduct of the
participants
well it was uh I'd say it was a very
festive atmosphere people were very
emotional
hugs all over the place
um
there was this the stage the crane stage
truck had already been established up at
the intersection of Metcalf and
Wellington by the time I got out for the
very first time to go actually see it
for myself
and so that that's where I I went
and it wasn't it was it was incredible
there were
the crowd was humongous and people
if I recall correctly the first time I
got out was to actually go make a speech
on the stage truck
and it was a very overwhelming emotional
experience because I
I felt that there was a sense of hope
that Canada wouldn't go to a very dark
place and what was your speech about
just very generally
it was well I know that I included some
of those remarks in my speech that prior
to that Convoy I was ready to leave the
country I was my wife and I had
discussed that at length
uh moving somewhere where we would be
well treated as an equal citizen
and and especially for the future of our
children
and that seeing the Convoy and the
rallying
of support behind it all across Canada
restored my faith in Canadians that they
weren't just going to let Canada
degenerate further did you talk about
security issues or behavioral issues I
did I
I gave a thank you to the First
Responders and I even kind of tipped my
hat slightly to some of my old
colleagues that were up on the roof of
the parliament buildings doing OverWatch
you know saying that I know a lot of
these people they're good people and
they're here to protect us too
there was a great deal of mistrust of
the police
and
and I reminded everyone or advocated for
everyone to remain lawful peaceful and
lawful at all times so that the
government and the media could not label
us with similar derogatory terms that
they already had
and uh
if we could go put uh back up please uh
hrf four zeros one five five three
and if you can just scroll through that
to the date February 1.
so if you can stop at just there I take
it you took daily notes of everything
that you were doing
yeah I tried to document as much as I
could and that's all set out in your
your statement yes so for example you
were dealing with
issues like
um
if you identified on February 1st a or
you received a call about an aggressive
unidentified mail at Wellington and
Metcalf and uh
you uh reported that to the police
correct
in the first paragraph there yeah I
don't recall if I called the police I
think people that were present at the
stage truck at the time called the
police
and if you just keep scrolling please
you'll see there's a number of events uh
or issues that you dealt with on
February 1st
and then into February 2nd
and then if
we come to uh February 3rd could you put
up these hrf four zeros one two eight
seven
this is a letter for from the Justice
Center for constitutional freedoms to
the mayor
um but uh
it refers on on page two to a press
conference that you gave on February 3.
that's correct
and so in the second paragraph there you
indicate that you'd like to put people's
minds at ease the public is watching
people that have concerns over what
they're seeing in regards to the heavy
police presence
uh what was your objective there
just to bring down the overall anxiety
level of the
protesters I mean in my mind
Ottawa residents have seen that type of
police presence probably on a regular
basis at Large Scale events but a lot of
these people that traveled to Ottawa
have likely never been here before and
likely never participated in in an event
of this magnitude so I just wanted
everyone to understand that when you
have a massive crowd such as this come
to the national capital region
for a large event it's normal to have
multiple police agencies involved it's
normal to have specialized units moving
around in more tactical looking clothing
and it's normal to have snipers on
rooftops because that was something that
a lot of people were really panicked
about they were nervous about the
presence of of snipers being on the roof
and that being my old job I was able to
speak to people and keep the you know
keep them calm me like it's totally
normal Don't Panic that's what happens
here all the time
and if you can go put up please hrf four
zeros1289
and it's um
page 11 of the document I believe
um
all right
can you just scroll uh back a bit
no more
I scroll up then sorry about that no the
other way please
yeah keep going please
more
this um
keep going please
this is an affidavit that you swore in
connection with the uh proceedings the
class action commenced by sexy Lee
yes that's correct
and you talk about at paragraph seven
and eight if you can scroll there
about a complaint from an Ottawa
resident about honking through the night
yes that's correct you say you told him
that quiet hours from 8 pm to 8am had
been put in place wind
what was your understanding of that who
put that into place
my understanding is that the truck
captains had already put that into place
maybe even the day before if not
no
if not that day the day before
that's what was communicated to myself
and this was the one and only complaint
I ever received about it
and what was your understanding moving
to through the period of time that the
Convoy was in Ottawa did that change
well there was the injunction came into
place as well which uh definitely
definitely impacted the horn honking and
I I would
I would
say in my opinion it reduced it even
further
and can we go to paragraph nine of your
affidavit
you say there my primary concern is
individuals or groups with potential to
deliberately instigate conflict with the
freedom Convoy movement and to discredit
uh the freedom Convoy can you
say what you're how that why that was
your concern
well I would go back partially to my
concern about
A Lone Wolf or small cell that could
potentially try and uh leverage the
large crowd
for their own agenda but I also I also
had concerns because I've I've done
OverWatch at a number of protests and
counter protests in Ottawa and I've seen
with my own eyes
how aggressive groups
related to the antifa movement can be
when they are much larger in numbers
than the group that they're counter
protesting against and how aggressive
they can be overrunning the police line
as well
so when you're referring to instigators
who were you referring to
well people who were
who would deliberately
try to initiate a
a violent interaction with a freedom
Convoy protester
or
uh maybe even someone who would try to
infiltrate the crowd with a
racist type flag
to try and bring discredit to the
freedom Convoy protest
and
do you recall and I believe the day it
was February 8 having a conversation
with Constable where's biki about your
concern and displeasure with the
psychological operation being waged on
Convoy participants yes I do and what
was that about
so in the initial I would say close to
initial two weeks
I thought that Chief slowly was pretty
fair in his uh
remarks regarding the Convoy you know
understanding his position as the chief
of police of the city of Ottawa but I
thought that he was pretty unbiased and
then after the
I think it was a a council meeting
for a police services board meeting
there was a lot of rhetoric
regarding the freedom Convoy protesters
allegations of being extremists
insurrectionists I believe even the term
uh domestic terrorism may have been
thrown around
and
I noticed at that time that was
it also coincided with a lot of that
same rhetoric from the Legacy Media
and
you know and we'd already heard and seen
the Prime Minister using similar
language
and so
I felt that that was
that was definitely heightening the
anxiety of the overall crowd
the the fear that they were going to be
labeled such and dealt with as such by
law enforcement because they were under
so much pressure from the from uh the
different levels of government
and
there was also I believe that was right
around
the same time
that there was also
they were being denied access
to service some of the portable toilets
so I mean you're denying people their
basic sanitation needs
and there was also information beginning
to circulate about the involvement of
Cas or uh Children's Aid Society I
believe is what that stands for and that
to me was
that was a clear red flag to me that if
you are deliberately trying to provoke
people
to take action
if you make them believe that you're
going to take their kids away
that's going to elicit a very strong
emotional response and I believe that
that was deliberately done in order to
bully the freedom Convoy protesters
and um
we can put up please document hrf
five zeros five six eight
foreign
security uh briefing that you would
prepare
on a day a day-to-day basis
I believe there was a mistake I I did
not prepare these daily security
briefings like a document yes that was
another individual but I mean these are
some of my uh
some of the actions that I took place in
and the conversations that I took place
in and who is Constable where's Vicki he
is an opp liaison officer
and in this uh
document uh you refer to uh in the
under February 4 in the um
first paragraph to an incident at
Confederation Park
and then you refer to an incident
involving the new queen of Canada
and uh
next paragraph down
um
you were asked about Pat King's
involvement
in the Convoy
and you indicated you had limited
knowledge and almost zero contact with
him
and if you can scroll
further down please
connect
um
next page
there is no next page that um did you
also at one time speak to Constable
where's Vicki about
um a memorandum of understanding
that was circulating
I don't recall speaking to
Constable where's biki about that no did
did you know about the memorandum of
understanding
I yes I had heard about it and I think I
may have seen it circulating online
ahead of the Convoy
uh the first time I ever actually read
it was just last week
and
you mentioned the intersection at Rito
and Sussex did you have occasion to uh
go to Rito in Sussex
yes uh I walked through that
intersection
multiple times
daily but at least probably twice a day
when I would go out for a foot patrol
and when I would come back
and uh what were your observations
well they were primarily made up of
quebecois truckers but then there was
also like other Witnesses have testified
there was also like a a Polish or
Eastern European contingent
and
I actually I actually encountered a a
Cuban Canadian who
spoke to me at length about how he felt
strongly about being there to support
the Convoy because he had lived through
communism and that Canadians could not
give up their freedoms
and were you there at any time when
there was attempts to move vehicles from
Rito and Sussex no I was not
and what how what was your impression of
the way uh people were behaving at the
intersection
well on weekends they would have a stage
and music and they would have like a
nightly dance party on uh definitely on
the Friday and the Saturday night
typically is what I recall
and what about during the week
do you recall there was a lot of uh a
lot of different food tents and
barbecues people were were cooking and
preparing food and
clumps of people
now we heard evidence from Keith Wilson
you know Mr Wilson yes I do
um
that there were leaks in either the Ops
OPP or both because the Convoy
organizers were aware of police
operations before they happened
did you know about that
I'd never had any Active Duty Officers
leaking me any sensitive information
I did have a number of
police officers for former police
officers former military
that were helping me with some of those
different security tasks
and there was
I'm not exactly certain of the number
but there was
there was officers that were on leave
for various reasons whether it be the
mandates or their own personal reasons I
didn't ask it wasn't my business that
were also helping with some of the
security tasks that I was
coordinating
okay and if I can move to a different
subject
did you continue to have contact with
the PLT of the uh the police forces over
the entire period
in general yes there might have been
there might have been the odd day where
there was no communication I know uh
communication with the Ottawa Police
Service liaison teams
kind of it I I recall it reducing
near the end like
especially after the emergencies act had
been invoked but
from my recollection the opp was fairly
regularly engaged
and did you concerning the uh uh Ops did
you have a view on how effective they
were being
yeah well I think they were overwhelmed
by the size of the Convoy
I think that
I actually had the the young officer
that I spoke to that early early in the
Convoy down at booth and Sir John A
McDonald
he actually said to me
I can't believe the size of this
something to this effect I can't believe
the size of this we're totally
unprepared for something this size and I
kind of laughed and I said well you guys
have to stop listening to the CBC for
intelligence
and and that was kind of the end of that
interaction but um because if you had
been paying attention to open source
like any kind of social media was
obvious that this was a huge event that
was about to land in Ottawa
uh but coming back to uh how effective
they were
I have no complaints about dealing with
them but it I don't think it was ever
really I never really felt as though
there was any kind of a negotiation
taking place it was just my means to
communicate with the police because we
would try and do
we would try and get
simple
returns
from the police Liaisons like something
as simple as like could we possibly get
access to this location so we could drop
some portable toilets
and we were getting shut down almost all
the time the only time I ever remember
having any success with that was after I
had
expressed my displeasure about the
psychological operation that was being
conducted when I had that discussion
with OPP Where's Becky
and at one point did you come to learn
that uh Chief slowly had asked for 1800
police officers
yes I did and what was uh your reaction
to that
well I
I anticipated that at the very least he
was asking for a large number
because this could be a sustained event
and members would obviously need to be
cycled out for sustainment
likely that they were preparing for a
mass mobilization
and did you do anything as a result of
hearing that information
I mean I we had discussions about it I I
don't it didn't change it didn't change
what my role was my my task was to just
continue trying to keep things as safe
as possible
and were you aware of negotiations that
were taking place between uh the leaders
in the Convoy and the mayor
I was made aware of that after the fact
okay
and in terms of
did you have any communication with
anyone who was
involved in the uh
and Ambassador Bridge protest no I did
not
I I believe we had we've already seen an
email that was forwarded to me by Miss
Leach yes during her testimony and that
was the only time I'd ever seen anything
from uh Windsor and that I didn't even
open that until well after the Ottawa
Convoy had been dismantled
and what about uh Coots No Sir Emerson
Surrey none
now at what point do you recall learning
uh that the uh
emergencies Act was to be invoked
I believe the day that it was officially
announced by the federal government
did you hear anything about it prior to
that date
I think there was discussions people try
wondering if it would be and my thought
process was that
well I wasn't going I would not be
surprised if it was because the city had
declared a state of emergency The
Province had declared one
to me it would not surprise me in the
least if the next logical step was the
Federal Government
and do you recall
subsequent to the invocation on February
16 holding a press conference yes I do
and that was with Mr gerseys and
Mr Cornell that's correct and who who is
Mr Cornell he's one of the members of
the steering committee for the group
Veterans for freedom
he's a combat veteran and if I can just
read you what I understand you said at
that press conference the emergency
order clearly states that the protest is
allowed to continue if the protest is
peaceful the government is trying to
order the police to use Force against
peaceful protesters we call on our
fellow Canadians to come to Ottawa to
exercise their legal right to assembly
and protest
the more Canadians that come to Ottawa
the harder it will be for the police to
carry out the government's illegal order
is that something you said that's
correct and
did you receive advice as to your
interpretation of the emergency order
yes we had received a briefing from the
legal team that based on I think I
believe it's Justice McLean's ruling
that as long as people did not come to
Ottawa to engage in violence disrupt
trade or block critical infrastructure
we still fell within the confines of a
lawful Pro lawful protest
and did somebody request that you give
this press conference or did you do it
on your own initiative
well I was already I was working with
the media relations people
from early on I I think my like you
mentioned that my first press conference
that I attended was on February 3rd
and so I did a number of
press conference events during my time
with the Convoy and at this point isn't
it fair to say that uh
you
believe that
enforcement action
could come
at any time
perhaps I was naively hoping that my
brothers and sisters in law enforcement
would see the truth on the ground as
opposed to what the government and the
media was saying and that they would
take a historic opportunity to stand up
for our Charter of Rights and Freedoms
and did you think about
um
or was it a concern to you
that you were encouraging people to come
into
Ottawa where that sort of law
enforcement activity might well take
place
no because at that time like I said I
still had faith that front line members
would do the right thing
now I my understanding is that on
February 18 uh
your wife advised you that you were
going to be arrested
yes that's correct I uh
she advised me that she had received a
text message
from one of our neighbors that the news
was reporting that the police were
looking for me to arrest me
and if we
turn to
um
the document PB NSC
can
four zeros eight nine two four
the second page of the document
this is uh an RCMP uh document and if
you look at the bottom of the page
you'll see information collected
Freedom Convoy organizers held a press
conference at 13 30 hours participants
included and that's uh uh
blanked out spoke to the same theme and
you see what it says there about
Canadians still being allowed to come to
Ottawa with their children to engage in
peaceful awful protests
is that
what you said at your press conference
yeah I believe that's accurate
and you'll see the last paragraph there
all three individuals have contravened
to section five of the emergency
measures regulations by inviting a
person to participate in an assembly
that may reasonably be expected to lead
to a breach of the Peace
okay I can come back um
were you were you arrested on February
18th yes I was and can you briefly
tell the commissioner about that
well after the press conference
and my wife showed me the text message
from our neighbor
I will I left the Lord Elgin Hotel I
walked down to Rito and Sussex where I
knew that the police action had already
begun
initially I encountered the certain
Quebec no one would respond to me so
then I I realized that there was RCMP a
line of RCMP officers over closer to the
senate or the the old train station and
so I walked over to them
I approached the line
I presented myself and I said
I
something to the effect of I hear that
you're looking for me to arrest me
is that true and then I was arrested for
mischief
and were you ultimately charged no I was
not
were your bank accounts Frozen yes they
were can you tell the commissioner about
that please
to my recollection we realized that our
bank accounts were frozen
so
two different banks and a primary credit
card
I realized I think
we
how I recall it going was that
accessing online banking
with our primary Bank
and it was just like a blank Dash where
the account balance would normally be
and then leave my wife confirmed with
the other bank
attempted to use the credit card
and it was declined
and my wife spoke to a banking
professional a friend of ours
to ask
if
with our accounts Frozen with our
mortgage payments and automatic
withdrawals still still be paid and we
were advised that it would not be
and so
I would say roughly a period of five to
six days
we were
completely dependent on what cash we had
and after that how long were your
accounts froze
I believe it was my accounts were
unfrozen on the
Tuesday the the 22nd or the 23rd of
February when the after the emergencies
act had been revoked so they were frozen
for how many days
I
I believe I realized they were frozen on
the 17th
and then I think that was the Thursday
I didn't receive any kind of
notification about it until I think the
the bank One bank called me and left a
voicemail message on the Saturday
foreign
it was it was unfrozen after the
emergencies act had been revoked and
were you able to meet your day-to-day
expenses during that period
well
fortunately we didn't
have a whole pile of expenses that we
had to
incur during those days but we
we had some
help from some family
okay thank you sir those are my
questions
God if I may add one thing about the
accounts being frozen
I was never notified by the police that
my accounts were frozen
contrary to what was said to Parliament
by the RCMP when they testified in
committee
thank you thank you
okay next we have the Ottawa Police
Service please
good afternoon Mr Belford my name is
David mijikovsky I'm a lawyer for the
Ottawa Police Service good afternoon sir
good afternoon
um you talked about your interactions
with the PLT and I gather from reviewing
your statement you had many interactions
with the PLT is that correct that's
correct and they were very helpful
I think they desired to be yes and you
had the sense that they wish they had
more ability to negotiate
yes I would say that's accurate I do
recall
I do recall uh you know when when there
was attempts to negotiate
occasionally receiving the reply to like
that wasn't their decision to make right
um
in your um
statement you prepared you have a
statement that says Canada Freedom
Rights Movement Daniel Joseph bullford's
statement that's a statement that was
prepared for you by the uh justice
centers lawyers no sir I prepared that
myself and you put that logo on top or
that name on top Canada Freedom Rights
Movement yes I did okay and did you
suggest that everyone else do that as
well no I did not
um in that report you indicate a number
of potentially criminal actions
involving non-convoy members that you
reported to the Ops and so I see things
in that report about bikers about the
new queen of Canada false claims that
bricks had been ordered uh in your name
uh potential instigation concerns about
Canada Unity uh vandalism of trucks
social media posts made by Mr lacasse a
shortage a sabotage of Transport trucks
bikers and bomb threats right those are
all things that you referenced that's
correct and you're a strong supporter I
take it of Law and Order
my dad was a police officer for 38 years
both of my older brothers were police
officers
obviously I was and there's only one of
us remaining but
the my hometown in Alberta referred to
us as the byzants and Blue Bloods
and I know from the Ottawa Police
Service institutional report that I
won't turn up in order to save time that
during the period of the Convoy there
were a number of criminal charges laid
in fact we know and it's on page 14 that
there were
533 of them according to schedule C
but what I don't see is single notation
of in your statement is where you
brought any of those uh criminal
offenses to the attention of the Ottawa
Police
can you refresh me on the dates that
you're referring to
the dates yes your statement I'm not
sure when your statement was prepared
but the um evidence that we have in the
record is that during the period of the
freedom Convoy
so from January 28th to a date in March
there were a total of 533 criminal
charges
okay
sorry I can't remember if that's laid or
people arrested and so I didn't see
anywhere in your statement where you
brought information about those that
criminal activity to the attention of
the Ottawa Police I have an objection
hold on one yes my my friend is
misstating the evidence to the witness
and I object to it on that basis um the
evidence is is that the vast majority of
charges were laid after the fact and
that actually at least based on the one
document and evidence
uh criminal charges that existed at the
time before the invocation were only
about 19 that of charges late so with
respect to my friends stating in the Ops
document and I can advise the commission
that after I looked at what they had put
together I asked for disclosure from
them with respect to when these charges
were laid and they've decided not to
provide that and they're using a jumbled
up statistic so in my submission sir my
friend's going to ask the witness about
why he didn't include Ops information
in his statement that isn't clear I
think he needs to actually put the
actual evidence that is before this
tribunal before him and not jumbled up
into a fact that these are 500 some odd
charges that may or may not have been
laid during the time period that he was
here sir okay well maybe you can just
ask I I think without reference I think
the question was fair and my friends now
used a couple minutes of my time but
there were a lot of charges During the
period of the freedom Convoy we know
that
and I don't see anywhere in your
statement where you reference informing
the Ottawa Police of the situations
leading to those criminal charges
well I
often reported to the Ottawa Police the
the various police agencies anything
that came to my attention that I
believed to be criminal or a public
safety concern and I believe that the
majority of those arrests and charges
happened during the dismantle operation
of the protest
a significant chunk of which I was in
custody
you were in custody as of what date sir
February 18th
um and uh well the record will speak for
itself
um and so in your statement in paragraph
80 of your statement you say you did
everything to cooperate with the police
and to maintain public
peace and police safety
is that correct or is that incorrect
that's correct okay and so I also note
um that in the institutional report of
the Ottawa Police that the communication
Center received many emergency calls
from businesses to have protesters
removed because they weren't wearing a
mask to deal with complaints about being
harassed while walking on the street
with masks to complaints of being
sexually harassed and threatened
uh
I see as well that questions were asked
about ops's enforcement uh plans I see
as well that there were noise complaints
that were received and requests for
charges against the protesters and I
don't see anywhere sir in your statement
where you reference any of those things
well sir
that's not my job to handle the call
volume that the Ottawa Police receives
and
there's a lot of allegations that I've
heard
during testimony at this inquiry that I
haven't I have no knowledge or
have not seen any real evidence of I'm
not suggesting that it's not possible
but
people were not calling me
to report criminal offenses to the
police
you've heard the evidence of counselors
uh McKenney and flurry
yes and you heard about what um their
constituents had to put up with correct
you heard that evidence I'm just asking
you that question yes I heard their
evidence and so either did you believe
what counselor McKenney and Fleury said
or did you think the issues they were
raising were trivial
I wouldn't characterize what they were
saying as trivial but again
I've come to the point where I'm not
going to believe anything until I see
actual evidence of it
okay
um you told me about you uh clearly
respect Law and Order I take you have a
lot of respect for the Canadian court
system
correct
I sincerely hope it's still functioning
the way it is intended yes it's
important that decisions of the Court be
respected
yes and one of the decisions was
um that the Convoy had negatively
impacted residents and the Convoy
protesters were breaching bylaws
you're aware of that
could you specify the bylaws
um were you aware of that sir
well again sir it's it's not my
profession to enforce bylaws in the city
of Ottawa okay and as a police officer
you understand that disclosing
confidential information is an offense
what type of confidential information
are confidential information it's an
offense under the police services act
and it's also an offense under the code
of conduct for the RCMP correct that's
correct you mean like as it relates to
information I learned during my time as
a police officer
no I'm just asking you the question
generally that the disclosure of
confidential information is an offense
correct
while if a serving police officer
discloses information that is an offense
correct
like under under the if I was to
disclose something confidential as a
current as an active serving police
officer that would be an offense under
the RCMP code of conduct right I would
agree with that yes and same thing would
apply to a municipal police officer who
discloses uh information they had as a
police officer
I I'm not entirely certain I would
assume you're probably accurate but I
didn't fall under the police services
Act
okay sure it would be breach of
confidence if that's of assistance but
um it can also potentially be a criminal
offense as well correct breach of trust
yeah probably and uh being a person who
supports Law and Order you would not
condone that kind of thing would you you
wouldn't want police officers to be
um breaching their Oaths and providing
confidential information to members of
the Convoy would you
no and so Mr Wilson in his witness
statement
um talks about people working at the um
Swiss hotel that was where you were
that's correct and so he said there were
former Law Enforcement Officers they had
radios Maps many of these ex-service
Personnel were connected and brought in
Intel Wilson is unaware of the sources
but the freedom Convoy was receiving
leaked information from law enforcement
I just want to be clear you never became
aware of any leaked information from
Ottawa Police Service officers did you I
will be 100 clear at no time did I
receive sensitive information from an
active duty Ottawa police officer and
you never received confidential
information from an Ottawa police
officer did you
no okay and Mr Wilson never told you who
these people were
no and you were very involved in the
security uh the a response and the
incident command
um that was going on at that hotel
correct that's correct so one would
expect that you would know if there was
leaked confidential information correct
yes I expect I would
um and you're not suggesting obviously
that if such a thing had occurred that
the Ottawa Police Service would condone
that kind of thing correct
I think it's fair to say that the Ottawa
Police would not condone that right and
one of the things you reference in your
statement at paragraph 80 is you accuse
the police leadership and I'm just going
to quote you of quote knowingly
attempting to instigate a strong
emotional reaction from Convoy
participants by using inflamed rhetoric
and threatening the involvement of child
protective services
yes that's correct okay
um Mr clerk I wonder if I could ask you
please to call up
hrf40s 1553
and if we go to page 22 please
at paragraph 103
thank you and I'll just read that
sentence the first sentence sir
I also advise and this is from your
statement correct that's correct I also
advised him of my belief that our own
government was committing crimes against
humanity allowing thousands of Canadians
to die because they've been denied
life-saving treatment and others have
been disabled or have died from the
vaccine something a homicide detective
may want to consider
and would you agree with me that that
would be an example of inflammatory
rhetoric attempting to instigate a
strong emotional response
I don't think it's an example of
inflammatory rhetoric I think it's
absolutely factually true okay and that
I was trying to elicit a response from
detective Benson
okay because he as a homicide detective
should be investigating something of
that nature
and um in I won't take you to the
paragraph to save time
um uh but in paragraph 121 of your
statement you also talk about the
extreme dehumanization of unvaccinated
uh people and I guess you don't see that
as inflammatory rhetoric either correct
no sir
and um in your witness statement
um you talk about the um
the police breaching windows and
extracting protesters during the uh
tactical operation the POU operation you
recall that I do and you know of course
from your experience in law enforcement
that it's easy to be an armchair
quarterback and say what's wrong with
the police carrying out a uh tactical
operation after the fact correct it's
very difficult to be on the ground and
in the theater of operations isn't it I
would agree with that and I think to add
context to the answer is that I believe
in my statement I outlined why I
believed that occurred and you would
agree with me that uh that in the
theater of operations police may be
dealing with situations that may be
volatile and more dangerous than appear
to onlookers correct that's correct
and you're aware
um
from the uh police operations that were
carried out by uh the Ottawa Police
Service the opp the RCMP and a number of
other public order uh units
um you're aware from your experience
that there would generally be an arrest
and detention plan prepared for those
type of circumstances correct
yes and so uh opp04
um
200 OPP four zeros four two eight six if
we could just briefly call that up
you're going to have to be wrapping up
pretty soon I if I may just have uh one
more minute no problem thanks very much
um
that is if you just um you good enough
to scroll down that is the arrest and
detention plan uh with respect to the
operation that was carried out and you
wouldn't presume to say that it wasn't
an appropriate arrest plan would you
I can't I don't feel I'm qualified to
speak to that for a major public order
operation such as what occurred my
typical experience with an arrest plan
was in a much smaller context and it was
very simple okay
um and finally just um to finish off you
testified uh in uh answer to my uh
friend that you expected when although
there was an announcement of the
a large number of police officers and
you realize that they were preparing for
a tactical or a public order unit
response you testified that you thought
that the police officers would do the
right thing correct I had hoped so and
you thought that they would disregard
the situation
and simply allow the status quo to
continue correct
yes I I had hoped
that they would
see through the false narrative
and stand up for us and do what was
right and protect us
thank you very much those are all my
questions
okay next is the
Ottawa residence coalition
uh good evening now Mr Belfort I guess
we can say my name is Paul champ for the
record for the Ottawa Coalition
residents and businesses
uh Mr Beaufort I just want to ask you uh
about the first thing you're talking
about uh you were concerned about being
uh disciplined for speaking out about uh
vaccine rules and restrictions
the federal vaccine mandate and and
you're concerned about being
um disciplined for speaking out about
that yes I was well I'm very sorry to
hear that I think that would have been
totally inappropriate well the that's my
lived experience with the RCMP sir yeah
I I know I've represented RCMP officers
for over 20 years including people for
speaking publicly and um you know things
have been different I've been happy to
represent you on that
now I want to ask you some questions
about uh your drive around with Sergeant
frost on the eve of the uh protests so
the two of you drove around looking at
appropriate spots for the trucks to park
is that right that's correct and during
that drive did the two of you uh discuss
in any way about how long the protest
might last
I don't recall
it may have been it may have come up
and at that time I I didn't have an
accurate timeline
for sure because you've told us that you
expected the protest would last until
the federal government dropped uh
vaccine mandates and rules is that right
that was my impression yes and is that
what you conveyed to Sergeant Frost
potentially okay
now I just want to ask you is an aside
about the crowd size
um you you indicated that it was uh the
largest crowd you'd ever observed in
Ottawa I would say that's accurate yes
um you I believe uh some of the records
we have from uh police records that the
uh the size of the crowds are in the ten
thousand to fifteen thousand range does
that sound about right no sir what did
you think the size was I
based on my experience doing OverWatch
on Canada day yep and seeing the large
crowds especially like let's say Canada
Day 150 where it was probably the
biggest I had seen
I would have estimated the crowds in
downtown Ottawa on Parliament Hill
Wellington that General vicinity
I would have estimated close to a
hundred thousand
so uh indeed so do you think that the
police were uh
recording false information deliberately
or they just assessed it differently
than you
I can't say I well I don't I doubt very
much that they would record it false
deliberately
it could it be that you maybe just uh it
was hard for you to assess because all
the trucks took up so much space it was
tough to assess the size I thought about
that there the trucks do take up a lot
of space but
the crowd even between the trucks was
jam-packed
from the Supreme Court
almost all the way to the Chateau
Laurier
and
I I don't recall seeing that before I
recall seeing large crowds moving around
Parliament Hill along Wellington into
the byword market
and but that those numbers
Encompass a much larger geographic area
than what I'm referring to right yeah
but when you do OverWatch you're up on
top of the buildings and glandular block
and stuff like that so you'd have a
better eye view of that's correct crowd
and you weren't able to be up on those
buildings during this time right nope
okay uh now I want to ask you about uh
the the dance parties you told us about
you thought those parties were Fridays
and Saturday nights I believe so but you
and I don't think are so far off in age
uh you weren't going out to the dance
parties every night I gather Mr bullford
I didn't have time sir yeah I understand
uh and so if there's dance parties on
Wednesdays and Thursday nights you just
you wouldn't necessarily know
I seem to recall them being restricted
to weekends but I could be mistaken okay
now I want to ask you some questions
about your interactions with law
enforcement you've already heard a lot
of your evidence on that uh you uh about
your interactions with plts uh but you
also had interactions with uh officers
who are off duty is that right
no like you mean
objective officers yes exactly and just
because I'm not going to be asking for
names I'm just trying to understand
because we heard the testimony from Mr
Wilson the other day who yes I
understand and uh I just want to
understand it so is Mr Wilson getting
that information from others
I can't say for certain but all of the
officers that were supporting me in a
security context were either off work
for their own personal reasons right or
they had left their service right they
had made a similar decision to me and
had decided to leave policing how many
people are we talking about here roughly
a dozen a dozen and so each one of those
uh officers would have had their own
network of contacts in law enforcement
is that right
possible and could have been getting
information from current law enforcement
I don't know sir but you have to
remember it wasn't just again it was
people from all across Canada from
multiple multiple agents like they had
worked for multiple agencies it wasn't
just one service
uh I want to ask you about a different
topic Mr bulford now the the Convoy
organizers misleech missed Barber uh
others yourself uh you were doing
everything possible to convey to
protesters to refrain from any kind of
violence correct yes I would say so
um but uh you you because you were
security you were dealing with threats
at times is that right
yeah but not threats from within the
Convoy protest most of most of the
anything that I was receiving that was
information of a public safety concern
was typically
someone who had was committing a
criminal act or potentially a criminal
act against the protest right there
there was one or two instances where
there was some vehicles that people had
uh
reported that they were kind of
presenting the idea of blocking
intersections right and those instances
were reported to me by Convoy protesters
which then I passed on to the police
because we were trying to act within the
confines of we do not want to block all
of the intersections but Mr Beaufort my
understand you were you were concerned
and we're doing what you could to
protect uh the Convoy organizer leaders
is that right
be coordinating with some of the other
officers to ensure that Mr Barber Ms
leech and so forth were safe Miss Leach
did end up getting a former military
member yeah to provide some security for
her yeah because she had received a
number of death threats right uh other
than that the only people that were
really receiving
like a close protection detail if you
want to call it that yeah where the the
doctors and
former Premier peckford when he was in
town right because especially three of
the doctors in particular had received a
number of death or a number of her
harassing
or they had been subject to harassment
and a number of threats themselves right
now Ms Leach uh she uh very successfully
raised a large money amount of money
from GoFundMe but you know we heard her
testimony uh she was encountering all
kinds of difficulty in accessing any of
that money you you knew about that at
the time correct
yes and there was many people who were
very angry at her uh for not being able
to produce that money there is different
theories and so forth that she was
deliberately not giving the money to
them and so forth there was that going
around right there was there was
fractures within the within the I would
say the Freedom Movement maybe not just
specific to Ottawa but even people I
found that the people who are the
biggest critics of people like misleads
were people who were not here presently
in Ottawa sure
but what I'm getting at is that you know
although Ms Leach was trying to convey
what she was you know trying to do to
get to get the access to GoFundMe money
to help uh the truckers which you know
we've we've seen all the documents
that's what she was doing but some
people at that protest who wanting
access to that money perhaps had driven
a long way they were getting very
frustrated and she was uh was she
getting threats from some of those
people not that I recall no none no so
what was the security detail for
well my impression was that she was
being receiving threats from people that
were opposed to the Convoy being in
Ottawa
and everyone else who wanted access to
that money who had driven across the
country spent thousands of dollars they
were just content to sit and they
weren't angry about not getting access
to the money I don't have any
information or evidence to support that
Sir Sir Mr Beaufort you're a
professional right you're a professional
security detail protecting uh uh uh very
important people correct in my past
career yes right let's just like be
honest with each other uh someone in her
situation if you would assess that as a
professional you would have thought she
might be at risk or physical safety the
people wanting access to that money who
weren't getting it were frustrated that
was a that was a reasonable threat
assessment was it not
it could be potential yes but I didn't
have I didn't have any intelligence or
evidence to support that notion
other than the fact that yeah she was
she was the face of the Convoy they had
raised a substantial amount of money
but my experience when you've seen Miss
Leach in public
people loved her
now
um you're aware also Mr Beauford that
GoFundMe uh they were concerned uh
because they some of their staff were
getting threats for not releasing the
money you were you aware of that no sir
I was never heard about that no sir but
that was some of the concerns GoFundMe
so that that Ms Leach and Mr Wilson so
forth never shared that with you no sir
what about fuel providers who then
decided to stop providing fuel uh did
you ever hear about any of them getting
threats
from the Convoy yes well from anyone no
sir I'd stopped saying stopped all right
uh honestly no I don't I don't recall
information about fuel providers being
threatened now what about tow truck
drivers we've heard a lot about tow
truck drivers uh were there any threats
to tow truck drivers if they tried to
assist law enforcement had you heard
anything about that the first time I
heard of it was from the police
Witnesses at this inquiry right right
um and what about
um
uh uh Mr King
um did you ever view him in any way as a
threat to any of the other Convoy
organizers
like a physical threat yes no sir you'd
never heard of him threatening or
intimidating any of the other leaders
Mr King came to the Swiss Hotel one
evening angry
and he ended up in a
verbal altercation with Mr with Chad
arrows I believe I didn't learn about
that until the following day I was not
there when that occurred Mr King had a
couple of very large people with him and
was intimidating Mr Euros
I don't know who he had with him okay
but I mean Mr King is a large man
himself no doubt now what about uh media
now I I know obviously uh you're not uh
very supportive or or don't consume uh
what you call Legacy Media but uh you
were aware and heard of that uh
reporters for some of those
organizations downtown uh were often
being threatened while they were down
trying to cover the uh the Convoy
demonstrations you were aware of that Mr
bulford I was not aware of that I did I
did
learn that I believe the RCMP may have
been providing
security for some of those reporters
I saw one video just recently like
within the last two weeks where I think
Mr McGregor people were yelling in the
background while he was trying to give a
broadcast but right that that was the
first I'd ever seen of that or uh uh Mr
Raymond filion with TV ah was pushed to
the ground I did not I was not aware of
that until you just said it or Mr Evans
Solomon from CTV News had a beer can
thrown at his head I did not I was not
aware of that either he hadn't seen any
of the other videos or just on on your
own walkabouts ever seeing reporters for
CBC or Global what not of crowds
swarming around them and yelling and
yelling at them no not that I recall I
remember okay some okay mainstream
reporters approaching me the night that
Miss Leach was arrested when we were
standing up by the stage truck and
they were trying to ask for interviews
and I just declined but I don't recall
anyone being threatening towards them at
all okay so I didn't see any of those
things no sir
okay uh and then the the the Legacy
Media as you call it
um you you believe that they were
misrepresenting the Convoy is that right
yes I do and so when you say Legacy
Media you're talking about CTV CBC
Global News Post media all of those
well I would definitely I would
definitely say CBC CTV Global you're
accurate in that okay post media I'm not
not so much but uh also I would throw in
the Toronto Star is probably the worst
offender in my opinion okay and then um
so it was a year understanding and
belief that they were all kind of
working together in some way to to cover
the Convoy in a certain way
well it it's been my experience Mr champ
that they've been
reporting very similar to each other for
the last at least the last two years I
thought your early testimony was that
you weren't really watching them during
the Convoy were you watching them or you
weren't watching them
I didn't really have time to watch them
that much sir I did review a few
articles that people would send me like
for instance the article detailing one
of the local Ottawa residents
who had been arrested early on in the
Convoy
for carrying weapons in a public place
right and they wrote the article I
believe I saw it in the Toronto Star
and CBC but but just the whole phrase
Legacy Media I'm just trying to
understand what that means Legacy Media
that means like old media that can't be
trusted
no it's the main it's a it's another
name for the mainstream right the big
Outlets that have a
that seem to have I don't know if you'd
call it a monopoly but they they
dominate the television
sure right uh but all journalists all
story they all have an agenda that's
counter to to the people that you
support is that what your understanding
is I did not say all journalists do
all journalists with Legacy Media
I can't say that I can't say that all
journalists do but I've seen many
concerning
remarks come from the Legacy Media yeah
just just last Point Mr uh bulford
um I Heard uh Mr midikovsky from the
Ottawa Police Service uh oh no I
apologize maybe it was maybe the
commission Council asked me about
um uh racist flags that were being
carried around uh during the protest and
I believe you were implying in your
testimony
uh that you didn't think those were real
Convoy protesters that there were others
who might have been infiltrating is that
yes I suspect that's the case that's but
you don't have any evidence for that
well I did see a photograph yeah of a a
gentleman who I know to be a
photographer that follows Mr Trudeau
around on a regular basis taking a
close-up shot of the gentleman carrying
a Confederate flag
it's because Confederate flags can be
viewed as a racist flag is that right
that's correct right it appeared staged
to me right and so and you didn't think
that there was anyone involved in the
Convoy who brought Confederate flags uh
to the protests is that right
not that I was aware of what the video I
seen the the video of a a masked man
like wearing a a winter balaclava
walking through the crowd with a
Confederate flag and the video that I
saw was a number of protesters telling
him to get out of there right because he
wasn't welcome and they didn't want that
type of they didn't want that type of
symbol being associated to the Convoy
right all the Convoy people left their
Confederate flags at home like Mr Barber
[Applause]
sir
I don't know what beliefs all of the
people that came to Ottawa hold and I
don't know what they have in their
possession that would be purely
speculation on my part
all right thank you
government of Canada please
good evening Mr bullford and my name is
Victor Ryan and I'm part of the council
team at the government of Canada
um you already testified to your
previous history of service with the
RCMP but I just like to go back to it
briefly uh you stated you began your
RCMP career with a posting with M
Division and UConn correct that's
correct and within a few years of
working uh in the Yukon you were
selected to become a member of the
Emergency Response Team correct that's
correct and by virtue of your selection
to join the ERT uh you were trained as
an assaulter I believe correct initially
yes and then as a sniper that's correct
and would you agree with me that the
selection process for uh an emergency
response team is highly competitive
normally yes
okay because erts are responsible for
resolving incidents beyond the
capabilities of regular police in part
due to the increased risk of violence
that they can face
yes
and you continue to work as part of the
ERT in UConn as you stated in both White
Horse and Mayo before you transferred to
Ottawa is that correct that's correct
and when you came to Ottawa you were
working with the national division
Emergency Response Team
yes
and you were also often involved in high
profile protective operations for
individuals such as the Prime Minister
foreign heads of state when they came to
Ottawa members of the royal family
correct that's correct
and you were often deployed around the
world to protect the Prime Minister and
other high-profile individuals attending
various International Summits and
conferences correct
two times two times two times
and you eventually Rose to the rank of
Corporal and second in command of the
surveillance and reconnaissance team
within National division ERT do I have
that right that's correct
and so you would agree that your career
with RCMP was a successful one right I
think your evidence was uh earlier was
that you uh felt that you were a
dedicated professional yes
and so while you were in Ottawa and
while you were working with the
Emergency Response Team I believe the
dates were 2013 to 2021 is that correct
yes you were trained by a variety of
external law enforcement agencies during
that time
yeah uh well I wouldn't say a number but
less than a handful probably okay more
than one yes yeah uh including the FBI
hostage Rescue Team
that's correct uh Canadian Special
Forces Operations Command
correct and the types of things that you
were trained in the various tactical
aspects of policing for which you
received training including things like
covert surveillance
yes yeah the explosive forced entry and
breaching yes mass casualty response
yes
and so through this training that you
received and through your experience
working in the National division you
would have come to have an intimate
knowledge of the Parliamentary Precinct
in downtown Ottawa is that correct
yes that's correct uh and so you you
knew for instance how police would uh
train for and plan for a large-scale
demonstration uh like the Convoy
I was a I I would
I would say that
I am aware of a tip how a typical
deployment
or a mobilization would look for a large
scale event
but I never worked on a public order
unit
okay but you would have been familiar
with how the ERT would have interacted
with uh various other police forces in
Ottawa during an event such as this
somewhat yes
and of course you'd be keenly familiar
with the the jurisdictional uh uh I
guess intersections in the downtown area
between the RCMP the PPS the Ops
yes
uh you knew how police would gather
intelligence on the leadership and the
key figures of of any sort of protest
movement that would come in
I yeah I have some exposure to that and
you knew what the police goals and
strategies would be in policing a large
scale demonstration
foreign
well I think it's it's fairly basic
for something such as what happened in
Ottawa but maybe not basic is the right
term but
it's no surprise to me that people would
be surveilled
and that they would try and learn who
who is a person
identified as
you know a face of the Convoy
and
but predominantly most of the events
that take place
you you mobilize
resources
for a worst case scenario but the vast
majority of the time
nothing happens and when you talk about
mobilizing resources one of the ways
that you do so is by pulling other
police officers from other jurisdictions
that's correct yes that's that's common
yeah and as an RCMP officer former RCMP
member you would have been aware of uh
the different RCMP detachments and
divisions across the country
um have a general understanding of where
the rcmpr police of jurisdiction and
other areas of the country yes you would
have been aware of the Practical
difficulties involved in pulling RCMP
officers from provinces far flung and
transferring them to Ottawa to assist
the local police here in any enforcement
well yes sir I think um the RCMP has
been under resourced for pretty much my
entire career as far as back as I can
remember likely before
and I think that's almost like we've
heard from other police Witnesses that's
pretty much a universal in policing
and you would have had a knowledge
roughly of how many police officers
would be required to to manage a
large-scale demonstration
no I don't agree with that this was
I I don't know my involvement with these
large-scale events was very
compartmentalized to my role on the
Emergency Response Team okay and uh and
that role
um you touted quite a bit uh during the
occupation uh publicly correct I I don't
I wouldn't
consider it touting but I tried to
explain who I was what my experience was
so that I can try and reduce people's
anxiety about the heavy police presence
that they were seeing in Ottawa and my
friend from commission Council showed
you a document that contained a quote
from you from a press release where you
said I have extensive experience in
protective operations for large-scale
events here in the national capital
region I've been involved in tactical
planning for many of these large-scale
events so I'm keenly familiar with what
is happening right now in regards to the
police presence down around Parliament
Hill and the downtown core does that
sound familiar to you yes that's correct
uh
also on that in that same press
conference you also stated my primary
concern is individuals or groups with
the potential to deliberately instigate
conflict with the freedom Convoy
movement Crest that's correct and that
was to you your most important concern
because you knew from your past
experience the potential for individuals
or groups whether associated with you or
not to use the Convoy as cover for their
own means correct
yes I would agree that anytime you have
a large event where there's a large
crowd of people there's the primary
concern
from the police standpoint would be a
mass casualty attack
and by February 3rd you had already
begun to appreciate the number of
different factions and elements that
were converging on downtown Ottawa
correct
yeah I would agree with that for
instance you were involved as I take
your evidence with mounties for Freedom
you are volunteering with adopt a
trucker and you are also closely
associated with the freedom Convoy
correct
well yeah I mean my role with
volunteering with adopt a trucker was in
direct support of the freedom Convoy but
you were not associated with Canada
Unity correct no sir but Canada Unity
was there at the Convoy yes yeah and you
are not associated with James bowder
correct no sir no and the mou that that
he brought with him no like I said the
first time I read it was last week but
he was there at the Convoy craft
I heard that he was the first time I
ever seen him was here at this inquiry
uh and you are not affiliated with the
farfatas that were at Rito and Sussex
correct I also had no idea who farfadas
was
or what that what that was until after
I read about
Mr charlin's arrest owed it near Van
cleeg Hill after the Convoy had been
dismantled and the individual describing
herself as as Queen Ramona and Her
supporters you weren't associated with
her or her supporters correct no sir no
but they were there at the Convoy crap
yes I did have an interaction with some
of her supporters
uh and you weren't associated with any
Outlaw motorcycle gangs correct no
absolutely not no but they were there at
the Convoy correct I believe that there
was
two
men identified as
potentially belonging to an outlaw
motorcycle gang in the crowd early on
I don't recall ever seeing them or
hearing of them again and again uh
I
that's a bit of an assumption on my part
because I don't specifically have any
knowledge of that particular group
so you heard that they were there but
you didn't actually see them I saw a
photograph of them okay so you saw a
photograph of them at the Convoy but you
didn't actually encounter them that's
correct
uh you've already testified that your
main role was to collect intelligence
from the Convoy collect you know uh
threats of violence assess their
credibility and forward them on to the
police
um but I also take your evidence that
this was a peaceful protest correct
yes yep
uh and I in the chronology that's set
out in your witness statement I won't
take you to it unless you require it but
it's again hrf four zeros one five five
three
you state that on January 29 2022 you
sent a photo to Ops and RCMP of an
unidentified man in Ottawa who
reportedly wore body armor and stated
they don't realize what things will be
like when the hard boys show up with the
legitimate beef is that correct that's
correct
and uh on January 30th the next day you
emailed PLT about a conspiracy to Stage
a hit and run with a tractor-trailer
hitting a horse that contains specific
information regarding a member of the
prime minister's protective detail
correct that's correct
and uh you relate information to PLT
regarding fights that you uh either saw
or that were related to you correct
well there was
the aggressive mail up at the stage
truck
I don't recall other fights beyond that
okay other than the one instance where
email
pulled a crowbar out of his car I leave
you referring to the individual referred
to as black Buffalo that's correct
and so uh speaking of that
um black Buffalo became very angry at
what he perceived to be an incursion
into his territory began yelling pulled
a crowbar from his truck pushed a female
uh actually into you that's correct as I
understand it correctly
um would you agree that that's a fight
I think it could have become one
but we were able to move people away and
de-escalate the situation you're uh over
your times I would just like to add it
based on my experience in policing
especially my time as a general duty
officer
I suspect that Mr the man who presented
himself as black Buffalo
was uh suffering from some mental health
issues
okay uh and just one last question you
also dealt at the insistence of I
believe Keith Wilson with people at
Coventry Road referring to themselves as
Sovereign citizens who were deputizing
themselves and planning to arrest peace
officers correct I never dealt with
those people I received word while I was
at the Swiss hotel that that was
occurring
and so and and the information that I
received is that someone was pretending
to be me and deputizing people and so
the people at the Swiss Hotel took
photographs and maybe even a video of me
to have proof that I was currently at
the Swiss not
falsely deputizing people at Coventry
Road and so I called
one of the uh gentlemen who was a point
of contact at Coventry Road and asked
him was this taking place and he knew
nothing about it but he was in I think
he was in a tent or a shelter of some
kind so I asked him if he could go
outside and check he went outside and
checked and confirmed that there was
nothing going on there I did later
end up questioned by the I think it was
Ottawa Police questioned me about that
and I relayed the same information I
just said to you
okay uh so just one last question these
examples that you and I have just
discussed uh in your view are they
examples of a peaceful protest
well I don't believe any of those
instances resulted in any real violence
thank you those are my questions
thank you next is uh Council for former
Chief slowly
foreign
thank you commissioner
retired Corporal bulford Tom Curry for
former Chief slowly a couple just a
couple of things that many many of these
questions have the other questions I had
had been asked by my friends
um could I just ask you to look at the
statement that you prepared with us
please
hrf1553 Mr registrar
just when this comes up I just want to
go please if we could to paragraph 19.
um when we get there I I hope we find uh
there it is maybe 18 if you don't mind
just a little higher thank you
I think you told us that you emailed
an introduction to those representatives
of the Ops RCMP and PPS
early in your tenure with this with the
Convoy
and identified
who you were and what you were going to
do is that right yes I did and then just
scroll down if you don't mind just you
see the sentence please rest assured
all organizers of the Convoy group are
operating under strict strict
instructions at every single person
involved must be respectful and lawful
at all times and that was your mandate
from those with whom you had been
dealing
that's correct yes that was I mean I
would not have been involved if I didn't
think that was going to be the case one
of the challenges is as you've described
that this was a very difficult
organization that is the Convoy in its
largest sense to have any command or
control over yeah I I don't think we
actually
without any official authority of any
kind you know you're not operating
within a police organization or a
military unit
you're trying to do the best you can as
a bunch of Civilian volunteers to make
sure that people are all on board with
the messaging yeah and and try as you
might and others have testified to this
try as you might to have imposed a
requirement
for respect and
for conduct that is respectful and
lawful you weren't always able to
achieve that goal Fair
I think we did a very good job
considering the size of that Convoy and
that and the the crowds that that
protest generated but you weren't always
able to control the conduct in the way
that you might have liked
is that is that fair well sir honestly
my my intention was never to try and
exert control on people because I was no
longer a person of any kind of authority
in Canada
the the reason I ask is because at as
you watched this especially with your
experience as you watched the Convoy the
events of the Convoy unfold from the
earliest days when you arrived until the
end when when you yourself were
were arrested
um you must have had a sense that the
end was coming
through this public order exercise
unless there was some other breakthrough
is that fair
well
I don't think any of us expected this to
go on indefinitely but my understanding
was that we were trying to
take pressure off the city of Ottawa and
chief slowly right you know with the
negotiated deal that I learned about
after the fact and I was 100 on board
with whatever negotiations that the the
truck captains could accomplish and
legal team could accomplish with the
police
to
prevent a massive takedown of the Convoy
occurring I was in support of that right
because because in the absence of some
effort by the Convoy successful effort
by the Convoy organizers to be able to
eliminate the consequences for the
residents and the City of Ottawa
businesses and the like
you understood that it was going to come
to an end via a police enforcement
action
I knew that that was a possibility I
didn't know I didn't like I said before
I had hoped that it wouldn't come to
that
right and that honestly sir I was hoping
that the police would stand up with us
which would then basically be a symbolic
gesture
for the federal government that what
they were doing was no longer lawful in
Canada and they weren't going to have
the police as their enforcement arm to
do anything that was unconstitutional
and unlawful and not backed on evidence
which would require Police Services not
just Ottawa but OPP RCMP PPS all of the
other services who had come to help to
disclaim their their duty to uphold the
law you were asking quite a lot yeah I
was but it happened in Ontario earlier
in the declared pandemic when Premier
Ford tried to exert more power and the
police said no
can I ask a couple of other things then
just in the time remaining
um you you told the commissioner that
you upon arrival and getting this
underway you imposed a form of ICS model
or incident command structure to the
best that you could yeah I mean it was a
joint effort but I mean myself and a
number of others were familiar with that
system right and so it was it was
brought to our attention maybe we should
set something like this up because the
first that initial few days was absolute
chaos
and to whom then did you bring if you
were were you at the top were you the
designated Incident Commander no sir I
was not who was
well Mr Guerra was in charge of adopt a
trucker
and then my
the overall
if you want to call it Incident
Commander volunteer was a former Ottawa
paramedic got it and then Mr Garrett
would he have
taken Direction strategic direction from
the from the board of the co of the
Convoy Corporation once it was
incorporated
or were you aware
I would say that's accurate because our
whole purpose of being there was to
support the truckers I mean it the whole
initial mission was to provide you know
food and shelter and uh transportation
services to protesters was part of your
effort in the the within that group The
Incident Command group to keep track of
the the number of police Personnel who
were on the scene
no sir okay no I that that was not
something that we were interested in I
mean the police were going to do what
they were
what they were gonna do and we were
trusting them to do their job then just
finally a couple of things if I may if I
could Mr register I'm sorry to drag that
document back up one five five three
thanks so much and if you could go to
paragraph 99 just want to get your help
with with one one thing please
these go to the events of February the
15th
um
and
describe you had uh a visit at the Swiss
Hotel described here
in which uh OPP
and Ops liaison officers attended to
meet with volunteer coordinators and Ms
Leach where you you were one of the
volunteer coordinators
yeah I was the volunteers volunteer
security coordinator and and who were
the other volunteer coordinators if you
recall with whom that meeting or who
attended that meeting well that was
myself Tamara Leach and the the former
Ottawa paramedic okay got it so three of
you and three police Personnel to the
best of my recollection yes and it was
at that meeting that they attend they
you've written that they attended to
discuss the recent document provided by
police to Convoy participants and that's
the document that laid out that the
emergencies act having been declared it
was now required that people vacate the
the uh the protests set fair
well it's more nuanced than that because
when I reviewed that document I know
which one you're talking about it had
the red border outside of it
we read I read through the criteria
and
I don't think any of us in that room
with those liaison officers met the
criteria laid out
in that in that document from the Ops of
people that were
no longer permitted into the downtown
right and what you engaged with I won't
read all of it but you spoke to the to
those officers to express your concern
that that the growing that the use of
force by police against the peaceful
protests without negotiation was was
wrong and they ought not to do that yes
fair I didn't and then and scroll down
if you don't mind please just to
paragraph uh 102. now that we're on the
17th
um and you had an encounter with another
officer or detective Benson uh to who
replied to your query about being
whether you were uh on people were on
the lookout for you
no Mr Benson contacted me by text
message after Tamara leech had been
arrested okay thank you and
um
you had an exchange with him I'm just
interested in the second last sentence
he responded by saying that the
occupation was beyond a protest and the
trucks had to go
and you replied to him that it was not
an occupation well my belief that a
definition of an occupation is usually
like a foreign military has taken
control of another country right
it was it did you do you now accept
thinking back about it that from the
perspective of the the residents of the
city of Ottawa the Ottawa Police Service
that the protest
embedded as it was
was
the equivalent of an occupation no I
don't agree with that okay
now uh final final thing my friends
asked you about uh whether you had
information from active serving officers
or service Personnel of the Ottawa
Police Service or any other Police
Service
um you tell us tell the commissioner if
you know in respect of the information
that Mr Wilson had am I right that so
far as you know the information Mr
Wilson had was the same as the
information you had that is only from
retired that is non-active for police
Personnel
I can't say that for certain because Mr
Wilson spent the majority of the time Mr
Wilson was at the ark hotel and the
majority of the time I was at the Swiss
Hotel all right thank you I don't have
any other questions
thank you next if I could call on the
Ontario Provincial Police
commissioner I have no questions
okay thank you for the Democracy fund
jccf and uh
citizens for Freedom commissioner Rob
kittridge for uh Justice Center we have
no questions for this witness and to the
extent it may be necessary we'll see
dark time to Mr Miller
okay is it Convoy organizers
for the record Brennan Miller uh Mr
bullford I'm counsel to the Convoy or
sorry Freedom uh Corp uh who is the
entity representing the protesters that
were in this city in February and
January of 2022.
good evening
um commissioner just freeze of reference
what I'm continuing to do now just to
get to the point your Council have been
excellent in educing evidence in Chief
and I'm just going to deal with
examination uh from the questions that
arose from the other parties and so I'll
try and be quicker now for you so they
won't hear many complaints I think from
the hall on that but thank you very much
it's of course your entitle your time I
just think it's helpful so there's a
couple things and there will be a couple
documents that arose that are in the
system already from my friends
questioning I want to put to you but the
first thing I'd like to ask you about Mr
Beaufort is
Parliament protection services this is
of course to most Canadians
a sort of Police Service that nobody
understands and nobody knows much about
what can you tell me about it
well after the October 22nd 2014
shooting at the war memorial and uh Mr
bibo storming the center block
there was a big review afterwards that
took place because there was three
different agencies that were responsible
for security on Parliament Hill
and they were all Amalgamated into the
Parliamentary protective service so that
they would have one cohesive unit for
the precinct right and can you tell me
who does the parliament Protection
Services who does it answer to
well when I was working
they I still believed they fell under
the rcmp's command but that may have
that may not be the case anymore they
may be completely independent now right
and the RCMP command then that falls
under
um commissioner lucky that's correct and
is it fair to say that from what you've
seen from being within an RCM from being
within the RCMP and seeing on the news
that you've witnessed or heard of uh
commissioner lucky relaying public
messages on behalf of the elected
executive branch or relaying information
that the political executive branch
wants to relate to the public
yes okay
so
uh the next question I want to bring up
if I can bring up document uh 7722
underscore Rel dot zero zero zero one
Council are you referring to uh text
messages text messages yes so it's gonna
and I'll have to get the other one too
so it's
7724 is the next one just so you know
now I'm not sure if you were present or
you had watched
um this part of the hearing when I
referred to these text messages
this is a text exchange between one of
the staffers with the prime minister's
office and another one of the staffers
with the minister of public safety's
office okay
and
this is in in this context uh the
staffer with the prime minister's office
states to the staff are with uh Public
Safety Minister's office
that
got a quick response people are into it
let me know if your boss is too boss
being the minister of Public Safety
happy to help however I can this is what
I sent through by the way hi I just had
a chat with Alex at PS being Public
Safety uh who had a bit of an
interesting idea as you saw in the Pod
goals chat the trucker Convoy and some
of their more extreme comments calling
for January 6th style Insurrection are
getting more coverage in the media Alex
was surveying whether there would be
some interest in his boss doing some
media on this eventually
he was chatting with uh Medici medicinal
uh about it right before Mendocino sorry
about right before about it right before
he went into a cabinet Retreat and can
you agree the cabinet retreat was on
January 24th were you aware of that
that sounds accurate yeah of stuff 2002.
and
there he goes on I think there could be
an opportunity to get in on this growing
Narrative of the truckers particularly
with the research that lrb is doing into
their backers do you know who the lrb is
no have you ever heard of the liberal
research Bureau while you were on the
hill no okay
and my thoughts of framing here would be
similar to what the PM slash Blair being
Minister bearing the Prime Minister said
last year when January 6 occurred and
the first point is our democracy is
something we need to nurture and protect
every day and then if we could bring up
the second uh part of the text message
at 7724
and then it goes on
um and this is the points that are being
relayed and or that is essentially going
to be the narrative we will always
support the right to peaceful protest
and some of the calls that organizers of
these events are making are concerning
and will take them seriously would need
something to back this up
we'll continue to monitor the situation
closely the fine line to walk would be
to ensure we are not looking like we're
directing the police which obviously is
not the goal here hoping to Canvas your
thoughts Alex said he'd come back to me
with a proposal this afternoon when he
gets to chat with uh
Mendocino again obviously pending his
bosses in our interests uh in looking
into this further so that text is to
either the prime minister or someone
within his office
and they're explaining what Alex uh the
uh chief of staff for the public safety
Minister has come up with and key
response thanks I had an initial chat
with my boss and he's supportive but
wants to wait a day or two there's a
danger that if we come down too hard
they might push out the crazies being
I think you have the Far Far extreme
fractions online they were talking about
I think that's fair um she responds
apparently global
and others are working on stories maybe
we see how those land
so
you had mentioned that you don't trust
Legacy Media and you mentioned Global
News and that's one of them yes that's
true okay now
I've sent this around I'm not going to
try and move this article into evidence
at this juncture
but did you know that the following day
Global released a news article
titled January uh sixth event or Jed
that there was a gonna be a January a
potential January type six event on uh
the odd during the Ottawa Convoy and
they managed to get uh Parliament
Protection Services to comment
and what was reiterated was one of the
points in that text message
so again I'm asking you
if the government
was going to try and relay a narrative
from your experience from working on the
hill in law enforcement would they use
something like the Parliamentary
Protection Services to relay a narrative
I I can't say for certain I've
my all of my experience with the
Parliamentary Protective Service is
I've never I've never seen anything
political from them because they're
they're Limited in scope
okay
and so the Parliamentary Protective
Services
um reiterate and I'll just read it in
I'm just trying to pull it up again
I'm not sure you got much uh
from the witness about parliamentary
right so in any event I'll deal with
that
um there are going to be lots of
witnesses understood later uh understood
so you can use your time but yeah
um so
moving on uh essentially the
Parliamentary Protective Services in
this article states that they're wary of
the security and they won't talk about
further matters in order to keep people
safe I'm just summarizing it we'll put
it into evidence through other Witnesses
but is it concerning to you that
you know coming from this issue with
misinformation that you're concerned
about you've testified to that
the exact the elected executive branch
has identified knowing about news
articles what they're going to be about
before they come out
and what's the evidence of that
directly in the text messages they said
that Global's running a piece on it it
was on January 24th of which that was
and the news article I'm speaking of was
on January 25th and then parliamentary
Security Services
says essentially the byline that is in
those text messages sir and I'll put
that into evidence and I'm just asking
if it concerns him if that's the case
just trying to understand where the
evidence is for that yes it's the text
messages so you have the text messages
between the the staffers with both the
prime minister's office as well as with
the minister of Public Safety they then
say what the narrative is going to be
they then say that Global is going to be
running this story
and then when Global runs the story they
quote parliamentary Protective Services
citing basically one of the lines in the
text messages sir I'm not sure I
understand the link at all in the way
you describe it but the record is clear
so we'll leave it so uh with respect to
that if that is the case is that
something that concerns you yes
absolutely okay
and moving on from that point
um my friend brought up with you
the issue with respect to danger of
people staying and the advice you were
giving and everything and I'd like to
bring up Ops document one four five zero
four please
hmm
do you recognize this document yes I do
and what is it
it's the document that
the opp and two Ops Liaisons brought to
the Swiss hotel right and in reviewing
that document does any of it therein say
that all the protesters have to leave
no all right and so was that one of the
documents that formed your understanding
of what was to happen
I thought it was just reinforcing
Justice McLean's
decision that as long as we abided by
those three conditions of
no one coming to Ottawa to commit
violence
do not block critical infrastructure
and do not disrupt trade we were still
considered a lawful protest
and the people that they were delivering
that message to such as myself and the
others
didn't fit into any of those categories
that I'm reading here
right and with respect to the position
they're in that says they need to move
their trucks
you're not contesting that that was
going to have to happen
no okay and so when you talk about
lawful protest you're talking about
people
actually physical people human beings on
a street protesting is that fair
that's correct okay and so it was your
belief and you were advising Canadians
to come to Ottawa or to stay in Ottawa
in order to carry out that sort of
protest
you know I had to it's David
mitchikovsky
um I hate to spend more time on Friday
evening of everyone but we really are
getting into Crossings
that's fine I'll move on
um leading questions thanks so if we
could please bring up uh OPP document
4286
okay so this is the document
um that my uh friend puts you it's the
operational plan and if uh uh Mr Clark
wouldn't mind scrolling down to page 31.
it's it's not 31 in the documents or I
don't know it is there we go perfect
so if you can just take a moment to look
at that Mr bulford it's a script for
arresting for lawyer for for arresting
protesters
okay all right so you can agree the plan
was is that the protesters were
essentially going to be released with
just a court date and some release
conditions as soon as possible they
weren't being put before a justice of
the peace or a bail hearing that was the
plan yes all right and so
other than Tamara Leach and Chris Barber
do you know of anyone else this plan
just wasn't applied to
where they just got a promise to appear
with conditions undertakings
and
you know they all got they they didn't
get massive
bail conditions imposed upon them by the
crown or on behalf of Ops do you know
anyone else other than those two
individuals who wasn't released under
this sort of release plan
well I know at least
Pat King yeah and his friend I believe
his name is Tyson Billings yeah we're
both incarcerated for an extended period
of time was anybody else that you know
of
foreign
I've heard of other people that were
were charged but I don't know the
particulars of their release okay
thank you those are my questions thank
you okay any re-examination
no thank you commissioner okay so thank
you uh you're free to go thank you sir
so uh we've completed the list for today
and uh we will uh
come back on Monday morning at 9 30.
the commission is adjourned the
commissioner